foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the Lord's day let's talk to y'all right
quick how we feeling out here
how we feel it out here what's going on
around I see y'all bright and early top
of the morning so this week almost the
afternoon what's going on let's do some
roll calls in here some mic checks the
geeky to her in here early
he likes the topics blade X King he said
we caught we got the MPD numbers for
November we coming okay Lydia Master
what up I imagine what's going on okay
Asante my bro what's going on talk to me
let's let's get it live Supremacy what's
up Thomas More films what's going on
Lloyd Metroid talking that Elden ring
Game of the Year talk IMAX what's up
brizzle
uh black conflict X hungover what
happened to power to the people
hustling motivate thank you brother
appreciate you appreciate you out of my
chat see what's going on out here Sith
Lord what's going on Thomas what's up
man James Lauren said what's up David
hot right what's going on salute salute
salute yeah we got some fun things to
talk about this series huh
gonna be in a building excited addicts
in the building attic talk to the people
[Music]
[Music]
I couldn't fit enough words in it to be
honest with you that's that's literally
I had to do some abbreviations of what I
really wanted to describe you got to
work with me you understand the uh the
overall essence of it so anyway yeah
Judas look amazing yeah yeah I like the
way that I was looking so yeah we're
gonna get my man
punk soda OG podcaster now
finally making his debut in the room we
got some fun James eggs to go get the
rest of Lords in here and we're going
through this thing for real so I will be
back
and uh get ready it's gonna be a show
today
trust me
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm anti-social or my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got you that's
[Music]
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just to
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when he was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but a man talk social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable why can't
it be and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
and we are alive I Am Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
game in we don't use coffee anymore
we're utilizing this focus on Deck
number two you already know it's my
favorite right here the energy line you
already know birthday cake one of my
absolute favorites completely delicious
this is a pre-workout equivalent and
also doesn't use beta Adeline so you
don't get the Jitters and stuff like
that so it's really good for that and
then the new new we got that hydration
line y'all this is really good for
people who don't like caffeine who want
an electrolyte substitute and it is
really sugar-free absolutely delicious
so you got your three choices once again
you know Cog lover is sour you already
know and we're doing this right now so
go get yourself to advancedg.com use
code iron Lord on the checkout this is
something I use all the time got to
support Advanced EG great products if
you want to get your workout on even if
you don't work out you're just gaming
you need that focus and again the
hydration line for those who don't want
caffeine no sugar electrolytes you're
good to go lower Cognito here iron Lord
podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on the Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
hot bike
VHS
Calvin got it for the seals welcome to
the high levels podcast LLC and also
live on lordsofgamery.net episode number
284. that's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table of the
Lord's day I'm very excited for our
special guest and we've got the
FTC blocking Microsoft's acquisition of
Activision we blind backers damn 70 Xbox
games and our game awards recap to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who is not
only a true story in video games and
podcast culture but whose infectious
positive energy always radiates whether
it's balanced and well-informed gaming
perspectives
introducing the co-host of living split
screen and a panelist of the shop Xbox
Factor Xbox ultimate and the PM in the
PM podcast
the Lord of podcast guesting and
appearances
my fellow Sega Bridget and turn-based
whose gaming Soul was forged from that
OG essence of Paul
live from Minnesota and finally making
his debut into the realm of the Lord's
my man Lord pong Soul how we doing sir
pinch me pinch me pinch me I'm actually
I'm actually here I'm actually on the
iron Lords after all this time Cog I'm
finally here wow what an honor to hear
your introduction for me like honestly
you guys you don't know um every show is
special to me as I was telling you guys
in the background like if I get invited
I get invited every single one humbles
me more and more but there's certain
ones that are special because when I
will get into it but when I jumped in
the community in the chat you guys were
one of the first shows that I played wow
and you guys have been an inspiration to
ever since I decided to start doing this
process your show
um your camaraderie uh obviously those
deep friendships that you got I mean
again I'm jealous of that because I
never had that so I watch you guys I'm
like oh man this is great all of that uh
makes this even more special when I show
up here so thank you for the invite glad
to finally be here what a week
so
yo we got a break protocol real quick
someone has returned I'm sorry Paul let
me go get your flowers
why do we have to break bro we got a
great protocol this is something we
haven't done in a while baby let me play
with your joystick five dollar Super
Chat my baby song is a winner as
expected thank you thank you appreciate
that I have a prize for you of your
upgrade okay
[Laughter]
you know normally uh since a lot of
people in the chat probably don't even
know uh my you know what I'm like I'm a
grazer right uh that's Microsoft's
internal word for somebody who plays a
lot of video games uh may not finish a
lot of video games but plays a lot and
that's what I'm about at this point in
my life like I just like all the
experiences so normally I come on here
with a list of like 10 12 games but but
one game what's this one as grab me
what's this one and this is my now
favorite game of 2022 out of the blue
I was off of this game uh when they came
out with the card based system right
right I was hype I'm like oh for axis
yeah cards oh no and then I started
watching more and more started watching
their Dev uh Deep dive and I was like
okay I'm back on I'm back on I think I'm
gonna trust for access to do this right
and again you guys gotta know I'm not a
superhero guy like that I used to do
Comics Uncanny X-Men was my jam back in
80s 90s right I'm not there anymore I
don't watch Marvel shows or anything
like that so superheroes don't do much
for me right jumped into this game
it's like three games in one yes and
it's crazy I know it's not gonna be for
everybody but for me it's like the
perfect mix I can't stop playing it [ __ ]
and I I know you've been playing it too
you know this you know the Spider-Man
mission is like oh yeah mission right
fourth or fifth mission
I took I was 30 hours in before I did
that oh you like me doing the same thing
I'm doing the strategy layer the base
layer I'm building stuff up because I
know how far axes do so I'm not
advancing the story I'm doing the sound
[ __ ] yeah you know what it is that
you use a turn-based vet continue yes
yes absolutely so I've been just
enjoying the mix I mean even you can't
even say that they're doing anything new
like the RPG elements are like from 15
years ago right yeah but it's that Loop
that gay nice like day and night cycle
yes that's got me and I just got into a
good pattern of you know you get to you
get your pattern of everything that
you're gonna do get your relationship
building are you doing your attendance
you're getting your Tinder on you you're
hollering at people
you know so I'm doing all of that right
it's funny right right exactly like what
you said though is for Access you know
what's coming yes and so I like to build
up my characters prior to getting into
one of those situations where I'm in
trouble right so absolutely so yeah no
it's been midnight Sons I did play
through the first part of chained Echoes
which is dropped onto a Game Pass okay
it's got a 91 meta old school 8-bit
16-bit JRP what did you say that was on
Game Pass sir oh excuse me we want the
score you want the score no no no no no
no no no no no no
game yeah uh chained Echoes oh did you
have to pay any money for that sir no
sir it's Game Pass
and you were just like surprised look at
this oh here we go oh man that's how
game passes so uh listen yeah no so I
played that uh well worth it if you're
an old school jrpgs and you want that
all feel the story so far just the
opening intro is about now 45 minutes
long or so fantastic that's what I've
been doing absolutely shout out to do
gays [ __ ] dude you say what's up
Lloyd said happy Sunday everybody except
pong
slanderous mouth
watching you kneel yeah
real quick uh King did you see what they
just announced
uh my hero is coming to fortnite my hair
oh wow
so Neo what are you pull it up oh
I'm going to put
this way Neo don't be like me wanting
wanting the Naruto skins when you
eventually start playing fortnite okay
we it's a club you're coming eventually
you might as well get in there and get a
little Refreshments ready man pre-order
so some skin so when you decide to come
to to the greatness of fortnite you
already have it there you see what I've
done he said I'm over the age of 12 so I
don't get excited for fortnite all right
okay
shout out to my man John Wolf up in
there I see you he he's the one getting
you in a hot tub I'm not boss all right
[Laughter]
those original Lords of the realm here
at the round table my co-host Nicole
Mouse my brother from another Mama the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf Lord
addict of the attic show how we doing
sir
doing pretty good you know I've been
playing a lot of Tactics Ogre this week
like you know uh uh I still so far
I still prefer tactics Final Fantasy
Tactics but like what I do like about
ogre is like tactus is kind of like
conditioned a little bit like they kind
of know exactly how you want to fight
certain people obviously you can do
whatever you want but when you fight on
ogre it's just like we gonna over we oh
you you used to fighting six seven
people nah that's just the opening scene
here it's like how we get it set off
it's like it's like oh you don't think
this is fair there's 30 people tough
luck place that's how it goes I'm like
dude there's like there's like for every
four there's three of them like no mercy
they brought tactics over over back like
intact they didn't they didn't they
didn't they didn't bring it up to Snuff
when it comes to like modern stuff like
it's like nah it's just a little bit
prettier that's it Tactics Ogre is a
beast in the game
it's you know it's it's why the Final
Fantasy Tactics is the goal because
learn from that
we agree
yeah I I still enjoy tactics more
because I feel like the the class system
was a little bit more well thought of in
that one like I'm not saying the classes
when this game's bad it's not by any
means so far but like I I will say that
I felt like the class system was like
more customers uh customizable like the
way you want to play the game than it is
in that game but I I've really been
enjoying it unfortunately it's not on
Xbox so you know uh I've had to uh Bank
Square yeah so you know I right now
currently I'm playing it on um what
you're playing it on on PC the Lords of
uneven business
because at this point I'd rather I gotta
I got a deal on PC so that probably
helped out but because
you know how much I'm loving this game
let's be wrong here this is not a 60
game 50 or however much it is like it's
kind of crazy that these these Studios
try to get like that type of money for
games that look like it was made when I
was like a teenager
but that's not a bad thing that's just
it's a remake of an old game and it's
just like I don't know how much the game
is not for you but it's 60. oh yeah see
see it's 60. it's about it's about 30
dollars too much like I think it's 60
too much because you got a little
spoiled with the Game Pass thing didn't
you oh no I don't mind uh you know I
don't mind IOP paying for myself he's
doing on the bank quick
I don't know
today has been it sir
uh that I try to jump back into Destiny
um it was a it was like a rotating door
it was like I walked in oh cool
y'all retired but I don't know we're not
retired I think to be honest like
fortnite beads
I'm going you see I play
I just
I gotta agree like no I I won't agree
with certain people in the destiny
community that I watch that say the
game's dead like I will admit that I
didn't know that the the numbers were so
low but it's just like I these people be
acting like we ain't been here before
like the numbers Get Low next expansion
drops it's it's higher than it's ever
been like it's just like like I think
people need to realize there's other
games besides Destin it's okay to cheat
factual it's okay no one's gonna say
nothing
who plays attacking so much finish it's
crazy
yeah but it's just like there's other
stuff out there to play you can go out
there and play other stuff and you know
pop in I used to try to do the seasonal
stuff I don't even care about that
anymore it's just like I'ma show up do
my high y'all out the front door do that
raid when the first raid pops off on
that one and then I'ma quietly exit out
the back door when that's open like for
that experience in that new rate we
already know what it is shout out to fun
speculation I see you what's going on
doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gaming
list for the single players oh let me
say something more real quick okay I I
do want you guys
I understand that this is gaming and the
thing that me and King does is like a
different cycle but I'm telling you like
right now we're getting the Kinks out
worked out and I think once we figure
out exactly what we want around the show
I think you guys should give r r a
chance like yeah because you know we are
when does that happen I heard about this
it happens Tuesdays at 5 p.m I already
know with the Lord's okay give it a
chance they need to be there
we'll see like my goal is to get the
Kinks out before like phase five like
really starts out the gate you know what
I'm saying because I feel like that's
when you know it's gonna be the peak uh
and you know we we got a little thing
going I I want I watched uh King's anime
so we'll see how that goes yeah
then no Kinks
dude trying to get me to watch some old
stuff man good yeah okay true good well
buddy
ninja scroll yeah
yes yes yeah the overview let's get that
whoa whoa whoa that will be exclusively
on patreon
demon city
of the damn game awards
my brother and rightful Champion Lord
Sovereign how you doing sir
you know what's sad I looked up
the wants yeah and he would have won
even if he won yeah
if he would have went with his heart we
would have went with our heart so he
still would have won wow
[Music]
what's funny is like I put like a Italy
system I think next year I'm gonna do
the tallies but no one can see them to
the end
the pressure is dead I love the way I
like it yeah people see the numbers I
feel like there would be more pressure
if I like for the for the audience we
don't want none of that FTC crap
transparency no behind the scenes we
want to see your paperwork outside
anyway so what you been up to man have
you guys got any chance she's freaking
crazy yeah working crazy this week was
uh was Lady SOB's birthday so he was
celebrated a little bit thank you
fantastic we celebrated on Thursday a
little bit and then Saturday was a
little bit of a surprise took her to go
see MJ on Broadway
foreign
that show is something special man the
Michael Jackson uh Broadway show is uh
really something special like
obviously like his music of course is
kind of transcendent
um the the the people that they got to
play him at different points in his life
to young Michael kind of Michael going
into like Thriller
and beat it and stuff like that and then
and then older Michael
um and that that actor actually won the
Tony award earlier this year for that
portrayal
um yeah those dudes look nice fantastic
show it just you know again you you move
in you bump into all this stuff and then
I think the most beautiful thing to see
was the diversity of faces in the crowd
when you look around
my wife Mike started off black but he
ended white dog man
realisticness
the Gap himself
pigmentation Moving on but it was it was
a it was a special thing to see because
my wife and I was six we were on the the
orchestra like fourth like fourth row
and like six people in in a row so to my
right was an elderly white couple and to
her left was an elderly white couple my
wife and I were bumping you know but
them they were rocking they were like
and I'm like wow I'm gonna use the power
of his music you know what I mean music
this is
[Laughter]
I did a little bit a little bit more
Callisto protocol a little bit more evil
West not much to say there
um it's funny because people describe
okay yeah I get it I get it for
something I want to finish it out but
it's funny because I had never I heard
people uh describing the Dodge mechanic
as punch out and then when I looked at
it again I'm like yes it really is punch
out so it's some weird stuff in that
game could be better I hope they do fix
only things punch out about that game so
I want to punch myself
foreign
I don't think yes no he didn't have to
play Punch Out oh okay yeah yeah oh
punch out you know we should know him
please
the last thing that I played was the
forespoken demo oh thoughts let's go
let's go
no talk about the unspoken graphic uh
undergrade wait wait what's up
all right I had kind of been I had been
rough on on news media um on gaming
media kind of like being super critical
extremely hard on it hard on it
especially because of the writing and
the voice act yeah and I hadn't heard
enough of it to really be that outraged
by it obviously they played more
whatever so I was just like I've been
too extra
you know you know when we were young and
you you used to curse all the time
because you thought it it made you sound
older and and like mature in this stupid
way yeah exactly exactly
but you know what it means like you
thought you'd curse at any chance you
got because you thought it made you look
cooler and older
it feels like that like she drops
f-bombs in situations that are not
necessary like I need to act asleep
go get some sleep
go go Dina fire it for no reason huh
okay and the tone of the voice she
sounds like I'm gonna be okay I thought
he said the voice Act is British
okay she's British she sounds like I
just don't know what they were thinking
you know there's some very high profile
people it is it is the district
the game looks beautiful the world is is
an open world is I don't really know
what's going on so they just kind of
throw you into these in this scenario
and uh they show you like the combat
stuff and whatnot okay and the combat
stuff seems cool but it's just it's it's
fantasy so it's fair like the you know
the the enemies look weird and stuff
like that it's a fantasy world I don't
have a lot of context for what's going
on so I don't know that I care yet
um when it comes to the combat the
combat seems cool so far like so she
wields magic so so far you have you can
pick between two different types of
magic one seems to be more projectile
based the other one seems to be uh melee
based right okay and you can switch back
and forth between them you have uh
certain Magics that are um sort of
defensive Magics or they allow you to
sort of stifle the enemy and then you
can attack them with some thing right so
it's a back and forth between that and
between the different magic so seeing
cool it doesn't the the lock-on mechanic
feels a little bit weird doesn't always
seem to work
the traversal stuff is cool like it you
basically you basically hold down a
traversal button that kind of allows you
to I don't know if you've seen in videos
you can go up Cliff faces and stuff like
that okay yeah so it it
parts of it look cool I just don't know
what I'm doing yet nor do I care about
this world
um and it sounds it definitely sounds
like a PlayStation endorsed game it
sounds like I'm gonna wait and see
um
so it has three performance modes right
okay all right it has a ray tracing mode
which I don't know if it was engaged
because when I went to it I didn't
really immediately see any uh like
changes in Shadows it was the that's
this new movie
jumping in right then take our word for
it it's working
yeah it's 60 FPS and they had like a
regular just uh like whatever like a
detail mode yeah yeah um so that that
seemed cool
um again the character turned me off
really completely
it really like like the it she sounded
she sounded like a like a like an
African-American Karen oh okay wow and
she does not sound young she sounds
angry and jaded and like just sarcastic
in a mean way so just it's just that's
right because it takes a lot for you to
be turtled just by a character banter
character yeah
you feel you feel that it is it's been
warranted no it ain't even about being
woke up sound good
where they got the archetype for this
like this is what a young New York woman
for the right pool yeah
we shall see fair enough family now
hopefully it sells no doubt and that's
what it served yes sir and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer the prophet of Xbox Swami
King of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience and is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
ooh beloved okay how are we doing first
of all I'd like to apologize to
everybody who showed up last night for
combat talk with the King and we didn't
have any combat talk we did small combat
talk with the UFC but I want to right
now say
um
ESPN yeah
I kept trying to switch you know so we
have the ESPN joint and I kept trying to
switch to the regular ESPN it just kept
circling like it wasn't working it
wasn't working and somebody told me to
go through the the Hulu app but
didn't have the whole list so it's
whatever that didn't happen all right
the BLK Prime I paid for BLK priming you
know I was gonna hit the bank up after
the fact you know just hit me up
yo that is the worst app ever I don't
know what buddy was thinking I don't
know they lost a ton of sales
you want to debut himself on
what was gonna happen yesterday but we
know what you up to but you're trying to
to use smoking mirrors for the app
though let's get to that so the app's
not working though all right so he just
worrying about people in the building he
didn't care about the app he just wanted
his money right this is the most
ignorant mismanagement of your career
that I have ever seen this is how you
tank your career let me give you a
sobering
word of advice let's go
yesterday's Finch was in a car accident
right
again a terrible car accident wait wait
recently again Yes again oh no I didn't
know right listen to this he was driving
in his bulletproof car oh now everybody
that knows a bulletproof car is
reinforced steel from front to back
right side to side all the windows are
triple five graded pain glass
so the cause virtually indestructible
when he went on his live and showed his
car his car was destroyed yo what is he
a 14 year old kid no no took his parents
car or stole the car
um allegedly mm-hmm
was going at a high rate of speed and
ran straight through a red light and
smashed his car head on okay Jesus if
Spence was I don't know what what what
type of
um otherworldly thing is chasing this
man when it comes to cars because this
is his fourth car accident car accident
since I've known uh you know
he said if he was in his other car that
car he would have tore through the car
bro he got so many signs bro he got a he
gotta get the hell out of Texas yeah
it's too much get away from Texas those
dudes as well but I say this to say
there's a lot of times where we supposed
to have fights and stuff supposed to
happen and you keep pushing it off for
whatever reason or another fact and it
doesn't happen yesterday you saw the
mortality of this situation and
ebenezian the the super bump could have
actually probably slipped on a banana
pill and knock butt out right anyway we
got a lot of fights that we didn't get
because dudes was messing up the money
but stop messing up the money stick
inside the ring getting the ring and
stuff could have happened yesterday so
I'm glad everybody is okay everybody got
out of that teal female again bum
bashing shot that was special good fight
um I got a chance to watch some UFC okay
uh so I watched till versus uh oh damn I
forgot the other guy name explain this
first
but it was entertaining and I got off
that but next time PVC stuff I got you
guys I do apologize listen we got over
500 the Lights 100 people you walked in
the door hit that like button wipe your
feed off and share it out with somebody
we're about to talk to porn soap Yes
what I've been playing but you've been
playing sir Fortnight did the switch
over fortnite has uh released the full
Suite of Unreal Engine 5 uh assets
inside the world of uh well epic release
inside the world of fortnite
luminese and Global illumination and all
that stuff and in that nights everything
that they talked about in those demos
that you saw with the girl jumping all
over the place is present in fortnite
right now so if you want to get a good
graphical measure have a good PC have a
series X or a PlayStation 5 and even
Series S is showing you those things the
game looks phenomenal I got the
Incredible Hulk Skin
Man attic was playing having a good time
monkey and I was playing uh it's so much
fun we love you neo to just come over
here and hang out with us I've been
playing Vampire Survivor now I've got a
little hack anybody's want to make it
further inside vampires look at the
secrets and the unlocks and then all of
those rules there and you start to
unlock things and I did it yesterday
it's a lot that game has so many layers
this man was a genius to after you feel
like you're a little bit bored trying to
figure out what you didn't unlock go
figure it out and it's more hidden
character I got this weird dude that
shoot well uh rail cards at people
and I was like who is this dude the game
is incredible it keeps me uh addictive
addicted to it um next week we have a
whole bunch of Game Pass stuff dropping
so I can't wait oh I'm gonna stop being
like Kratos from taking up our time
let's go
real quick King I you know I didn't play
I didn't play with any unlocks the first
month I didn't know no I didn't know the
characters
you know when you're able to buy stuff
yeah I didn't I didn't do any of that
the first one just went off the rip
that's crazy yeah he didn't see what he
was doing like it's so much stuff it's
very addictive no doubt and of course
it's me they gave me ninja
spread that realism gonna tell you which
whatever what you need to hear shout out
to my man Maddie plays man we did the
fun and do it we had a lot to talk about
obviously game awards obviously one of
Xbox's most interesting weeks you talked
about that uh obviously um ultimately we
hit the 70 games right which we will hit
also later shout out to my man Tyga
Chopper shout out to bonds just doing
that Destiny thing talking season of the
serif very positive impression so far we
like what we're seeing and as far as
games shout out to pong man I'm with him
midnight Sons got me all the way live
bro like it is just a complete it's
three games like I said it's it's the
gameplay layer of of just a plus you
know turn-based action with a different
spin you know the heroic system using
the environment to your advantage
movement placement got me like it Miss
Marvel King you know I don't like
Captain Marvel like hey at all Cog talk
about that bro once I once I could
change her hair because I put the
classics oh yeah absolutely yeah I got
rid of that hair I don't like
so I did that and then I'm doing the
joints where you do the knee you get the
um the armor she becomes tank then you
get a level three she becomes binary she
is a beast then you get the thing where
you ever get the thing where it if you
you get hurt a taunt and anytime yeah
the enemy's Direction goes to her and
then she get a plus one counter so every
time she get hit she respond she get hit
she's shooting full-time blast oh yeah
she's just straight when people left and
right Doctor Strange is ridiculous oh my
so I got him right now Doctor Strange
got some joints that's going on crazy
but I go for a kid to Joy that's gonna
get you laugh is the base layer the bass
layer basically that's when the
tindering going on
when you read the messages
do you have time tonight and I was
figuring you know if me and you could go
that joint is hilarious but the story
itself is great and to be honest you're
the main character the unique character
is extremely good like I'm very
impressed yeah but he's very strong and
and you see where the storyline they go
with that so I've still been rocking
that Destiny new season and then um
Tekken 7 on Steam deck I've been really
sharpening up for reasons oh I can't
wait yeah we get to the Game Boy section
I have a sharpen it up for reasons you
know what I'm saying what's up let's get
these uh super chats and we get uh bring
pumpkin bet no doubt
okay we have Donald taku 10 super chat
shout out to Nintendo taking home best
action game and best multiplayer game
shout out to Game of the Year Kirby and
the goaded lands if you have a family
they also got a strategy they got Mario
oh yeah that's right that's right they
did that how did I know something you
didn't know Donald talking
if you have a family that means Kirby is
the best unless you're an orphan
then we got drawn TJ five dollars good
morning Lords High panel High pong there
will be no ps6 and the ABK deal will go
oh all right all right confidence let's
go then we have the Don cjg with the
four pound 49 Pence Super Chat I
dedicate the Super Chat to my reformed
podcaster Lord Cog wild reforms that is
it's a play on the the kid that went up
afterwards
let's put the crest in the chat for the
newest member Tom from tooname
yeah salute salute then we have Sith
Lord remember for two months two dollars
for chat fortnite is going beyond plus
ultra
um
any game they could do that really yeah
that's my hero uh quote okay okay and
they they like consider like if they go
above their beans that's what they'll
scream that [ __ ] dude like
then we have THX 1138 two dollar Super
Chat steam deck love Square Enix yeah
then we have Spartan go 17 two pound
Super Chat ninja scroll and underground
classic GoGo 13 as well I forgot to have
the gold one logo 13. that is a hell of
a game on the
um yes
cinematics was crazy yes
I know who did also uh loaded pixels
yeah Donald tackle five dollars for chat
why ain't y'all get free R Kelly on the
show to promote his new album from
prison
love to my brothers thank you guys for
another song thank you
then we got THX 1138 again two dollar
Super Chat for spoken equals forgotten
for the payer wow okay wow we'll see
then we got Jim dance move gym dance
Ryan's right yeah two dollars Super Chat
how much for addict to get destroyed by
punch out oh no people willing to pay
attention I don't know the name has to
be yeah like the community what's this
I do enough for the community it's fine
uh Stitch is asking you something about
something about how they faked the nose
for the Michael Jackson joint or the
show he's oh no his no he has he the the
the my the main actor miles Frosty he
has like a kind of a pointy nose Okay
absolutely yeah States you got your
answer continue
then we got yummy
five dollar Super Chat hello Lords I
hope everyone is well y'all are the best
gaming podcasts thank you much love when
are you guys hosting another Community
game day playing Halo was dope next
Saturday well yeah yeah that's right
yeah absolutely next time most likely
next next Saturday yeah um we have some
requirements though um because we have
asked you guys and I've asked you very
nicely now I'm gonna have to do uh how
Chris does and tell you my whole life
story
what I need you to do is I need you to
go to Valaria
fellows please yes please links it I
need you to get those pillows out
because uh my mom's raised me and I
didn't think that I would be anything in
this world
sale two uh make sure that uh Al Pacino
let me give you a hug you gotta slow
down a little bit King you're going too
fast yo play the music play the music
as I take the time out too as hell
everyone how I feel about how life has
treated me
all right
please
you know he's never won anything before
that's why and and my for my next job I
need a YouTube please please you know
what's funny
when they did the
the music because that's the first time
we've heard the music wrap it up I
didn't realize that they were using that
to rush people off to stay yeah hurry up
wrap it up B so I was thinking that they
were using to like like
Dramatics
you know what's crazy that that was one
of the criticisms last year right yo you
got to let these people talk right he
does it right off the door
you know what it probably was I bet you
Jeff was like Chris come here Chris
comes over there like I want you to take
like 10 minutes on a speech are you sure
are you sure Jeff he said I don't want
them to ever complain I don't give you
guys
get all your balls off nah they had to
talk to him after the show they had to
rush the rest of them
did you see what he said on Twitter
he got rushed off the stage
yeah Russia he didn't have time to thank
his wife I like I like this I like when
Keely was like yeah he was trying to
sell some extra steam decks yeah yeah I
picked that King he had like a sniper I
think they did the math it cost him like
an extra like ten thousand dollars for
him to do what he did anyway yeah take
it out of the the GoFundMe phone no
doubt
you gotta do that yeah we got uh Jay
Rembert five dollar super tattoo pong is
a pillar to the Xbox computer right
then we have uh Harge to knee five
dollars salute to the Lord's hey pong
where Eternal comes to PC how is this
possible what about the great power of
the Immaculate SSD I'll give you a
message
told you it wasn't real
cycle gamer five dollar Super Chat I
feel like Microsoft gets an L for having
to offer its competition a 10-year a 10
plus a year deal for something they
spent billions on this is wow that's
psycho I would say that David is in a
minute I mean I'm gonna tell you right
now their plan was it's too much easy
money for them I don't think they would
ever think about taking Call of Duty
anyplace else it's just too much money
10-year plan from the beginning they
just will get into it and the final one
uh put the crust into Tapas Cedric age
members for 29 months
I really uh it's it's nice
on guarding them
this is for attic to play Punch Out we
need this coming through strong yo they
look like
yeah
we need a pretty pillow
we need three pillows for that so I'm
going to have my paper
don't listen to him
at the top go to the link at the top
just call it Lord 15 get that 50 off
that velari guys
punch out if there's five pillows we got
you on the three don't worry about it
no if the community wants this nonsense
thing that's three buttons you're gonna
you're gonna pay for it yeah you're
gonna see at it no see see I know they
ain't doing it oh you tested
Community after okay
three hours
please
I want him three hours on glass Joe he
said on glass not
glasses
yeah he played the original the original
with Mike Tyson in it with Mike yeah
yeah
all right hold on we're going to put the
link in the description
It's gotta it's got to start by today
I'll give you guys so today until
Tuesday it's 700 people in there
okay I think attic actually wants to
play this he's doing way too easy no I'm
just trying to sell pillows
here's the thing
if I gotta sacrifice my Saturday playing
this old ass stuff people gonna pay for
it listen he's one of those guys that
you have the gun on him and it's loaded
and you can say
oh my God
it's not gonna happen yeah y'all know
what to do get them yeah punch out still
plays great though you won't have it for
life
they're talking all this stuff and none
of you can
he died
he'll beat last joke
you guys want me to box a hippo
his name
he gonna put your things
it's a wrap hey what's that sound when
you get that down
your citizen said don't look it up on
YouTube either at it
yeah yeah that's that real OG gaming get
him yo links in the description
hippo we don't know them he don't know
the better
say that I know what to do I gave y'all
every
everything yeah we got we got uh
yeah baby five dollar Super Chat Phil
said at the game awards with the mad
face and watch PS games Win award after
award I was mad AF I don't think he was
mad
at the um at them winning anything I
think he he was just sitting there at
the level of hypocrisy of the people
that's around him that said probably
something to him in the background but
sitting there shaking people hands and
clapping
y'all work let's go and we got David hot
right two dollars per chat punch out
with the OG and yes
no no no not no modern fangle stuff
little squared boxes okay so the bank
gotta go order the bank gotta order that
yeah yeah the bank don't have to do
nothing
that's it we go now
all right
so I guess he's been very patient
this is all part of the experience
we gotta turn our attention and focus
the Lord Palm Soul his video game system
history his journey into podcasts and
content creation and of course what led
him to co-hosting living split screen so
love Paul let's stop at the very
beginning man what's some of the first
video games you got started with what
got you the game
well look buckle up at it because we're
going back to the Stone Age
get him sticks and dots baby uh as the
name States I started with
I'm sorry that was funny it was funny he
turned it over that I'm sorry that was
hilarious that's some young ignorance
right there but okay educate the boy
educated boy yes so uh yeah no pong uh I
go all the way back uh and uh some of my
earliest memories actually
um because uh my grandpa actually had it
at his house and so my dad would get me
on the weekends um and we'd wind up uh
over my grandparents house uh which was
close by and uh they had a little 12
inch 13 inch black and white TV with the
pong paddles hooked up and that's where
I got started uh and uh as I tell the
stories
um to other podcasts and stuff it's
um like I said it's it's I lost my
grandpa when he when I was about seven
or eight
um so I don't have a whole lot of
memories right and I lost Grandma when I
was like 10. so those are like some of
my earliest memories of course you know
fishing and everything else is in there
but pong and then Atari with the oldest
memories I've got in a lot of ways so uh
yeah I go all the way back to that
um and then right into artari 2600 right
yes sir
um Atari 2600 again at the grandparents
house my mom my step dad weren't about
the video game Life for a long time so
you know I got to experience it outside
so you had to go over there to get that
yeah it's like me I had to go to my dad
to get there yeah yeah and my dad was a
graphic uh designer oh okay so he you
know he was he was still I'm actually
using his drafting board right now as a
desk um his original drafting board so
he started long before computers but he
was always interested in um and he was
always into art and all that kind of
stuff so he was always interested in his
electronic medium that was coming out of
nowhere and what they could do and stuff
so that's kind of where it really began
for me because I had somebody else who
was highly interested in it as an adult
so they wanted to buy it and play it
with me so you know me my dad bonded
over that a lot in Atari 2600 listen
you can say what you want to say but we
wouldn't be here right now without Atari
man uh in fact Nintendo before Nintendo
right so Atari set it off even though
they almost destroyed the industry
but you know you go back and you look
you know you call you know like combat
like Pitfall Pac-Man uh Adventures
no alligators in the water and all that
that's right and you could go backwards
yes
that was like one of the first times
you've ever seen that frog did you get
Tarzan I know never got Tarzan it
actually had the oh yes
how dare you
yeah we're just like football
yeah
uh I learned how to play Blackjack on
the attack
at a young age hustling yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that stuff evolved very quickly because
you had competitors that came out and it
wasn't any unknown competition
situations going on so are you implying
that the industry allowed competition
because you had Domingo you had the
Commodore 64. you have coleco Vision you
had different variation of these games
and then they will all make this the
same game up to the capabilities of the
machine right right so it wasn't no
gimping somebody it was like yo your
machine could do it uh let it run let's
go oh yar's Revenge oh my God that's
amazing right yeah yards Revenge was
great too
um and shout out to you know the worst
birthday gift ever in the history of my
birthday
ET
baby E.T I still remember opening up I'm
sorry for you you fell into that pit
right a million times a million times
and I swore this was gonna be the time I
was gonna get out right we kept trying
it over and over again you know you
watch all the Reese's Pieces you know
the counter count down as your head was
levitating you up towards the top did
any of y'all beat it Daniel you can't
beat it I beat it you can go beat it it
really sucks but you can go wow I
thought the glitch was the pit nah you
could you can get out the pit and you
got to collect all the pieces of the
phone and then go back to yeah you can
win no see that nobody else I had the
patience yeah
there's no without so that was the end
of the uh video games
um actually that was really the complete
and that was the crash yeah right so the
crash actually happened and from that
crash Nintendo saw the void yeah if it
wasn't for Nintendo we what we're not
future that's huge Atari actually
finished us yes yes yeah in the West for
sure
yeah because you had NEC over there and
um they were battling Nintendo we didn't
know anything about what they were doing
over there and then Nintendo saw the
void over here and brought the NES over
here which was called the famicom over
there actually so it was like at least
two years ahead yeah in
um in the Eastern Market and we were in
Western Market two years behind very
much so sorry Paul no exactly no no the
history is great because a lot of people
don't hear it all the time right I don't
understand where we came from that's why
it's so important us old guys bring it
and tell it like it is I appreciate that
um and and speaking of it like in
television and ColecoVision never owned
them but I had uh family friends and
cousins who had those so I got I got to
experience the other stuff too as well
outside of Atari and then of course
during this time you know a lot of the
rise of the arcades right yes sir you
know if we went if we weren't going to
my grandparents house my dad and I would
go to the yard
right exactly so
um that was huge for me as well just
being involved in that I mean that goes
back to the you know the Tron our kids
yo exactly and pinball machines my dad
was a pinball fanatics
but you got you know you got all the you
got all the great art
games at that time so we're called
Pinball Wizard sir
disrespect us he's not yeah Aficionado
he's not an arcade Master he's not a
problem
is crazy
it's crazy so yeah so the arcades uh
were all always always a part of this as
well throughout this whole process right
and that was huge yeah because that was
a whole that was a whole different realm
when you walked into an arcade like the
dark seed and then I just got hit one
second because what people fail to
realize is that the arcade was next gen
before you got it right you get to see
where technology was going because this
looked way better than the things we had
in our house there was a disparity
between the the NES
those consoles that was the next gen
right exactly it was like a nightmare to
have to go out to see next gym
we used to leave our house
that's the problem with the youth today
they don't want to engage anybody else
I don't even like engaging see in the
podcast
I can't even pronounce that well
actually I could this is the only time
in history where I can easily pronounce
all these games
y'all was sit there and stream on
Twitter all day y'all won't go outside
this is see that's the difference we
lived in an active hostile environment
right so and the best part about it is
you learned your place in this world in
that arcade
in the pecking order yes right because
if you were seen as somebody that can
handle theyself you walked in the arcade
with no problem
you got next if you was the dude
we didn't go to therapy we did our
things yes
people got punched in the face
facts you learn right there how to
interact yeah
and be respectful yes even in defeat and
I'm saying and you knew who yeah
obviously you'll be disrespectful you
could get jumped if you're not no don't
out the door everybody with the cool
kids to jump people
either jumper or the jumpy
so anyway but you had to get nice man
uh in community community and then you
get friends and you see that people
remember you from last night
this is good stuff
um the other thing about their cage too
uh when you walked in you always knew
when the new game had shown
that's right you're the first time
because because again we didn't get
information the internet didn't exist so
we didn't know but also you walk in the
arcade and here's 20 25 people standing
around yeah around and everybody's like
oh that must be the new game and you
have to go over and you'd be like what
is it what is it what is it right and
then you find out and you're like okay
how many people I gotta wait for here
and you know it was like a whole it was
a whole different world and experience
to walk into an arcade for all of you
guys just pointed out let me ask you a
question yeah because I always ask
everybody this that's a arcade head yeah
and it's and it's when you're walking
because this was the most vocal arcade
machine I've heard at that time
when you walked in and you heard Daytona
oh my God the giant machine and people
were sitting down in it and it was uh I
think it was two dollars to play where
we were at
and the graphics was immense the
soundtrack was crazy it was the loudest
machine in the store the most expensive
machine to store like 30 grand a machine
what was your experience when you saw
the first Daytona live listen
um because we we progressed through the
arcades right like at first it was you
know most of them were all stand up and
then slowly but surely like afterburner
came along you had to sit down and then
it started moving right then you got the
movement so then when we started getting
the big screens and the multiple you
know setups all linked together Daytona
listen when you walked in you saw
Daytona uh it was a different type of
experience because I first of all I I I
really like racing games right I'm one
of those guys so being able to sit down
and see something that was so far
Advanced from what we had gotten at home
right that was always that arcade
experience like again like you said COD
you were experiencing the next next gen
of what was coming right because it
didn't it took a long time before
consoles started catching up factual so
it was crazy when you first sat down but
yeah King to your comment that overload
of Senses in that game from the the
noise to the music to just seeing all
the big screen and and how fast
everything appeared on screen right that
was something else that was something
that's why I said it was important to me
because they had so many of those type
games from hang on I remember to outrun
hang on remember you go to hang on the
super hanger you see the speakers on the
thing you jump on the bike
and I was like damn why is the sound so
I felt like you know
it was just so overpowered it was an
immersive experience and I think Sega
was very you know very dominant in that
space I think that's when we learned
about about development teams yes
because that's the first time I learned
about things yeah
factual continue sir yeah shout out to
them so so yeah so then we get into uh
the NES uh right the NES shows up again
I don't have my mom and stepdad just
weren't into video games right so I
still didn't have a system at my house
um and I remember what was going on with
my dad at the time I think he was uh in
between wives at the time so uh things
were kind of mixed up pop dude Rolling
Stones
so you know
um I had to experience the NES for the
first time just friends and um you know
that was the other thing that you guys
always talk about right and again I
didn't have a group of friends like you
guys did per se that weren't that into
it but I did have friends that liked the
video game
um you know and we had moved out to the
suburbs at that time from the city so
you know I was getting to know new
people I happened to get in a group with
some
upper middle class to rich kids out
there right well off individuals yeah
they got everything right we had kids so
he was my brother-off individuals I was
like what are we getting next yes
exactly that's the way it was and it was
like
yeah yeah you know my one friend for
sure who had everything was like Hey man
uh you know you know you want to do
sleepover at your house and I'm like
yeah I'm coming let's do a sleepover
it was every weekend right so let's go
um so yeah so he had the nesque he had
the power glove he had robbed oh he rich
rich yeah
yeah yeah oh he's Rich Rob the robot and
all of it right set up so um and then he
had like one of the projection big
screen TVs this was like Silver Spoons
exactly why didn't want to sleep over
anybody else I was here got all the
snacks we got Joe
so NES
um again this is where I fell in love
with jrpgs especially right
um this is when I got my first
experience with like Dragon Warrior
which we all know is Dragon Quest now
you know Dragon Warrior the first one
the first Final Fantasy
people act like it's not a Nintendo
property and it's so funny yeah organic
Nintendo obviously somebody stole it
yeah
so my buddy was into him too and you
know and DND was big around this time as
well we had a little DND group so we did
all that so that's and I was a ferocious
reader at the time as well um and I read
a lot of fantasy so all of a sudden I
had these games right that I could like
I'm like oh man this is like Fast we've
got dragons We've Got Elves we've got
slimes you know we got all this crazy
stuff so me and my buddy would sit and
just trade off the controller back and
forth in a lot of those games but then
of course on top of that it's got the
sports game oh yeah you know and you get
you're getting you're getting double
dribble double dribble yeah double
dribble this is probably the height of
my oh yeah and he has basketballs oh
yeah double triple hell
um and then uh of course I was huge in
the football so Tech Mobile oh the heart
the heart the Hut yeah
and then you get you know then with
techmobile the thing was right so you'd
be sitting around the lunch table of
course that's when competition started
really kicking yeah right you had your
boys and and you were you were talking
to them and you're like oh man I'm gonna
get you back this weekend well then
certain people will find out about you
know Secrets yeah so sir buddy plays
yes money Players yeah yeah yeah yeah
shout out to Bo Jackson
OH hustle said if you knew about if you
did a little bit of baits of steel or
was it not not too much oh yes
of course man being able to fight in a
hockey game are you crazy
stories what stories yes yes so uh so
that became huge uh for us right and
that was like okay all right so this is
where I really started falling like in
love with video game like this is where
it starts cementing itself nice because
you know you got that camaraderie but
also you know you got that single player
experience as well and eventually my mom
caved right eventually my mom came you
know and and got me and my sister
you got the basic got the basic drink
got the basic no doubt no doubt so we
didn't need that little robot yeah we
need to we don't need no light gun we
only know robots
well I mean we probably had duck hunt at
one point okay but
um so we got that and so then I got to
really start playing a little bit more
now she cut you know she watched my time
when I was up here when we spend two he
had to go outside right yeah yeah um you
know and during this whole time too I
should say too that I was uh I was a
sick kid from the time I was born until
my 20s right so I had a lot of medical
issues allergies chronic bronchitis
asthma you name it so Sports I tried my
hardest right I played a lot of soccer
and stuff but um sixth grade that was
over with
um I couldn't do it anymore it just
wasn't worth it right it was so
frustrating so video games right video
games and books you know I had to be
that guy because I couldn't be the
athlete I couldn't you know I couldn't
do it so you know my time outside I did
still do a lot of time outside
skateboarding and that kind of stuff I
got into all that but video games were
always there for me and that was really
the start of it right
um so we got into you know me and my
sister bonded over like Bubble Bobble
bobble bubble Jam right yes yes that was
awesome
you know how much money I put in that
arcade machine
it feels like there's just regret here
and not enjoying
earlier
[Laughter]
a legendary yeah that game was amazing
amazing it really was
um so gradius too
oh my God I'm Gonna Be Crazy
Life Force life force exactly and all
the little balls hanging behind your
ship and you're shooting two poles
exactly the power-ups were amazing yes
sir so yeah no I had obviously NES
monster I changed everything like
Kingston
industry did you stay in the NES realm
what was your next machine after NES was
it uh yeah
let's go get to the real part because I
know his history
he talking Golden Era talk and people
understand any yes was so
yes it was they were I guess you could
say even more than the PlayStation was
you know now at this time like well
considering the amount of people playing
video games right it was if you
considered video games Nintendo at one
point like guess how it is because it
was an open market they came in the
market when the void was right and what
they delivered was first of all they
delivered the two-player controller
situation yeah yeah right off the rip
right right and then the the 8-Bit chip
that was on the on the board
was greater than any chip that was
inside any machine that we had in the
house right because the sound chip was
on the board as well so we had Superior
Sound Superior colors Superior graphics
and speed at that period of time they
opened it was an open void remember the
market had collapsed over here and they
were thriving in Japan but their main
rival was NEC NEC didn't make the travel
over with the turbo Graphics so after
Nintendo put a foothold here and then
the Master System didn't do anything
yeah
so let's get to the part where I want to
know right after this what because you
know where we going
let him cook
listen I had the uh I should also
mention my rich friend oh yeah I had the
unfortunate pleasure of being able to
play the Virtual Boy
played that at King's house too
exactly never ever again the only
problem is it was only one color come on
yeah
anyways in between yeah we're getting in
between so what happens in between too
um is that uh now again my mom and
stepdad against a lot of stuff right it
was really hard to convince them on
things well I had gotten into some
computer classes at school again people
nowadays are like oh that's a big deal
back then that was a big deal right a
big deal especially I was going to
Catholic school so they had to spend
extra money which they didn't normally
do right so they got computers so I got
into a computer class and something I
convinced my
went out and bought the Apple 2gs wow
one of the last apples before they fell
under yes literally under a year later
this man this hot my hard-working
stepdad is his soul too right working
his butt off right you know we were
middle class whatever else my you know
all that stuff it was different back
then right because money was different
so my mama's stay-at-home mom but this
man went out damn and he and he wasn't
uh my parents were into classic cars
right so I grew up around cars so they
built cars and all that kind of stuff
this man went out and spent like three
G's on this thing and apple goes under
[Music]
um
you want to talk about the nail in the
coffin when it came to Tech for this man
I was over with it it was over it was
like a year later right yeah it was like
like a year or less than a year later
when we went out right and we bought
this thing so anyways I had like at that
time the Apple II GS was like one of the
top line computers right so so I got
into a little bit of PC gaming this is
like one of the only Parts outside of
other people's houses and stuff like
that I play PC a lot right so but I did
I got to mention this part because the
two games that really again I talk about
my early High School my eighth grade
early high school years might magic two
oh Diablo five or British himself yes
um man these two games again when it
comes to RPGs of course white magic 2
was the corridor RPG right in uh Ultima
was kind of the precursor and you hear
Todd Howard talk about this online too
to the Bethesda style yeah American
World kind of you can do anything you
want to you get thrown in jail if you so
happen to have a pick lock you can pick
your way out again and then you're
wanted right all that kind of stuff so I
played those games non-stop like I can
close my eyes and I can be back there
there music same thing with the music I
was listening to at the time in excess
uh you know Run DMC hello
right now let's go oh yeah oh yeah so I
had to point that out because it is
important part because that man that's
when I became like again I was like in
like RPGs I'm done this is this this is
like a level yeah next level stuff
um and then to King uh let's get here we
go King so
my next system was the SNES was the
Super Nintendo I did state
but let me tell you something so what
happened let me tell you I got a job at
Funko land shout the Funko land before
shout out to Funko land before GameStop
right it was Funko it's there it's Funko
land I got a job at Funko land so I had
my uh my Super Nintendo let's go well
obviously yes stop stop I'm stopping you
you're about to launch pad off I know
where you about to go I think I know
where you're going too but but the first
thing the first thing
to jump from the area
the the chipset the six and they they
had a separate audio again because they
did it again
all right what was your first games with
this this magical console that you had
like the first for the first night just
the first night was a wreck that's just
a Super Mario
it was Super Mario for sure again this
whole brain don't work too well did you
get razor no I did not get the ACT razor
until later I got act razor eventually
but um it was Super Mario Brothers I
can't
this is going to set it up yeah
all right we already know the graphics
looking crazy because I know that's
visually that you was like oh my God but
the second to none part of the Nintendo
was that chip the sound chip yeah when
you went down in your first tunnel under
underground you heard the echo on your
joint what was your young face in mind
like
uh mind-boggled uh right I was I was
wide-eyed at the leap again what you're
what you're getting at King is the leap
between Generations back then was so
ridiculous like it felt like a whole new
world we got a new system right and I
100 agree so every time I got a new
system back then it was like that first
time you even the powering up part right
because the Super Nintendo was so
different yeah even from just the box
right to to what we had in the NES with
those cheap little power buttons
like they're gonna pop out anytime it
was cheap you got that Super Nintendo
that thing was solid right it had the
purple premium yes and it had it had
switches and the first time you flicked
it on and you heard it power up but yeah
the sound from Super Mario was a whole
new but even visually to the clarity was
just starting to increase right as we
got up in the bits and all that kind of
yes it was amazing King and those
moments like I said you every time you
got something like that it was such a
special time I agree man there was
nothing like it when I first heard that
Echo because that's what you were
reading about yeah people don't
understand we got three month four month
old information for that new magazine we
didn't get daily updates right so you
get that new magazine you'd be like oh
oh oh they're talking about the CH and
at least for me because I was old enough
I didn't just read about the games or
look at the pictures right I was reading
about the business side of things I was
reading about the technology side thing
so I was like oh man they got a new
sound chip oh my God I can't wait to see
it no and of course writers back then
they were the same kind of I mean we
call it clickbait on the internet they
write these they would write these
dramatic articles right about how great
things are going to be because
it's gonna blow your mind yo blah blah
um so yeah that's that's exactly what
happened with the SC uh with the Super
Nintendo is uh I got into the Funko yep
get the Funko right and of course
first time I I get my jrpg love in
secret a man of yes
over with right Breath of Fire
right all that kind of stuff so I'm
loving the Super Nintendo then I get the
Funko land right yeah and I've been
eyeing the Sega Genesis this new 16-bit
machine because I never I never did
experience the Master System at all
right so I I see the Sega Genesis and of
course you know Sonic and it's starting
to blow up and I get the Funko land and
and of course you start playing
everything at Funk correct right because
you're working right and this is this
this is this is back in the I don't know
what Game Stops are and I'm sure there's
some Game Stops that have really cool
managers let me tell you about my Funko
land manager dude's name was Don I still
remember to this day
Don Don had been a stock broker had a
heart attack at age 35. so his doctor
said you got to get out you got to get
out so what does he do he comes and
manages a funk
dude was one of the coolest guys you
could ever ask for his boss so
when we closed up shop that wasn't the
end of the night oh y'all bust out the
Jersey
that's fine yeah that's fine and we had
one of only two Neo GEOS yeah me too I
had one of only two for kids
and the whole Bronx the whole Bronx was
one it was his and the one that was at
the Wiz at the store
oh yes yes I know about his Elite
privileges the thing was so expensive
nobody was ever going to look like
dictionaries games we had five games so
we closed down the shop plug in the Neo
Geo with the sticks okay I'm curious we
had uh eight man after you remember that
yeah eight man after yeah what else we
had we had a couple other ones that I
can't basically yeah baseball baseball
Stars they had a real crowd we were like
that's a crowd
yes exactly so we do that but then of
course we were playing the Genesis right
and man when I first started playing the
Genesis when I first got to play Sonic
right and uh see the speed on screen
that's the process oh man there was
nothing like it I wound up turning in my
super nintendent
yo that's that moment back in the day
though when you know your joint is like
inferior and you see the new and you
look at your jelly all right what's got
to go
yeah right in the house and said okay we
got to get money together
you betrayed your loyalty is betrayed
when you see that new hotness you
betrayed all your oats all right I could
get credit for this and then I can get
credit for this right right and I had to
do it right I had to do it so I couldn't
stand it anymore course of Genesis had
been out longer than this time but I
just didn't have any real hands I had a
little bit of hands on because I had
some buddies with it right we were
playing you know like uh Joe Montana
talk football and all that kind of stuff
white so so I had my whole time but I
didn't have like a lot of time sit down
but Funko land I got I mean
I kept playing this game I kept playing
these games over and over again then I
saw like RPGs like Fantasy Star uh you
know landstalker fantasy
with the isometrics
Lance talker was uh sega's answer to
Zelda yeah yeah amazing game underrated
game okay yeah I can understand that now
like
some random names like you say you say
land stalker I'm thinking like you
stalking languages
worst decision I'm sorry I'm sorry you
have more fun because you got a chance
to put all the games on Sega listen
there's no doubt the sports gives us one
better on Genesis the sports games
Superior and we haven't even gotten to
Mortal Kombat
yes Nintendo was really for the single
player experience in the corner bodies
right that was yeah you're seeing the
same Trend now and then Sega was more
about friends and fun
system two player you know they they
thought was always around the two player
but go ahead because you said Sports
would would have made your decision yeah
yeah Sports and Mortal Kombat but
I get a side point I love Sonic at the
time
fantastic I was having such a good time
and not that the Super Nintendo wasn't
giving me fun but again back then it was
at that level of fun
stop bleeding the witness I had to make
a decision right so I made a decision
and um it winds up to be that uh I get
the Genesis and I never look back again
so Genesis comes out I'm all in on Sega
right and then she hot I'm still working
at Funko land when the Mortal Kombat
launch date I put them side by side was
that 1993 I think
so Monday yeah
Monday so I'm at Funko land so we get
the boxes of games right beforehand
we're opening up
while we're at the store getting prepped
right people don't understand again
midnight launch is another thing that I
hope yeah it's it's so sad back then it
was crazy right and Mortal Kombat though
was on another level people had been
absolutely drooling over this game in
the arcades and then it was announced it
was coming to console and then word came
out
Nintendo is gonna have the red blood
sweat
sweat listen if there's been a time in
my life when I was a fanboy it was this
bad because man when parents were coming
in to buy their kids maybe a super Nest
yeah I'm like you don't want this your
kids are going to be upset
like you don't want it I'm like you
gotta get a Genesis I sold so many
Genesis during The Mortals who was out
here doing the Lord's work
give them that Superior product with the
fatalities in the blood I love it we
gotta have it but that was one of my
greatest memories of all time from there
um was Mortal Kombat launch and then the
after hours parties but we had we had um
NHL
94.99 oh man I mean the greatest hockey
games of all time
Eternal champions
oh man did we love that game
we had hope for that it just didn't know
but it was still fun King and then we
had our Neo Geo time and we had all that
so that was a great time in my life but
that really is
yeah he was but he was so cool because
he'd give you advice you know I'm you
know I'm 17 18 years old he's giving me
advice he's talking to me I didn't
listen to most of them but you know what
I'm saying but he was just one of those
cool managers you didn't ask for a
better manager man I cared about you you
always talk to you about stuff and then
had all this if you slow back rubs
all right
he didn't have the black calcium
no no
it sounds like that episode of Different
Strokes
hey Mr Don what's his name
all right so so yeah so that was that
was like I was it uh I was Sega from
here on out right so now we get to the
point where we start getting fun right
now this is when things really start
changing right because we start getting
we start getting into change in
technology right cartridge to discs
right we do all this kind of stuff and I
can't forget Sega CD was in there too
right I picked up some Sega CD love my
second CD of course you know sewer shark
sewer shark uh you know Sonic CD you
know tell me it wasn't the biggest most
robust thing no King I waited I did not
get this oh you ain't get the big boy
because then what I did was I upgraded
my Genesis remember the slim down
and then it's side by side oh yeah side
by side okay okay
you know all that stuff was just so
beyond anything we had seen especially
like the live action stuff we looked
back at it now oh so cool it was so good
now we thought it was revolutionary
come on you just wanted to see Dana
Play-Doh yeah
um stars
associate themselves
this is like the first time we saw real
actors from teams from movies yeah being
associated with what we are playing
right so it felt
um Next Level it felt like this is
happening this is the jump off like this
is the leap right this is going to be it
we're playing like reality games now
right yep
[Music]
so we go from there and then you enter
like of course the 3DO Atari Jaguar Sega
Saturn PlayStation oh yeah Nintendo 64.
we get into that era 3DO it's like 1000
no no I'm not doing the 3D oh I'm not
doing it I had a friend who had one got
to play a little bit of it right but I
just was not feeling it right but
but uh
one of my biggest mistakes and really
started making me but it was a Learning
lesson right as long as you learned
something this is where I started
protecting my pocket
32x 32x no no I went and got the Jaguar
you know me you know me old school yeah
I believe I believe
yes sir did you learn how to fly
the worst that that AVP was hot though
that's what I'm gonna say
AVP show up bro but that struggle to get
to that one year that one
I Am Soldier yes
it was a giant Soldier cyber morph
Trevor mcferr
and the Bruce Lee Story yes
oh my gosh the most disastrous yes
console
terrible when you got it in the house
and you opened it back you knew the
cardboard the cardboard on the box was
weak and then it came in uh a cart
headquarters yes yeah that's when I said
oh no this is
we almost we had to laugh at someone
when they brought a brand solo yeah SOLO
brothers
and we is like oh this is the the 64.
but it's supposed to be dumbled into the
3DO is the best right we saw it out yeah
did it look like a toilet then
the CD portion of it right
it was a toilet bowl yes
so how's that experience it was it was
exactly as we talk about it right you
and you go through that you go through
that time when you spend that amount of
money and again I'm not yeah
I'm an adult but I'm still young you
spend that type of money on something
right but then you go through that time
period of time where you can try to
convince yourself
you're like you know your buddies are
your buddies are going I don't know
you can showcase to the homies yes and
the hobie's got the face on your brand
new purchase
you learn how to drive
regret that's the worst thing I regret
that's the worst feeling I did you know
so I went through that whole thing kept
trying to convince myself it was worth
it and then I did get a little bit of
recovery when aliens versus predators
yes sir that was good right right and
then you then I brought you know that
guy all my buddies back together again
I'm like oh no no no no no no no check
this check it out now yeah and then I
got to I got some oh wow oh okay this is
I'm gonna talk about it Aliens versus
Predator forever man nobody had seen
stuff like that it was awesome it was
amazing um
and then uh after that uh that was very
short-lived yeah that was very
short-lived right but then we got to
move on because some better stuff came
out at that time but then
um I was uh I was uh living with a girl
at the time one of my ex-girlfriends and
she wasn't a video game player but she
was very supportive of You Know video
game playing and all that kind of stuff
and she was a she was a really cool girl
back in the day like sports and all that
kind of stuff so she was cool we walked
into a mall and again that's another
um whole thing balls man that was a
whole different world too that people
don't understand right so we walk into a
mall back in the day and um walking of
course gotta do my rounds right so we're
walking to EB Games and see what's going
on so we walk into EB Games and I turned
the corner and in this back corner it
was around the corner one of the clerks
is back there and he's putting up signs
and I'm like no no I'm like no what's
this
Sega Saturn drops out of the blue I
don't know I had been reading about the
Santa course me and being a Sega guy at
this point right now I'm reading
everything I can on the Saturn I'm like
Oh my oh my God they're gonna blow the
industry out of the water you know all
this new stuff they did Pong they did
yeah they they did yeah
so I walk I walk in there turn the car
and I'm like are you I I I tap the dude
and the dude's putting up all the stuff
and they're just basically they haven't
gotten anything up and I'm like did you
guys get the Sega saturnan and he turns
around he looks at me and he's like yeah
I don't believe it either
nobody had a clue for anybody who does
not know
uh Sega had internal turmoil the
Japanese or the eastern and the Western
divisions were at odds they were at War
who was in the heart of that uh who was
it at the time oh Martin Cerny was in
the heart of that because yeah that's
right that's right sit back and go ahead
that's right so so there was a war going
on internally there was no communication
between divisions uh the the actual
development of the Sega Saturn was a
mess up until the point and some people
didn't think it was going to launch and
then they just shipped them like they
literally just shipped them out stores
got them and had no idea they were
coming
not not all stores got them that was the
big problem that was the other thing too
that was the other thing too they were
limited right soft they didn't yeah a
lot of stores got they they got shafted
when it came to getting any stock there
were specific deals with certain stores
I think it was yes was it KB that didn't
get any or something like that or
something like that and and they vowed
to never carry it they never did right
right exactly so I walk into the store
I'm with my girlfriend I look over at
her and I'm like the Sega Saturn's out
I had to grab it like the dude didn't
even have him out yet so he had to go in
the back grab the boxes rip them open
I'm just going oh my God I'm getting
like the first Sega Saturn let's go
probably in Minnesota right now like I'm
gonna go home like we still had shopping
to do and of course I'm just itching at
this point right but of course uh launch
games Clockwork night yes sir
um which was just cool right and your
Dragoon Panzer Dragoon the legend of
course which we didn't know what the
time was gonna be but the minute you pop
that in you knew you had something
different and then of course Daytona USA
busted version as well with the virtual
fighter but still virtual fun but still
right that was like arcade to home I was
like okay we getting you know close you
know right I played the Neil Young so I
knew but those were actual arcade boards
yes right right so we were getting
closer right so this was just a huge day
and I think I picked up a worldwide
soccer oh you remember I mean but that I
mean the 98 version of that was one of
those was amazing like 97 to 98 was like
regarded as one of the iterations yeah
it was regarded as one of the best
sports games period yeah
Saturn is what it is but I had a great
time with the Saturn right the Saturn is
the Saturn the Saturn is underrated uh
from the aspect that we got so it
depends what you liked right yeah
um it really does but jrpg wise yeah
yeah it's phenomenal phenomenal Shining
Force three Panda Dragon Saga Saga
Dragon Force DragonForce which was under
the radar um working designs by the way
the old publisher yeah a lot of these as
well
oh God bro and especially did you import
games did you import games
very special yeah if you imported games
because Japan kind of thrived with the
Saturn it was here that it just yeah
they didn't do yeah yeah it was Dead on
Arrival
um you know you got you got your shoot
em ups radiant silver gun came out on
the center which was absolutely yeah
ass I was a Shoot Em Up fan back then it
was amazing but you know like virtual
cop people that you could only play in
the game right you got the light gun
almost a direct arcade party I mean it
was fantastic right Sega bass fishing
right that kind of stuff showed up
eventually too so I had a great time
with the Saturn even though its lifespan
wasn't as long as it should have been
yeah and in the west like Saab just said
it just didn't take off it had too many
issues uh again another cell processor
type moment we're not Sega side when
they were trying to go to the you know
the separated boards right you know and
try to and everybody told them this is
going to be a problem they didn't listen
they didn't listen yeah that wasn't it
it was it was they couldn't afford to go
elsewhere I mean again
it was supposed to go 3D there were two
there were two skus they were they were
internally they were being looked at and
they went with the one that was cheaper
which was the 2D slash 3D one yeah which
they felt was still the way to go and do
this interim thing and even though they
still already had the 32x kind of doing
that and failing they didn't go all the
way with it and right this and then you
know the PlayStation came out and that
was the day
went full 3d yes and this thing was 2D
slash 3D and the problem was they were
saying that the the Saturn would be able
to do 3D I mean 2D that the PlayStation
couldn't do right yeah and then the
PlayStation came out and did capable
capable 2D right yeah the Saturn's 2D
was superior but it was it was superior
but the problem of it is we were already
going to 3D yeah the generation in
PlayStation
already had Superior their 3D was
Superior right so you saw a huge leap in
the 3D area against the Saturn and their
2D wasn't too far off from the Saturn
right yeah so and then Saturn needed
help with a ram card to even achieve
higher levels of Fidelity in 2D into the
OR Superior than uh Sony didn't need any
add-ons Sony had better marketing Sony
started doing things in the background
like we know them now
I mean it's true Sony bought certain
developers just to shutter them so that
the Saturn wouldn't have the devs like
they did that doesn't sound organic
they're not organic at all but we memory
hold that history right
I like that the OG is petty they hold it
they know the OG's knows what happened
it's so funny I said this you know what
it is it all that stuff it's it just
it's just an evolution of how it happens
in the scale to which it happens right
be within it but it's the business model
has always been the same hey yeah I love
it it makes me laugh when you hear all
this Purity talk about the right way of
doing things and I'm like we were there
fam like that it wasn't no Purity it
wasn't no cool body
get you out of there and if it means
blocking you on certain things it gonna
block you off certain things that's why
you are going to be a disrupter if you
are going to change an industry exactly
you have to begin you're not gonna come
in and get clean that's what I get I
don't even get I recommend them for that
no I don't they did what was necessary
back then I don't because remember and I
did this on purpose I stated in the
beginning it was open competition with
concerts from Atari to coleco
to to Amiga to Commodore 64. it was
getting where you fit in and make the
best games that you can right and let's
see what happens May the best one win
came in with an agenda to kill Nintendo
they were pissed off at Nintendo too
Nintendo
and they were able to help facilitate
the demise of the Beloved Sega at the
hands of pong so so what what I'm saying
is pong Sook just got exciting he just
got off the debacle of uh Atari Jaguar
yeah and he's got a Saturn because it's
a surprise launch he's surprised he's
happy yeah we're gonna go and do
something he got it sign him he got his
games tell me sir how did you feel when
the bricks started coming and Dreamcast
came out oh my god well uh obviously
PlayStation came next for sure right
PlayStation PlayStation did come next
again I I I've tried to own most I
probably own most systems at one time or
another right so uh Playstation uh blew
me away from the 3D aspect right
um again another Mall story walked into
the mall and right across from Aladdin's
Castle which was a big arcade yeah at
the time a lens capsule was huge next to
Circus Circus and uh Lance Castle is
headed there and all of a sudden the
Rotunda right out front of Aladdin's
Castle have been taken over by Sony it
was the and it was PlayStations
everywhere set up right and again had I
was like what is because I already been
reading a new PlayStation but I was like
what is this like they've got playables
here I'm like oh okay all right so we
forgot about the arcade pop over to one
of the stations in the first game that I
get to play is battle arena oh God yeah
over it was over I was like you got to
be kidding me I'm like you got to be
kidding me I left I left solved so quick
I left Vegas I was like I was like
virtual fight as a deeper game I don't
know but but then I saw it I was like I
get it
and I saw that PlayStation edition bro
remember dude he had the big the big guy
with the Big Valley or whatever his name
was
you take the CD out put your music CD in
yeah
I became the biggest Navco fan boy is
that yeah yep so y'all so PlayStation
was next and I kept my Saturn um you
know again I enjoyed way too many games
on it but then PlayStation really
started right PlayStation I mean again
you get your Gran Turismo
yeah you get you get your metal gear
Metal Gear Solid you get you get the JRP
you get like bagrant story you get
squeak it ends
[Music]
that's what I found out how far the
PlayStation was yeah in 3D yeah
did you go to Dreamcast yes yeah oh yeah
that's that's next it's coming up next
what's next that's next absolutely sir
uh siphon filter
yes you know tensions
before Metal Gear correct correct and
living that fantasy of being a ninja
like it was just so unbelievable
we gotta move along
punch out my attic you muted when you
said Punch Out attic was like bye
person you guys have said that I even
remotely know
we gotta speed up we gotta speed up a
little bit because we gotta speed up a
little bit okay
if they don't do this uh four scores
seven years ago American civilization
okay all right all right so uh all right
dream crash yes Dreamcast changed
everything Dreamcast was it I was there
at midnight launch for Dreamcast
um picked up that system brought it home
we played for 36 hours straight one of
the best launch lineups in gaming one of
the best launch lineups of all time
ready to rumble we could not stop
playing it was insane
um we had such a great time the VM used
uh plug-in setups like yes uh all of
that and we of course had dial up
internet right
Dreamcast changed everything green
Dreamcast by far change everything for
me first time I ever went online got we
got you know NFL 2K we got NBA 2K change
the sports scene completely yeah
Quake three oh Quake three oh Soul
Calibur Power Stone to this day is one
of my favorite Brawlers out there ever
right so you just had game after game
after game and unfortunately it still
wasn't enough right it still wasn't
enough no
um you know again losing out on the
Madden license oh that was tough yeah
it's a crazy story crazy story but but
just but just at that time we had we had
a bachelor pad I was living in a
bachelor pad okay right we had a four
Plex uh Huey the the building manager
was like 85 literally years old had no
hearing like the perfect dude we had the
other three we all became friends we had
some friends move in we had all friends
so it became the party place right and
so we had video game parties but the
Dreamcast was the center of a lot of
that right a lot of that now like a lot
of felonious Behavior
you don't even know kids
yeah
yeah
so it was uh Dreamcast against you know
again just changed everything for me
playing online for the first time again
the experience you will not awful awful
experience but it didn't matter it was
magic yes it was magic I knew that was
another person you were playing yes I'm
playing with somebody in New York right
now on NFL 2K right that's like crazy uh
but the battles between friends uh with
the four player controllers and having
NBA and NFL Legendary Legendary stuff
like literally just so much laughter so
much anger so much everything right yes
um Dreamcast it will always carry
special a place in my heart and I
absolutely love that the vmus changed
again about how you played football
because you were able to pick your plays
right yeah no she cheating no cheating
none of it yes so then uh you know after
that uh I'll speed it up here PS2
obviously PS2 came out had to get the
PS2 yeah yeah I had to uh there was no
way funny quick story about that is one
of the dudes who lived above us uh one
of them became a manager at a KB uh KB
Toys so uh for the PS2 uh midnight
launch I didn't have to go wait in the
midnight launch nice yeah I I talked to
him and he's like oh he's like yeah he's
on he's like as long as when I get off I
can come down and we can play nice he
goes yeah yeah he goes just come to the
back door knock oh you had the money
yeah oh yeah oh yes
[Music]
that's what it was came home played
PlayStation 2 and obviously the rest is
again one of the greatest lineups ever
in the history we'll never have a
catalog like that again of games
tremendously um just absolutely
phenomenal
um so the PS2 was it um and then uh you
know from there you know uh no GameCube
no GameCube nope Nintendo yep
and uh no Xbox oh we did not buy an Xbox
okay not okay
um my best friend at the time his
brother bought an Xbox he would always
bring it over I actually borrowed it I
traded my Dreamcast for like a month and
I kept the Xbox when Morrowind came out
right oh that was my opening love that
was there from the beginning huh yeah
organically organically yes
so so tomorrow
I'm sorry I'm sorry
so Morrowind of course we did have Lan
parties with Halo I just never fell in
love with hail for whatever reason I
thought it was a great I was like yeah
yeah no I know I know this is crazy to a
lot of people but we just never did
never did I had a lot of fun with it we
had a lot of great times with it but for
me it just never caught on like
everybody else so I feel the same way
about God of War 2018. there you go
there you go
I don't know I played it was hard
everybody that's whatever so then um
so from there we get into obviously the
Xbox 360 era
um and uh I again at this time I learned
my lessons from the past so every time
we get into a new generation I'm judging
each system for who's going to give me
the best value and who do I know out the
gate is not going to screw me over so uh
from the that started this generation
right so 360 generation I was watching
all the talk I was you know we had
forums at the time right we had a little
bit of internet going we had some some
information heard about the cell
processor and people don't remember the
cell processors
[Music]
it was going to be in your toaster it
was going to be in you know it was going
to be in your car this thing was going
to be everywhere right and and um I then
I started hearing the Rumblings from the
devs that they were having a hard time
so I went with Xbox out the gate 360 was
talking everything I wanted to hear not
to mention the soon as somebody dropped
that price point and said you know got
very very high and mighty let's just put
it that way with that price point I was
like nope 360 is it and of course
that changed you know some of the
greatest franchises in history
um came out of the 360 Generation
Um got married at the time
um my you know my son at the time uh was
young he that's his first system that he
started playing on that's when he bonded
just like I did with my dad yo exactly
uh you know again and I was one of those
parents I knew my kid is it was the
first Red Ring of Death though oh yeah
very early I I wound up with how many I
wound up with two or three I can't
remember I think you know I never got
one yeah I went up with two I think out
of that which was disappointing but that
was you know GameStop people remember
GameStop actually started uh exchanging
them before Microsoft agreed to start
taking them back like that was a big
battle I was it was stacked in the back
of that oh yeah yeah huge and I remember
going on forums going on Microsoft and
going to their customer service and
complaining like everybody else was like
this is this is a widespread problem I'm
not alone it's nothing I did here okay
that was a huge battle but but yeah the
bonding time with my son teaching him
how to play Battlefield and that kind of
stuff
you know rts's and all that kind of
stuff I got him Lord of the Rings he was
in The Lord of the Rings at the time
that that was a special time and uh you
know then you throw in Mass Effect
Bioshock
it's just I I it's so great man I mean
it's just such a changer when you think
about what we got during that time frame
so the 360
um came first uh and then towards the
end of the generation I did pick up a
PS3
oh and uh got to experience Last of Us
um you know which is one of my goats all
time uh number one number two doesn't
exist for me at all
you know piss kick off now I know I know
that's fine I know where King comes from
I know
um I just again it's a whole other thing
you played it though
last of us too had a lot of things going
on yeah but you played it though or you
refused to play it I refused to play oh
really
I've watched people play through it wow
I know the whole thing I refuse to play
so it just doesn't exist so it's just me
okay they did Joel dirty and I'm not
gonna ever you died I love how they did
jokes
the perspective on what people see
every action there's a reaction actually
because there's an effect so you can be
righteous in your stance consequences
somebody else's view here though
treachery will be uh rewarded rewarded
it was a beautiful scene
it just doesn't exist for me so like
you're saying something I I never
experience
shout out to Paris
I had the PS3 so I you know it got got
around playing the uncharteds and all
that kind of stuff as well
um and then we moved to PS4 Xbox again I
gotta make my decision right and I told
you I learned my lesson Donny D came out
speaking nonsense he came out talking
nothing I wanted to hear about
it none of it no no you gotta have a
connect you gotta have it connected you
gotta do all this you don't like it
online we got a system for you no you
don't want the camera in your box FTC
looking at you I don't want any of them
Donny D is not speaking my language
that's how you trade games without many
yep like many people I went right to PS4
got a PS4 because of it so that was pf4
that was the start of the generation I
did not you know and again PS4 at the
start of the generation was killing it
uh you didn't have a whole lot of games
they had no idea yeah they had no games
but what they did have were good right
but I wasn't you know again it wasn't
about that because again I still had my
old system so I was still playing 360. I
was still doing that kind of stuff I
wasn't trading everything in
um at that time but I made PS4 my main
reasons out the gate and then um you
know a lot of great memories again
through all that right there was a lot
yeah Indies in the beginning yeah it was
delicious
then we come back and finally Xbox
starts talking my language right Phil
comes in
um you know they they start up this game
pass thing and um you know they start
talking you know much more about games
and about what they're going to do right
and um start seeing a couple
Acquisitions obviously yeah who did that
that was true
who wrote you back in the phone
dominance Maximus are really expensive
so he started talking and I actually uh
actually went out and actually uh my
wife's oldest was moving out at the time
and uh he didn't want his Xbox anymore
and he had the Xbox one VCR so I was
like oh I'll buy it off you so I bought
it
and I got to catch up on all the stuff I
missed out of Xbox generation right and
when I got back into the Xbox ecosystem
at that point it felt like coming back
home again like it just felt because
what they were doing what they were
doing you know with some a bunch of my
saves showed up you know from the yeah
welcome back exactly exactly
segment
so I came back into the ecosystem I saw
my PS4 um and again what the PS4 gave
was great
um but but again I don't know if it
wasn't enough no no it wasn't it wasn't
the overall experience I wanted because
when they went to the third person
narrative games I gotta tell you guys oh
there's certain ones that hit but
there's certain ones that don't hit God
of War didn't hit for me I like The
Jeffy
yes I I like that right God of War is a
great I know why people love it I'm not
stupid and again I'm not that guy that
just goes oh I hate it so it's terrible
I'm not that guy even with last of us
too I understand why people enjoy the
quality is obvious I'm not gonna sit
here and try anything it's crazy right
right absolutely and so God of War
didn't hit for me Spider-Man again not
being a Marvel guy I actually played it
no I was like this is a cool game Cool
game but not I don't need the the game
right
um Uncharted was probably the last
series that I really loved I had woke up
with that one because yeah I know I know
I know I'm just gonna sit there trying
to make sure like that game's like oh
it's the greatest game ever made it's
okay
and this is just personal opinion it's
all subjective
is fast
the only one I am said that I missed was
Ghost of sushima because I did so that
was a good game yeah and I want to go
back and play that at some point
that's the only one really bums me out
but the rest of it again just I felt
more in line with Xbox once this they
started speaking my language and Game
Pass again as the type of gamer I am you
know I'm not ready again the pain the
Pandy the panty destroyed my financial
situation you know the same as a lot of
people's and I haven't recovered right
so I'm really a budget gamer now right
I'm really a budget gamer and Game Pass
just sold it because it's not for it
doesn't have to be for everybody but for
me the way I play games now is Simply
the Best Value I've never experienced
anything like this like I never would
have dreamed as a kid that I'd ever have
a full Blockbuster store in my you know
on my console just filled with video
games like never thought that right but
for me it works out great so when that's
you know and that kind of leads into how
I hop in the community and stuff yeah
that's what we'll transition because
because that's when we started hearing
about I was fully back in on Xbox still
still playing PS4 from time to time
obviously there's still jrpgs and stuff
I miss on there and there's a lot there
but I had to make a decision coming into
this gen right coming to this gym right
and so I started
doing research and that's how I found
this community was through that at the
at the time trying to figure out which
way I was gonna go uh this round
um not knowing whether or not I was
going to be able to get both right so
um that's what happens so here we are uh
transition right into the podcast thing
and and getting into the community so
like you know how did how did that was
it just something you just looking for
the information now it's like okay I'm
gonna go to podcasts I need to make an
informed decision and then like is that
the the natural transition to then you
saying okay you know what watching these
people maybe I need to tip my toe in you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah so uh
Brown 2019 is when I popped in now I
popped in underneath my old Twitter
which I have nuked um that was I had
been on Twitter since like the spicy
Twitter series
no it was a it was a involved in more
real life stuff
yeah I just found myself actually really
becoming negative in a lot of ways and I
I protect my energy at this point my
life I'm too old
um you know and I found myself I found
it affecting me right so I was looking
for something and I was like well I need
to know about the new new systems coming
out so I got to find some people that
know what they're doing and I wasn't a
podcast guy I wasn't a listener a
podcast I you know my oldest son is 22
now and my wife's oldest 25 and the
youngest is 17. so I've been through
that whole realm and I used to look at
them I'm like why are you watching
people play games
I'm like this is corny I'm like let's do
this who does this right if it wasn't
for addict I wouldn't be here right
that's the way I was I was like this is
okay so I decided to blow up my Twitter
destroyed my Twitter account and create
a new one right and I had to come up
with something and I popped into this
community right and then I started
seeing podcasts and of course at that
point I found like RDX
yeah sure the dealer I found you guys
you know again you wouldn't know I was
in here but I was there can you get a
preview of the old
like they that she was creeping in no no
no
because I remember all the names
okay because here you go we could talk
about Paul we'll talk about it offline
we're talking about statute of
limitations but I was lurking I was
lurking I got two at the time so I was
just showing for freaking out and I was
hearing all this information
um and then um you know from there
really what happened was the Pandy you
know the panty started uh our business
uh where I work it's a financial sector
it deals with small businesses truck
drivers a lot of that stuff which were
the hardest hit in a lot of ways yeah so
that all came collapsing I was lucky
enough to be able to keep working during
that time because I'm a manager so I was
lucky enough to be able to still you
know go to the office or work from home
at the time but I had a ton of free time
there wasn't a whole lot going on so I
found myself like okay nobody's gonna be
talking so like let's let's hop into
some of these podcasts right and so
that's what I did I started hearing I
started here and all this stuff and I
still had no intention of like joining
the community that way right at all but
the more I listened and I I really it
was daily like I started like you know
listening to wandering Dutch
but I get all the Euro guys during the
afternoon and I get all the Western guys
at night that's my that's how it worked
so I was constantly listening at work
you know I listened music but then I
turn on podcasts and so I started
getting into it then when I created my
new kind of persona and hop back in
uh that's when I started chatting right
and I started chatting and really
getting involved and I started meeting
people
um like Assassin loop I shout out to her
absolutely we don't know anything about
her yet but yeah absolutely
you know Psychonauts yes um you know all
these people that now have become my
friends I started meeting these people
in the chats and it was consistent right
because if you're in there all the time
you start seeing things
right so I started hanging out started
talking blah blah
um and then it was funny enough I was
watching retro Renegades one night shot
at the graphic God Jay uh Jago and all
those guys over there they do different
show it's just a group of buddies
getting together talking bunch of
nonsense and I was listening to the show
and I was involved in the chat and
finally Jay hit me up in the DMS um and
said you should come on I like your
opinions I like come on no I'm not doing
podcasting I'm not doing that I have
zero interest to doing podcasting I am
not going to do that um and he you know
he hit me up and then I started thinking
about it I was like well nobody else is
at the office with me technically speak
I gotta bring my Surface Pro in I could
bring my you can do it and I could bring
my Astro a50s in this work right so I
might go maybe I'll do it it'll be for
fun you know not got nothing better to
do so I did it and it was my first show
I did retrograde photographic gospel the
boys yeah yeah I had a blast and from
there I still didn't have an inkling to
do this at all like I was like oh that's
cool uh maybe I'll do it again but I
mean whatever so
um eventually I started getting to know
three bit shout out yeah yeah I started
he was doing a show at the time he
doesn't you know do shows like that he
had his own channel and stuff but you
know he's so busy now with development
work so shout out to him um but I
started hanging out with him and he um
you know started hanging out his chat
started I found MAV uh streaming
yeah I was in math streams when he was
you know had like three four or five
people in his streams and I started
chatting with him a little bit
um and it kind of snowballed from there
three bit uh told ptk had put out ptk
Blanche
yeah good brother yeah yeah shout out to
shot podcast because he had put out a
tweet saying hey who should I have come
on well three bit threw my name in the
Hat and I was like oh three bit I'm like
he's like he hit me up in the DMS he's
like no I love your opinions when you're
in my chat I think you should go on blah
blah blah I'm like nah I don't know
about this well ptk hit me up and say
hey you want to come on the shop I'm
like what a podcast sure I'm like all
right we'll go on the shop podcast and
uh went on the shop podcast and had such
a phenomenal first show
um over there the fuzzy yeah yeah it was
so natural right it was just it was like
we we just connected it was just like
easy even though I hadn't this was my
second time ever doing like I was like
oh my God so um we did that ptk hit me
up right after the show said hey my wife
was listening to the show thinks you'd
be a great addition
um would you ever consider going
full-time doing podcasting full-time and
I was like ah yeah I don't know about
all that commitment like it did have a
great time so if I I said sure let's do
it right so ptk you know makes his final
decision says yep you're joining okay
cool all of a sudden make the
announcement goes out
I got math
yeah I had guessed it on Xbox ultimate
like once before or whatever else and
did a little something with those guys
over there with the family Matt hits me
up he's like oh man I just saw the post
from ptk Caitlyn and I were just talking
oh yeah
[Laughter]
I'm like when I'm like well Xbox
ultimates Friday nights right he's like
yeah and I'm like I mean we're at
lockdown I'm like yeah I'm like we got
nothing going on I said the wife's not
gonna be upset we don't again what are
we gonna do right her youngest had
almost
guests
I'm like let's do it so I joined Xbox
ultimate then like I don't know like a
couple weeks later at some point at that
Dan the Man Cunningham shout out to Dan
the Man
Cunningham puts me up uh boom asks who
he should have on his
so then Dan the man throws my name out
there for boom show
um
always giving people a shot always
giving people a shot right so I went on
his Thursday because he had a Thursday
Xbox Factor at the time I went on his
Thursday show uh in the afternoon
because I could work from home anytime
at that time anytime I wanted to so I
just worked from home and just hey get
paid to podcasts that's cool
yeah exactly so uh you know what they
don't know don't hurt them so I just uh
I went on there until now yeah nobody
know nobody at work knows yeah
so I uh did boom show and had a
phenomenal time and from there boom
invited me on a couple of his other
shows you know you know boom got the
shows who's got the shows
you made the round you did prime time
yeah breakfast okay okay
yeah I love you brother yeah so we did
that and uh eventually boom said hey I
you're basically doing this like all the
time you want to join Xbox Factory
and I was like yeah I got nothing better
slide got that slot so did that
um and uh join boom's crew
um and then um obviously from there
during this time period right during
this time period I was playing with MAV
and the crew over fun speculation
because they used to do a lot of Halo
nights after yeah
he's had crazy nights over there on Halo
this guy started coming around named
steel rain steel rain let's go
Young Buck very opinionated opinion
high energy dude yes myself
um and we you know again it's funny
because you're playing in a big group of
people on Halo right but there's certain
voices that just stand out sometimes
above the others right and Steele and I
just kept going back and forth we joke
with each other whatever else he had a
great sense of humor really
knowledgeable about the industry even
though he wasn't doing a show at the
time or whatever else and he started he
started doing all this well I'm getting
experience podcasting I'm really
enjoying myself but I'm like man I'd
really like something of my own right
you get that feeling I I like something
yeah yeah yeah like something of my own
um but I'm like you know I'm not gonna
do it by myself right I'm like I'm not
ready to do that that's tough at it you
host it yeah I'm like no way so I
started thinking about the people and
obviously everybody I knew was already
had either one show or two shows and I'm
like I got I want to get somebody fresh
I want to get somebody new and and like
instantly I was at work I still remember
I was at work and I was actually at the
office and Steele's name popped in my
head
just steal popped in my head and I I
didn't hesitate like I'm I'm a firm a
Believer is that sometimes you're
pointed the right way so I went right to
the Twitter DMS and I hit steel up facts
I hit him up and I said steel I said hey
man I said what did you think about
doing a show and he's like he's like are
you serious and I'm like yeah and he's
like well I used to podcast with my
brother he's like I've got the PC I got
the hook up I know how to do it he's
like I've been thinking about getting
back into doing it my brother's really
busy can't do it with him he's like
why'd you think of me I'm like man I
said just every time we're in Xbox live
together we're having a good time
yeah and I'm like your energy I'm like
your energy level is there with me I
said which is great we got this great
Dynamic I said and you're part of a
younger generation different perspective
I said your background your history
everything is different than mine and
I'm like so you come from an opposite
side of me but I said we do agree on a
lot but I said you still have a
different way of looking and thinking
about things I said that's a great
that's a great thing to have on a
podcast yeah so yeah from there went
through the whole hey what are we gonna
name this like we went through that
whole process graphics
and and steel you know again had done it
previously so he knew how to do a lot of
it which thankfully because again I was
not let me let me explain no I'm not I'm
the same way I'm not ready I know
nothing I know where the OBS I ain't
know nothing and I was like addict do do
that
I don't even have a PC yeah I'm rocking
on my Surface Pro right that's what I'm
doing my my Surface Pro 4 with the
bulging battery right now and I'm trying
to figure out where you're gonna keep
going that's gonna upgrade too
right right so so you know I'm just
thankful I'm like you know it just seems
like everything lines up into place yes
right for this to happen because Steel's
like no I got you you can do this not a
problem you really want to do this I'm
like yeah he's like okay if we're gonna
do this you know we're gonna commit it's
going to be what time slot are we gonna
do Saturday mornings worked out
perfectly for both of us nice time you
know there was nobody else there we knew
that we were talkers we did not know
what this was going to turn into yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so um we do it as a
perfect time stop so we set it all up
and we did our first show together and
it felt
sure it wasn't as comfortable as it is
now but even just the little bit I knew
of him and we talked back and forth we
had gotten on the phone together and had
kind of you know done that whole thing
as well but that first show went just so
well like it was crazy right so that was
our living split screen started yeah and
then um later
um math hit me up again yes I'll do an
Xbox ultimate and MAV says hey I'm
thinking about doing another shot man
show like you would steal Jesus yeah oh
yeah he's like he's like so uh I'm like
and he's like but I know you're packed
he's like do you think you can get
another one in and he's like you're my
first you know you're you're like you're
my first choice of this two-man show
he's like and I'm like when he's like
Thursday nights I'm like because now
work's picking up again right work's
picking up I'm like oh my God this is
gonna be I got an hour drive into work
right so it's an hour one way so I'm
like figuring out time frame I'm like
it's like two-man show he's like just
you and me we're gonna do it we'll have
to guess
yeah and he's like and I want you to
host oh he's like I'm gonna give you the
captains yeah there we go
I'm like all right let's do it I'm like
let's do it so that's how PM in the PM
was born so it was Matt hit me up so
that's kind of my history into the
community and again I never turned out
invites I have to nowadays because of
work schedule but back when the pandemic
was in full swing we were like I was
like anybody who wanted me I was going
yeah listen I had to run but your run
was crazy your run was crazy I've never
seen anything like that was for the
streets but he's outside he's outside
now
salute to you brother like just again
the journey tremendous you know you've
extremely loved in the culture always
positive energy yep you know what I'm
saying and um you know being an OG
you're kind of the game you know seeing
you motivated and quote unquote let's be
honest like a young man sport right for
us to be in here and have that energy
you know it's really tremendous and it's
awesome to see and um just hearing about
your intro was like was crazy man you
know we could continue to talk oh yeah
just for the sake of time I have to move
on a little bit because I don't know
what this is just gems and we will have
you back there's no doubt but um yeah I
just wanted to you know we got to ask
that question though oh God we gotta ask
that question is that thing that we do
for all the guests that we have to ask
that question uh you're gonna named a
lot of consoles you know laid a lot of
games but we need that top five video
games listen
um I do I do obviously knew this is
going right so but on any given day
besides the top three you can switch out
right so all right so here we go
um number one Elder Scrolls
done and on with Bethesda Todd Howard
they make the type of game that I want
to play Forever okay
yep starts with Morrowind
um I gotta say
um let's go
Bioshock whole entire franchise okay uh
obviously you know I'm excited for Judas
the genius the genius is back but
Bioshock Bioshock one is if you had to
pick a game that's the closest thing to
a 10 out of 10 Bioshock one is it okay
absolutely and I love the trilogy I even
like infinite which a lot of people have
questions about I like all three Mass
Effect Mass Effect you know it's coming
the whole entire trip
um again it's sci-fi it's sci-fi it's
the greatest sci-fi RPG we've ever had
which one
oh here we go everybody already knows
number one yeah
I'm the Nostalgia guy I I'm the
Nostalgia guy I will always when it
comes to that question 90 of the time I
will fall back to the original
number one there's no two yeah even with
the mechanics
no no
no you know the last of us too you know
oh
I got you I got you no doubts that's
like the Bioshock okay yeah Bioshock
um and then um see this is where it gets
really dicey from here because I
anything I got so much history like I
could throw in a mirror
um Knights of the Old Republic
I can't wait for that new one on the
PlayStation blocked off Edition
I'm not happy about that King I'm not
happy yeah me neither I know but nice
the old republics you need to know yeah
Star Wars it's the it's the best version
of Star Wars representation video game
both of them I love both of them to
death so Kotor is up there uh fifth spot
who am I gonna give it to today I could
get real weird
um or I could get uh
okay let's go because sometimes it's
about what have you done for me lately
okay and um so I'm gonna bring something
newer that people are going to disagree
more hardly with me 100 like this is not
this is controversial to a lot of people
but cyberpunk 2077. wow
yeah actually a DLC the only person I
ever say that uh
but cyberpunk and like I said on any
given day last of us can show up in
there I mean there's a million other
games but cyberpunk 2077 280 hours in
one place
um this is a world I got lost into the
receipts you know again I had the series
console didn't have the balls and
everybody else it was Exempted
him I played it from day one without the
patch all the way through wow I'm
talking about emotional impact from the
story a lot of the issues that it came
from was the last gen versions like
that's for the longest issues came from
and the hate train rolled from there and
a lot of it and again I'm so glad that
edge Runners brought it back a lot of
people are discovering it again yes
right and they had a lot of work to do I
gave CD project red the smoke I let him
know that what they did was wrong that
last generation version should never
have been out period Point Blank it was
wrong for them to hide it they need to
make money yes but they need to make
money I know I know I know uh sacrifice
right no listen if if they can't afford
the series all the PlayStation 5 I mean
yeah who did him
so but yeah when I completed that game
and I and again you already know Cog I
play games differently than a lot of
people I stayed away from I got through
maybe a quarter of the main um missions
and then did all the side stuff nice and
that 280 hours is drive and listen to
music in photo mode I mean I love the
world that they created much better and
better so then I hit the main missions
like the majority of the main missions
were saved to the last thing I did talk
about impactful I fell in love with
characters that I never thought I was
going to like in that game the chain
again CD projekt Red's Mastery of
character uh development uh and story
arcs shine through in that game oh yeah
again from a from a ending of the game
and again I don't beat very many games
if I say a b to game it's got to be
something special unless it's a short
game or some co-op game that I beat with
like steel or plug yeah so for me to sit
down 280 hours finish out this game and
then one of those games where you just
sit back and I just let the controller
and I just let the credits run right to
the music that's one of them ones that's
one of them ones for you I got it for me
no doubt tremendous five and final
question favorite console of all time
and why easy Dreamcast
in the story done and over with changed
pushed the industry forward despite its
short life span
um it it changed so much about what I
thought of as a console with the
internet uh the online play all that and
yes I know the PS2 eventually did I get
all that but I'm just saying the
Dreamcast from that from the jump from
the time I plug that thing in and turned
it on it was a different experience than
anything else I was having anywhere else
at the time and it has some of my
favorite games on there of all time code
Veronica oh yes I I called Veronica's my
favorite Resident Evil yes even over
Resident Evil 4. Code Veronica is still
pretty so there's just memories like
that that I have of the Dreamcast that I
will never forget and I still have my
original Dreamcast
[Music]
brother tremendous history
tremendous Journey brother we can talk
all day you know how this goes your
Ascension and see you know you you go
through the community and and you have
these opinions and it's based on again
being there seeing this industry develop
seeing this industry change and it's
great to see man I'm glad we got the
chance to talk hopefully you're still
hanging out for a bit oh yeah you go
okay yeah I know you guys you built I
don't even asked you I knew you was
built for it but I was like I just gotta
always put it out there if anyone you
know yes we're good no doubt so we're
gonna get into it because I know the
channel God will they get to the topic
please who is this stupid thing I gotta
respect I got a respect addict at least
get him in for one topic because I know
he got a hard stop nah
all right yeah
real quick okay cool we don't have two
minutes I'm gonna keep myself in the in
the chat so I can record it for the
stuff I need to do all right no problem
all right see you guys all right no
problem all right
we got cycle gamer five dollars which I
I feel like Microsoft gets an L for
having no no no we got that already
okay Highlander oh Highlander 001 10
super chat my dad brought home pong and
Space Invaders for Christmas for me and
my brother he got them from the local
bar right before it went up in Flames oh
my god wow this is back in 86 or 86 or
77 we still have the wow somebody owed
money in uh a fire broke out yeah yeah
a mysterious fire broke out screamed sir
we got dial-up Chronicles five dollars
E.T was voiced by an old chick who
smoked two packs a day yes wow
there we got c1bu five dollars shout out
to my reformed Orthodox Rabbi Bill
Clinton for winning game of the year
maybe next time uh Eldon ring and God of
War Ragnarok hashtag stopped the cat
yeah that was that was a moment
then we got CJ Mike 1024 new member put
the crest in the chat for CJ Mike thank
you sir and we got drive by Joe two
dollar Super Chat let me find out King
was the rich friend yes
I wish yeah I wish they would have been
playing those Imports
I had every console
every iteration of every console so Sal
probably what we got let's go do a quick
battle we got a couple of them just
Necromancer sale two dollar Super Chat I
miss shining for us yes so do I yeah
drunken ninja member for two years five
dollars which had nah Phil got to get
his lawyers to use the demise of Sega as
evidence against Sony for the FTC case
you're gonna see a lot of dirt come out
that we got flame member for two years
five dollar Super Chat greetings my
brothers thanks for having me on
Thursday it was truly an honor to cringe
with you all uh and surprise surprise
pong is here
that's a flame what's up brother
um and I think we are good we're caught
up
I think we're caught up
yeah we're good all right
oh the pop the the cogwick walk away
from uh ran to go grab his food I guess
I thought it would be longer
surprise
yeah I was quick
I was like this surprising silence going
on what's going on
do we got a lot or we had a little bit
so it's all good no doubt last week four
results that ended people have spoken
with the recent Todd Howard interview
discussing his passion for Fallout 3
different tone of Fallout 4 and upcoming
Fallout TV series how would you handle
the continuation of the Fallout Series
in the current Xbox series X and S
generation the winner of our four-way
ILP poll with 55 of the vote was
announced a new Fallout game developed
by Bethesda obsidian and in Exile group
coming in that second with 21 of the
vote was make a detailed remake of the
entire Fallout connection
and on the series X Series S in third
place 18 of the vote do a quick remaster
of the Fallout collection on series X
Series S and in last place with only
four percent of the vote was the messy
Lords I don't care We're Not Gonna Act
Like Fallout 76 don't already exist on
the platform group shout out to
everybody who wrote in the votes you
already know on Lawson what you think
man people want them to make a Fallout
game come with uh maybe a combined
effort with obsidian Exile that would be
that would be amazing right that's like
bringing together Devastator of Ultron
or something like that to make that
happen I mean yeah if they can again
they're all in-house they're all talking
to one another they're gonna make
something happen right I think we do see
a Vegas two uh we I I think we
absolutely see obsidian and Exile
working on Fallout at some point so I
think that's gonna happen um how it's
gonna happen I don't know
um I'm a fan though of remaking Fallout
one and two in this in this style style
that would be crazy that would be that
would be absolutely awesome because
nobody's playing those games anymore
right they're hard to go back to if
that's not if you don't come from that
era so factual no doubt so we're going
to get into these topics right now and
uh solve you're up I can set your volume
if you got it you got it oh I mean I'll
try you I'll Trust Impressions
all right so okay so on Thursday
um a mere hours before the game awards
the FTC announced that they plan to sue
to block Microsoft's acquisition of
Activision Blizzard King Incorporated
the uh and I quote the agency alleges
that the maker of Xbox would gain
control of top video game franchises
enabling it to harm competition and high
performance gaming consoles and
subscription Services by denying or
degrading Rivals access to its popular
content end quote
yes
yeah so that's just part of the press
release do you want more of the press
release because I think it's important
um yeah so obviously they allege that um
from acquiring that what they seek to
block it uh Microsoft from acquired
leading video game developer Activision
Blizzard Blockbuster game fractions like
Call of Duty blah blah blah all right in
a complaint issue today FTC pointed out
that to Microsoft's record of acquiring
and using valuable gaming content to
suppress competition from rival consoles
including its acquisition of xenomax
parent company of Bethesda Microsoft
decided to make several bethesda's
titles including Starfield and redfull
Microsoft exclusives despite assurances
it had given to the EU anti uh trust
authorities that it had no incentive to
withhold games from rival consoles and
it's they continue on to say that
Microsoft has already shown that it can
and will withhold content from its
gaming Rivals today we seek to stop
Microsoft from Gaining control over a
leading independent game studio and
using it to harm competition in multiple
Dynamic and fast growing gaming markets
another point they said is the series s
that the series X are only one of one of
only two types of high performance video
game consoled it the only consoles out
there seems um Activision they talk
about there being a developer obviously
the franchises and they said but that as
far as um Diablo World of Warcraft
OverWatch blah blah they said but that
could change if the deal is allowed to
proceed with control over Activision's
Blockbuster franchise Microsoft would
have both the means and motive to harm
competition by manipulating Activision
to pricing degrading activisions getting
quality or playing experience or rival
consoles and services and changing the
terms and timing of access to
Activision's content or withholding
content from competitors entirely for
soul to get home to Consumers that
sounds like an assumption [ __ ] yeah
but one last thing this was just a funny
part for me this is
issue the complaint was three to one
with commissioner Christine s Wilson
vote no no I think
we need that we need to know who we need
transparency we need to know who's paid
off and Who's acting up so now that we
know who's that Christine we coming so
if you wanted to talk about the dough or
you would be good we're good yeah okay
so the note this is important to note
and I quote note the commission issues
an administrative complaint when it has
reason to believe that the law the law
has been or is being violated and it
appears to the commission that a
proceeding is in the public interest the
issuance of the administrative complaint
marks the beginning of a proceeding in
which the allegations will be tried in a
formal hearing before an administrative
judge so this complaint is alleging that
they there is a strong indication yes
that laws have been broken and even
attempting to buy Activision Blizzard
yeah yeah shout out to court Corbin I
got to read this one he said uh card
waiter guilty under the sufficient that
you'll eventually break the law but
you'll eventually break the law after
that
Minority reports this is a good one look
so let's get to it this is this this
broke the internet this was all over the
place I know probably been making the
rounds I see a couple of comments we got
to talk about it man like you know this
broke you know and um we do we heard our
decision was imminent so what do you
think man now that this this came out
what you think about the reasoning are
you winning are you against it and you
know what's your thought process here so
I know you had a lot to say oh boy oh
boy all right I'm gonna try to
try to keep it down a little bit just
for the ILP here ah listen listen listen
listen let's go this is a joke this is
an absolute joke um this is a joke of a
complaint it's actually even worse than
what I thought it was going to be um
this entire this is a uh circus at this
point
um Lena Khan and the rest of the cronies
over at the FTC except for the one
um obviously are doing a lot of
political grandstanding there's a lot of
agenda involved they are literally
trying to rewrite the laws without going
through the legislative process as is
proper they are trying to increase the
power of the FTC
um without anybody's okay and that's
what this motivation is they want to
send a message to big Tech and they've
decided that of course Microsoft being
who they are is going to be an easy
target to do so except for they're going
to ignore the written laws of the land
and to me that is a a huge obvious
problem and again what they've done here
with what they've said in this complaint
and shout out to Hogue for sure
as he should be because the man the man
explains things so well
I'm a common gamer old dude who's just
been around for a long time that's all I
am but um just just going step by step
paragraph by paragraph through this
complaint there's a there's a reason
here why they are doing it in-house and
did not take this to the federal level
there's a reason why they want one of
their own judges to look at this
complaint and they don't want somebody
more neutral to be looking at this
complaint because it doesn't hold water
it doesn't it's hypocritical the fact
that they are trying
their best to say that Nintendo does not
count in this industry
says it all says it all okay and for
anybody who doesn't understand why
they're doing this this isn't just some
some willy-nilly thing that they decided
to do if they can get Nintendo excused
from this industry as a non-player
amongst the big boys then what that does
is it makes the market
you can you can play with the numbers to
say that Microsoft would have a much
bigger piece of the pie than they
actually do if it's just the two correct
uh so this is all cold it's all
calculated they decided to read the EU
um notes and read into their own
definition so they could make it seem
something nefarious was going on with
Microsoft and xenomax
um they have done their best uh Lena
Khan and the rest of them uh to
obviously create a villain in Microsoft
and Xbox out of thin air and that's
about how much worth I put in to this
complaint
um because again if this gets seen by
anybody and in fact Hoagie made the
point the complaint is so obvious and so
bad that the internal judge may even
side with Microsoft and Xbox here
um so I think that this again goes back
to political agenda it's motivated by
Lena's own personal
um want to obviously increase her
standing for future positions and she
has decided that she is going to win or
lose go down with the ship now I would
be surprised at the end of the day if we
see concessions that are you know big
enough that are going to sway her to
avoid this but also keep in mind there
is a Supreme Court case yes being heard
right now which could give an opening to
Microsoft if the Supreme Court rules
what's happening is it's supposed to be
ruled on by summer uh a company is suing
the FTC for this exact process a smaller
company who's been wrapped up in this
process with the FTC they've been
wrapped up for two years now over a
decision and obviously that's not how
this is supposed to work that's not how
it's written it's supposed to work it's
supposed to be a timely manner and
they're not getting their do their dude
uh they're not getting their due Justice
due process time wise and so they've got
it all the way up to the Supreme Court
Supreme Court's supposed to rule if the
Supreme Court favors the company against
the FTC that would open
give Microsoft an opening to sue the FTC
outright right
um we could speed up things now do you
think two follow-up questions do you
think that because notables in Microsoft
court right we saw the statements from
Brad Smith yes saying that you know if
we try for peace
Give Peace a chance but now that we're
gonna fight the soul we know there's
money on the table based on the fact
that it got blocked so one do you think
that they're going to fight and then two
what are your thought process on the
basis of the argument because the
argument they're trying to say is that
Microsoft wasn't truthful about the Zen
that's what they're kind of the core of
it is why they're saying they're suing
like Microsoft wasn't
forthcoming to them as far as redfull
and star field and because we we can't
trust them almost like a nefarious thing
that they would do harmful things with
Call of Duty and all the Activision
Blizzard you know IPS yeah
um first of all I think that this deal
is as important is it is too important
for Microsoft's future with Xbox and
where they're going 10 15 20 years down
the road right that I think this one
they they will fight for this one I
think yeah I think they're going to go
all the way with this one I think it's
too important now they could they have
plan B plan C absolutely they could I'm
sure they already do just in case but I
think this one is too important they see
the big picture with everything that
they're getting from this one deal will
solidify all the stuff that they see in
the crystal ball down the road happening
this will be that one deal that can
really really uh make things clear down
the road and I think that that's why
they're gonna fight this one out it's
too big it's too
um as far as the other point uh you know
whether or not the FTC here is
creating something out of nothing I
think they are at this point I think
that Microsoft's actions
to this point should speak louder again
going outside of the norm of this
industry to offer 10-year deals to
everybody for Call of Duty
uh says it all and again they can they
can twist and turn and try to you know
EU has already come out and said even if
that was implied during their process
xenomax games work big enough to change
the landscape in this industry this
industry is huge this idea again this
complaint they tried to actually say
that the only people that can make
triple A games
is activism or Activision EU the
distinction of AAA Ubisoft yeah the
distinction of AAA which is ridiculous
they again they're trying their hardest
to make this industry so much smaller
than it is right so no I I don't I think
their actions should speak louder I
think that what they've shown they're
going to do is is keep Call of Duty
everywhere because it's too big it's too
important it makes too much money and
again we're not just talking about
consoles here folks anymore we're
talking about mobile we're talking about
PC both of which are impacted by how
many people can play they want to get
into this mobile market that's where the
next big war is with Apple and Google
that's what they're gearing up for here
right they're going to use Call of Duty
mobile as one of the big boys oh
fairness right absolutely so I think
that at the end of the day the the FTC
trying to twist their words and say they
lied or they they misled the EU if you
want to take that road it's completely
all you have to do is go back and watch
the interviews all you have to do is go
back and watch the round table you see
it all they said they said exactly what
they were going to do the stuff that was
going to stay on there was the Legacy
titles that already have an audience
they did not commit any which way to the
rest of the titles and obviously if
you're going to start dictating the
businesses when they spend 7 billion or
70 billion by the building you're going
to buy the building you start dictating
what they can do with that brand new IP
now you're controlling business that's
why I hate big government that's why I
hate all this stuff the nanny State
again they're trying to get in the way
of the growth of this industry this
industry is still in a dynamic growth
phase you know I again Strauss zelnick
himself came out in of you and said
they've got 20 more years of projected
growth before they even see a cap at
some point
you can't come in and control that and I
think that they're they're doing their
best for their own reasons and I think
that's going to show whether they have
to go all the way and before their
internal judge and then appeal process
or whatever whatever it takes eventually
that's going to come out that that's
exactly what this was that this was an
agenda based complaint and nothing more
it has no substance I hear you hello
it's solved man let's go right back to
you bro
um this one broke the internet man so
you know it was all over the place FTC
with the stop Microsoft common Gamers
competition we gotta break this up yeah
your thoughts sir
so I I was super surprised when it
happened a because it happened so fast
and B Because earlier in the week we had
gotten a report coming out of it one of
the most reputables
one of the most reputable Outlets ever
um but it was what was interesting about
it was an indication that one of Lena
Khan's Democratic commission members
which size therefore causing sort of a
tie a little bit of a stalemate in terms
of voting on this action
um so that turned out not to happen for
whatever reason I I'm interested to see
where that information came from and and
what happened internally that if that
was true what happened internally to
change that
um but nonetheless they voted three to
one two two on you know move forward
with the complaint and I want to be
honest with you if it just feels like it
feels like politics at hand like
obviously Lena Khan's position at the
FTC is a presidential appointed uh
position and part of her appointment
uh was part part of kind of the deal
under it is that you know did she be
stronger on trust busting right right
and she has to show a strong hand when
it comes to that so when I'm you're
looking at this uh this deal this
Microsoft ABK deal what you see if
you're in the know is that there's a lot
of hypocrisy in the statements that are
made because a lot of the things that
they're claiming to want to protect the
industry from are actions and that that
PlayStation themselves undertakes on a
daily basis so it is it is very much
hypocritical
um at the end of the day though
Microsoft is considerably bigger yeah
and it's called Call of Duty is massive
it is
massive I would like to see receipts on
where they misled uh the European uh
Commission on specifics about the
Bethesda games I would love to see you
actually jumped out they defended
Microsoft on this yeah because where are
those receipts right they said that
that's not true it actually went at the
FTC about that part right so that that
really again so when you look at the
entirety of this complaint it feels like
it's a fight that Lena Khan feels that
she has to undertake in order to feign
strength right
and kind of kind of signpost to Big
Business big Tech that hey we're gonna
be watching you when we do this do do I
think she believes it's a losing matter
yes I do but I feel that it's one of
those things why I have to do this for
my like pong said from my standing and
all of this right not to look weak
because I think it looks weak in her
eyes if she from the beginning says you
know what it's not as bad as it made it
seem let's come Let's do let's go with
concessions and then we'll move forward
with it after I had already stated
there's a big allegation you implying
political it's brand standing for gaming
are you implying that there is ulterior
motives
definite this is this is one big
filibuster what it is it is it is
holding up the inevitable in order to
feign strength and
to be honest to put out a message to big
Tech big business hey we're watching you
we're watching you and we regardless of
what the end outcome is we're going to
scrutinize you at every step of the way
and that that's fine that makes a whole
lot of space or based on legality based
on the law is it is it this is the part
where
there is nothing to my lame and I right
that has happened that that falls under
the umbrella of illegality
so you imply that these things been
happening before it gave me that that
scale may be different but hold up let
me not put words
right right that might be yeah I don't
want to do that but
it's just one of those Microsoft is is
is too big pause
um
and you know they've been sort of
through this process before
and they are one of the companies that's
going to have a bullseye on them when
they try to do this
um
but the fact of the matter I grew upon I
think this is a fight they continue to
have and wherever it takes them whether
it takes them to the federal level where
they get shut down at the administrative
level with the administrative judge
which is essentially a judge within
their organization right the
administrative judge so you would think
they're supposed to be objective but hey
you never know
um
this is an attack if this doesn't go
through
this is an attack on Game Pass the
entire the entire way Microsoft is doing
Xbox is doing business in terms of Game
Pass and what they want to do with that
this is an attack on that and Microsoft
understands the the importance of this
deal because like I've been saying for a
while when you have a subscription
service that is that big
most of the time you want to own the
vast majority of things you have in that
service you don't want to be paying
these licensing fees and all these fees
to have games exclusively on your on
your console forever you want to do it
to start bringing people in but the goal
is to have however many you know
development studios in in-house that
they have already and however many more
the constant goal for them is going to
keep is going to be to keep acquiring
and getting larger so that the vast
majority of stuff in Game Pass belongs
to them right you're going to have your
your third party and your small Indie
thing here and there but ultimately Game
Pass evolves into a thing that is
largely Microsoft and Xbox owned
properties right so
this is huge for them they're going to
take this fight and go as far with it as
in my opinion as far with it as they
need to go but ultimately I think it's
baseless I think the argument's stupid
it don't make any sense to anybody who
knows anything about the industry as a
Layman looking at it I'm like this is a
lie this is not true none of this is
true so um
yes please
um I want to ask you what did you feel
about the CMAs response to it um I don't
know if you caught that you know in
reference to their their kind of
agreeing like I did and so please tell
me you know um statements in that and
then activisions you know presents say
Hey you know they're deferring to
competitors as opposed to Consumers like
basically it felt like the CMA the Ed
Activision and the EU well all the
defense of Microsoft despite the FTC
block that well this is the thing okay
so like you mentioned with the CMA
before with the the specifics about the
Bethesda deal
that feels completely untrue like that
would mean that Microsoft went in and
knowingly said something that wasn't
true knowing it would be documented A
and B at some point brought back up
right
they wouldn't do that no who would do
that who would out and out lie knowing
you were going to do something different
and it was going to be brought up again
again at that point maybe they had no
idea that they were going to be in the
running to purchase Activision Blizzard
I don't think anybody did
um but I think that seems to be the
discrepancy here they seems to be that
that both that they're using this
statement but that may not be an upright
Lie by them but it feels like they've
been they can twist the verbiage to suit
this particular point that they're
trying to destroy I think yeah as part
of the actual complaint and this and the
document it looks good right right but
at the end of the day receipts oh yeah
you know if I'm Microsoft lawyers I'm
like point to a specific place where
this was said point to a specific
document where this is documented that
we we indicated that we would not take
these games away from anyone remember if
we recall it was
um all service games we would not strip
off on Playstation so Elder Scroll is
online right yeah
remember the platforms they exist and
then it was said
um any new future new IP first they said
Case by case basis Case by case basis
and then no it would be where Game Pass
exists that was the key statement if I
remember
at no point in time did they ever State
no these games aren't going anywhere
they they ever state that right and like
pong said the moment you're gonna try to
tell people what to do with the thing
they've already you've already allowed
them to purchase right so you didn't
bring this up back then when they
purchased them you purchased it oh no
you shouldn't have done that uh
interesting it just it feels baseless it
except for to prove a point and to for
Lena Khan not to look weak and the FTC
not to look weak and she sees it as a as
an opportunity to show that they're
working and doing something even if it's
a losing battle which I think it 866 he
hit the like button wipe your feet be
having fun we're talking talking that's
what y'all waited for y'all what did the
Lord talk about this or hit the like
button y'all later here I see y'all
I was talking about the proof in the
pudding stuff look at next year Fallout
4 is getting a current gen patch who
else is getting that patch PlayStation
is yeah
they're following up you should charge
them ten dollars you should charge them
ten dollars absolutely because they're
willing to pay for it right so make them
pay more
the real real quick the other thing real
quick just real quick the other thing
that popped in my head that I forgot
um go for it all all WhatsApp said is
absolutely 100 correct the craziest
thing and the most telling about all of
this is that if they wanted a win out of
this at the FTC you want it in the EU
CMA all wanted a win out of this besides
the concessions about Call of Duty like
let's set that aside Microsoft is
opening the door for unionization within
the tech
which has which has been a problem
and all they had to do was get that
which they already started the CWA
already came out it's backing Microsoft
because they got a deal preach they
could have they could have come out of
this whole thing and said look we're
breaking open the tech Indus history for
unionization which is the most important
thing because all we ever talk about is
the workers
actually workers and the people in the
conditions that actually affects and the
jobs and the conditions that will affect
that are actually in favor of the deal
right that a certain group is not
actually protected
and the people that are in favor that
they have better conditions and
potentially unionization which Microsoft
doesn't seem to be interested in
blocking that's these wow that's
interesting sets the example for the
rest of all the big Tech yeah absolutely
I got in trouble for saying moral I did
get in trouble for saying moral and it
it's it's it's just disingenuous
I just get very sensitive when it comes
to developers and proper treatment and
things like that and I'm glad you
mentioned that pong because I think
that's being lost in all of this there
is a company
that is going through we've documented
insane conditions yes harassment you
know we talked about crunch we hearing
things about Diablo recently you know
what I'm saying we're hearing things
about stuff in the past rooms you know
what I'm saying all types of very
vicious conditions where there's a
certain group not even a group that
there's majority of them we had to
change their leadership over there right
where they're like we need change this
cannot go on as the status quo and I'm
glad you know that because that's the
part that I think everyone's missing
here right there is there is a I will
say there is a moral aspect of it in my
opinion you know I'm saying then there's
the political aspect whatever but I'm
not I'll get my balls off when it's my
time
my last two my last two points so it's a
very interesting yes yes
so first as this is an injunction to try
to block the acquisition yeah until it's
ruled upon the acquisition can continue
yes yes so technically the acquisition
could go through and then has to be
reneged that they vote against it
correct correct now
if they take this to court and it it is
ruled in Microsoft's favor that none of
this these statements are true and
everything
now they're free to proceed without a
single consession
I want to present that scenario because
I was dying to hear what king got to say
yeah if that scenario comes yes the
floor is yours yeah
we we've listened to my illustrious
panel members uh give the outline and
and uh all it takes is Microsoft lawyers
to tap that chin one time and
it always looks like you you're in the
lead is always looks like you got fast
hands it always looks like you're
connecting and you're winning and boom
you're sleeping
um
the FTC
it was watch out this is what I take it
as right you seen a kid getting picked
on
you see them getting picked on by the
CMA
it used like and and he was like yo go
down there I'm gonna pick on them too
I'm gonna pile on you try to pile on
so while they was kicking while they're
seeing me was kicking Microsoft you
threw a kick or a punch too
and looked at you and said I know you
didn't just swing on me
because they had the CMA where they
wanted them you understand they were
dealing with them they they were fine
with them
the EU
it was fine with them too they're gonna
work them it's gonna happen very easy
but here you go
oh you only have a good track record in
your last fight history
yeah you kind of spotted you was once a
fit dude but Khan
[ __ ] ain't looking good nowadays now I
know these lawyers is going to eat you
up what you're doing is you're giving
regurgitated nonsense you heard Jim
snitching and Jim telling you well when
the Godzilla Max what they had did right
well what happened was they got the star
filled and it's supposed to be the most
expensive world greatest thing ever and
we not getting it and then and then then
they could have another thing called
redfall and then that was being me we're
not getting no evil
FTC is parroting someone yes they don't
know what red Forest building
we don't know what red fellas so for you
to even sit there and try to say they're
locking off this content
FDC just lost six of eight past fights
you file for that stop I had to break
protocol but that was hilarious could do
the FTC
is following Jim's lead
people was paid well
cash is being paid well
all over the place so sometimes
you know you get hired to do a job and
you run out there and just didn't know
who you was really messing with like you
really thought you had a win you really
thought this was going to be an easy
snatch because they gave you fake
information oh
all that stuff is going to stay over
there all that Legacy stuff is going to
stay over there new stuff that we're
making is going to be exclusive to our
ecosystem on a game-to-game basis so
what they mean is if we can gouge you
yeah we'll throw it over there but if we
feel that this is for our community
we're going to lead us over here so you
don't get Starfield this I this is the
highest level of begging that I've ever
seen in my life you went and got the
principle because he didn't allow you to
play with his crayons
you're not playing with his crayons he
told you you could play with certain
amount of crayons you ain't playing with
the black and the red that's it you're
not getting those so you are upset right
now Sony is upset and I've never seen
an industry
try to come together
and block things but
I listen to Sovereign right yeah
and Sovereign always has this little
window into my third eye this little
he's the dude with the key and he he
opens this key
what if this play Ain't has has nothing
to do with video games what if this play
has absolutely nothing to do with Call
of Duty what if this player has
everything to do with unionization of
these individuals so they don't have
backing
Microsoft has no problem with it right
Microsoft said yeah we're willing to
allow unions to come in to give these
people
safety
so they're able to argue their case we
all know unions help out the employees
right
who doesn't want that right
you will have to say big business would
not want that because
if unions are Microsoft
then Union's gonna have to be in Sony
then unions is gonna have to be a
Nintendo and unions is going to have to
be an EA and unions is going to have to
be here and unions is going to have to
be there what if the big fight has
absolutely nothing to do with Call of
Duty and video games and the big fight
is actually being able to dictate to
these workers in the manner that they're
doing that is unconstitutional in some
matters because y'all hear crunch crunch
it will never happen again with a union
the way that you paying these guys will
never happen the felonious acts against
certain individuals will never happen
again
so what if the real play has absolutely
nothing to do with video games at the
heart of it and the money behind the
blocking has everything to do with
keeping unions out of big Tech
we got bigger problems
because it is because then the whole
base of the basis of it is protecting
the status quo right
I've already said on record
so he's fighting for their model yes 100
I said this is a model is old and
decrepit this this is a model philosophy
if I'll jump in the election I'm sorry
I'm not I'm not finished with it yeah
please please no please these these
because it looks baseless from the heart
of it right so then you know a lot of
times when there's a distraction going
on and you're looking at you're trying
to figure out what the argument is truly
about if they gave you 10 years here
what's the problem are we gonna get to
that one right if if if they're willing
to do this what's the problem so if if
somebody's meeting you on all your
demands and that's still not adequate
then that means that there's another
issue that didn't distracting you about
and this is not really truly the issue
sure for sure so I really honestly
believe and I'm listening to solving I'm
like damn I didn't have that take on it
before but if it's really about out
blocking unions
then this is the stance that you would
take because after this deal goes
through Activision is no longer under
the same type of uh problems that they
had prior and Microsoft already said
they're going to transform the building
from the top down right
so I really believe this is more about
unions and has less to do about video
games
in a sense that
once it does happen and once the union
does get into a trillion dollar company
then when it gets to Sony everything's
going to change when it gets to EA
everything is going to change there's
people sending money
and Dark Shadows and dark agencies in
the back and I think Amir Khan has felt
yes
she out of pocket look man this is this
is a week this was a week wow this
definitely came down broke the internet
I was like wow like soft said you know
we heard Rumblings you know from the
post first we heard three to one they're
going block from the rep right then we
heard
yo someone in the building you know 2-2
it's a Deadlock
deadlock goes through in Microsoft's
favor at that but I was like the ladies
were hurt so I'm like okay let's see how
this plays out so we knew the decision
was imminent felt it was coming this
week so it goes down
and I look at the basis of the argument
and then like okay but that's just
titles including Starfield red foal
you know Microsoft despite experiences
they've given the EU that it had
incentive no incentive to withhold games
for rival consoles so I'm probably like
oh That's the basis of the block I'm
like okay but then there's the thing
that really rubbed me wrong
so you're saying that you're going you
want to protect
other consoles you don't include
Nintendo right so Nintendo is is not a
console manufacturer not one of the
biggest so already I'm looking at it
like that is very strange how do you
even come to this conclusion of the
gaming Market not including Nintendo
right so that already I give a side out
for that but here's the thing if you
read this document right
there is no mention of the 10 years of
Call of Duty offered to PlayStation
there is no mention of the 10 years
offered to Nintendo switch there is no
there's no mention of the 10 years
offered to valve a competitor in the PC
space another platform
so if your basis is to protect and harm
competition when they're literally the
the home basis of the action is to get
offer it to more places where currently
it doesn't exist
they don't exist Call of Duty don't
exist there so to me it's like what are
you protecting because you're not you're
to me it the I'm under the impression
that you've already made your mind up
because of your document you don't even
include this what are we doing right and
this is not listen
I don't even care about Call of Duty
like that y'all know me like I don't
even care about this Joy this is not
about all you just because it's
Microsoft bro I don't care about that to
be honest I was like yo we're saying
y'all say you know me you know say like
I'ma be real like but I understood I'm
like all right you know what Kyle take
your bias out of it
it does make sense for them huge IPS
even though you don't play Call of Duty
like that you know what I'm saying and
the mobile that is something they want
to break into and that to me is a
legitimate argument jumping in that
space okay fine you want to look at that
you want to look at a new emerging
industry but if your reason
is to say yo they did something sheisty
with with redfall and Starfield with
xenomax and we got to protect consumers
we're not going to include Nintendo
we're not going to acknowledge any of
the offers made to show you then you
know what's crazy the valve situation to
me
was the dagger to their argument because
they said Microsoft is not to be trusted
you know how they get something they'll
break it down they'll give it to himself
right game valve and game literally said
yo we don't even need a contract
we are business relationship with them
we have full confidence in what
Microsoft is going to do based on our
relationships in the past this is a
competitor and say yo we'll put that on
the thing so what are we really doing
here and I gotta be honest though like
if you look at it objectively
to me this doesn't even make an argument
as to why it should not be there right
it you're literally doing your treating
Call of Duty like Minecraft
you keep your your letting and you're
showing in the xenomatic situation
you're letting the Legacy stuff stay
where it is right so I've got to just
look at what the facts present the facts
present that there's a bigger agenda
here there's something that someone is
trying to send a message and say no you
can't you know right for even if we have
those that the question is now the next
step we saw Brad Smith jump out
he's like yo watch out for peace we try
to do all the stuff you know they don't
want to do it okay fine then we have the
whole um the CMA aspect which is again
unionization which is actually important
you know what I'm saying Microsoft's
willing to do that yeah we have
activities say yo we're looking then we
got the EU right yo Microsoft didn't lie
bikes off didn't withhold anything with
the xenomac situation right so I don't
know it just seems to me that the agenda
was already pre preset they had their
preconceived notion of what they want to
do
um the question now is Microsoft gonna
fight it looks like they are very well
ready to go to war the question now is
okay this the battle and I think here's
the thing I do think that Jim Ryan is
he's shining right now though because
the the mission was accomplished the
mission was because regardless to
whatever how we feel how anything is
morally right this is genuinely is right
he set out to do what he had set out to
do the influence was is in the room I
always told people yo this man is
powerful in the EU this man dominated a
region right flying out or whatever
whatever everybody was laughing he there
listen there is some parroting going on
based on the lack of information a
certain group may have about the gaming
industry right so now it's up to
Microsoft to take it there and I'm
curious if it goes to that part where
they're willing to go all the way as far
as the FTC to get into this then they
talk about Supreme Court the thing about
this that does hurt them we could be
talking like a yeah bro like we could be
talking about who oh wow so you so you
could talk about you can forget about
Game Pass all that stuff this year you
know regardless of losses or whatever
but I will say this I ain't gonna front
this does with the political aspect now
jumping into this
as much as everything seems like a slam
dunk
who knows that that's just where I'm at
I I you know me I don't do religion
politics sexual I don't do that part
right
when that comes into the gaming part
all bets is off that's just where I'm at
so we'll see we'll see where this gonna
go but um yeah man this is this is crazy
I guess the last thing I want to say is
just that um
Again The Human Side
Activision so for the people who are
like yo y'all capping for some big
corporation like Microsoft
what's the alternative
y'all want 10 set to have Activision
yep
y'all want Activision to go out of
business and these game studios go away
what are we doing here see that's the
thing we got to stop with the Fanboys a
little bit because at the end of the day
uh yep here's the thing this is the
thing I don't like games disappearing I
come from and we just had pong on we
talk about all these companies some of
these joints don't even exist Midway
some of these people don't exist so you
don't want consolidation
you don't like Microsoft having it
the deal get blocked they go away
what happens if we happy we happy that
oh we we stop big Tech but big Tech
could have saved something so what are
we doing that's the thing one last point
you say that's the part that gets me
frustrated people keep saying they don't
want tell me what the alternative is
if this company's going out of business
and they got they're a disarray with
their organization so tell me what you
gonna do to save it that's the thing
people are talking about and it really
gets on my nerves because it's this
whole we're trying to fight against the
big guy thing but if the real big guy
which is 10 cent which let's not get
super political here but we know that
stance on the censoring of games we know
there's Sense on sexuality again we know
this dance on political stuff and if you
take that bag who knows what's gonna
happen to your game so let's be real
here that's what I've always said I'd
rather Microsoft than anybody save them
because no one else got that bag to do
it so what are we doing that's not
looking at it yeah and how you're
looking at it they're looking at it in
the mortality of the PlayStation yeah I
get that it's it and the young ones all
right the young ones that just got a
PlayStation 4 that is gravitate into a
PlayStation
that you ever had right okay cool you
play your Call of Duty you play your
stuff there and they just regurgitate
nonsense the older dudes that's been
around since the PlayStation was the
goats of one and two they are tied to it
right but this is it you knew and this
is for the older ones you knew what
they've done throughout the years
this is the real
perceived threat to their existence
because in all actuality
this deal happens in this manner
Game Pass gets solidified in a way that
the casuals have a choice now and to
where they get that Call of Duty or
whatever it doesn't matter if Call of
Duty is over there for the pay if it's
in Game Pass
for the game pass of fifteen dollars I'm
not going to say free no more I'm gonna
say 15. it's in Game Pass for 15 it's 15
versus 70. it's an attack of that model
a lot of casuals is going to choose the
15. oh for sure right the real estate
but what happens to the bottom line of
the old metrics to the old dude that's
over there that can't make it right
right they see that mortality and they
say there's no way to recover the reason
why I say Jim is a genius
oh absolutely absolutely to to to look
at your fan base and to stroke the
Flames of fear and tell you we have
nothing that can compete and then to go
to the FTC and the goal to the CM to go
to all these people and tell them we
have nothing that can compete with it
and they're a billion dollar company
yeah it's like and they're they're the
they're the perceived market leader
because the real market leader is
Nintendo they're the perceived market
leader and to have Nintendo excluded
from the conversation
makes it seem like it's a one-on-one
battle Yeah that it's just ingenious
let's just call it what it is
the thing that I hate about it is that
is this fear-mongering stuff right
that's right and and here's the thing
and I know a lot of people don't like to
hear this
but we are at inflection points I
remember Kong we just talked about it
you go to the phone call when you go to
the Blockbuster right right you're at
inflection points remember when when
Netflix and then was like yo we putting
the joints yeah digital we're not
shipping the dish no more yeah you know
what I'm saying there was a certain
industry like oh my God no oh my God no
you know what I'm saying
bro we've been around it like yo we go
to Dollar cabs okay you know what I'm
saying you call the cab company or you
wait outside for the yellow oh God
there's the app yeah did it come
straight to you Uber Uber
oh my God it's gonna make things you
know what I'm saying I get it but the
industry is going to go there right you
could hold on as much as you like
the industry is going to go there and
that's the thing that people have it's
the same thing people like oh the bomb
and pop stuff like that but you're gonna
sit there and tell me that you're not
using Amazon and shipping stuff to your
house you're not gonna sit there telling
me that y'all not have listen we love
midnight launches we love the history of
it y'all not gonna sit here and lock to
me and say y'all don't like sitting in
the comfort of your whole house and
downloading the digital game as well
there's a lot of people talking but I
see the numbers in the metrics show
different you know the numbers are also
the metrics show different between the
Banger and the free to play again we
have the data so we could fight and hold
on to the old school way and all of this
it's going to go there that's the thing
people have to understand and it's like
I get it you want to protect your
business model I get it but just don't
do it under disingenuous term like
you're not paying the whole picture bro
like that's all I'm saying it's
completely yeah yeah no it's completely
disingenuous and I think it goes to the
you know these statements that Phil
Spencer made in um in this other
interview with second request or the
second request yeah he was like the
arguments they're making is that
essentially PlayStation is trying to get
to grow larger
by shrinking Microsoft and taking away
their ability to expand the way they've
been doing and this is this is Sony Sony
is Sony is
blaming everybody else for their own
sins for their own bad decisions that
have Led Led them to this point [ __ ] and
that's the problem they knew where this
industry was going if they didn't they
got a bunch of dummies in charge but
they did because they spent 300 million
dollars on Geico
right and did nothing with it that is
their decision they decided to make
business moves to throw away to closet a
bunch of freaking ridiculously good IP
and solely focus on the narrative third
person type game and rely on third
parties like Call of Duty
but I love the fact that Sony was
allowed to jump into the cloud space
first and buy a guy Kai right yeah you
know what I'm saying that's all I'm
saying like they were allowed to try to
jump in the market that didn't exist yet
right right that so I I feel you on it
and to your point last thing I'd give it
right back to you is that you know the
thing that just involves me a little bit
is that the fact that
that whole business model has been about
taking stuff off of other things which
I'm not bad at but their whole business
so like the basis of this is for some
implied deception with Cinemax in two
games like that's what we do it all
right because no because they want to
hold on to the model that has made them
successful for as long as possible for
sure and they don't have the time and
resources to catch up to where Microsoft
is going so they're trying to attach an
anchor to Microsoft
this is the problem I have with Sony
again Sony used to be the disrupter Sony
did things in this industry that did
move it forward right now I look at them
they're holding this industry back by
going this route they are trying to hold
this industry back instead of letting it
progress like you said to the inevitable
future that we're all headed towards
whether we like it or not yeah and
that's my problem with Sony right now
that's why I look at them and this is
this has put a real doll on any shine I
had on Sony for me because they are
fighting against what they know is the
future that they had a chance to
capitalize on and they invested into all
that IP that they have locked away in
storage right now they could have their
own games and they could have their own
Game Pass service right now as we speak
they could have been the first ones out
the gate if they truly wanted to be but
they chose not to be because they had
the throne they had the easy money
rolling on in and that's what they took
and now that they see a threat to that
Throne now they're pointing fingers now
they're out here blaming everybody else
finding finding those sympathetic ears
at these regulatory bodies it just so
happens it aligns currently where we're
at in 2022 that these Regulators want to
make their own statements so here comes
Sony help us help us they're trying to
take away all of our all of our
mercenaries because we that's what we
lied on that's what they're doing now
the king is scared and he and but but it
is his own decisions that led to this
yeah what's crazy is that the gaming
industry is not the gaming industry is
not old at all and it's amazing to me
the amount of times that companies have
not taken the mistakes of their
predecessors to heart and continue to
make the same mistakes
and so we've done this a lot Xbox has
done it as well but when you look at you
know the PS3 the price point all you
need to do is look at all you need to do
is look at Neo Geo you needed to look at
3DO
um and with PlayStation you know with
the PS3 and the mistakes of the PS3 all
you need to do for Xbox was to look at
that and not make those mistakes
it's hubris and it's weird because like
it's like hey you look at that situation
and you're like hey that was Hubris they
didn't think things through they didn't
pay attention to the tea leaves like
pong said and and they continued to make
the same mistakes and this is this is
absolutely Sony
trying to buy time to catch up more and
be able to have something that's even
remotely competitive to what's coming
and in a lot of ways they've had to get
in bed with Microsoft with the Azure
server stuff right and that's going to
improve them on that end
but when it comes to at the end of the
day they know that those first party
games are coming whether they're all
bangers or not we don't know but they're
coming they're going to be able to
overwhelm them with sheer with the sheer
amount of stuff that's going to be
coming out
so you know and if you're going to
continue to make these AAA games that
are 100 million plus take five years to
make
five you know five years to make you're
gonna have to make more of those or one
of those service based games is going to
have to be a fortnight level hit right
so they're in a precarious position and
I get Jim I understand Roger I get it I
get it I just think again it's a big
filibuster that I don't know how long it
goes you only you're only going to get
so much time right yeah
um
I don't ever see Microsoft stopping this
fight though yeah we gotta see what's
gonna happen we gotta see what's gonna
happen and the sad part for us is
content creators I gotta keep for God
doing the damn Tire because it's not off
I'm like please this thing gonna be over
right I'm tired of talking about it we
always got this time it looks
fascinating though because it is it is
additional time right it is
yeah and we're getting information that
we never never yeah
this is where how Sony left the market
a possibility
a distinct possibility no you are
literally upsetting the dude that can
smash you you came over to your table
and gave you cocktail fruit and say yo
you can have cocktail with fruit for me
for the next week and you said that's
inadequate
trying to be your friend at all costs
but you sitting there talking behind his
back telling people lies about him
we don't know we don't know if you're
really gonna come through with that then
the bully the bully is gonna just turn
to you and smash you and get you out of
there because you know what
the bully had respected all that you've
done
for the industry and remember without
you the bully wouldn't exist it was a
fact right they looked over at you
trying to take over the living room and
Bill Gates said hell to the no no no all
right
we all tied together but there's a
moment in time where you got to cut that
available court and get rid of that baby
you gotta go score sure
in so much trouble you got it that's it
okay go we got to take him off here
there's only one that's me one and
that's me
so y'all didn't want to push them
forward and I see these dudes capping
someone you know she only she only did
she showed me to tell Sony to put their
first party games in their wax system
they see they service why don't you do
that why don't you care for that why
don't you get off Xbox dudes timelines
worrying about Game Pass and why don't
you worry about that weak system that
you got over there that's holding
everything back
they're snitching oh my God I'm I'm
bringing it to the hood I'm employing
everybody
[ __ ] man and these dudes just
actively out here snitching take a whole
style let's go over at that box and and
I really want the hood dudes to
understand are you gonna really rep the
alcohol industry oh baby
Apple was doing all this dirt but then
when he got caught he pointed fingers he
want to act like it ain't him
it's you it's you so y'all want to sit
here and wrap these raps I want y'all
everybody
this is a tape I'm gonna put this tape
behind my back
[Laughter]
it's the dude that's accusing the dude
of murder is the murderer
is lying on everybody else
an official statement from an
organization that
in it you could tell everything is a
supposition everything is if this
happens this could happen this could
possibly happen that's why I said
Minority Report stuff man yeah and then
and then they and then Microsoft with
the deals that they made with with valve
and with Nintendo they gave you the time
frame so you're saying in 10 years this
could possibly happen if Joyce wasn't
even ended that was crazy I was like yo
wow they they made up they buy it before
the information came on but we could go
on in circles with this fun topic let's
see what happens but we it listen it is
now just because Microsoft said they
fighting so more of this to come sorry
y'all I know we know we're getting out
of it but it's interesting it is very
interesting no doubt let's get these
secrets we have a ton of super chat
about if you want no I got them it's
just the last one is the NC ghost of
love so if anything comes up after that
yes he goes to Lowes
we got drunken ninja member for two
years five dollar Super Chat no I feel I
don't like we got that yeah we got that
never mind flame green my brother cringe
yes yes we got that okay Spartan go 17.
two pound Super Chat Paul Tassie is
asking if Starfield can release on
Playstation 5. I just answered him and I
told him no
[Laughter]
then we got Matt Jimenez member for one
month let's put the crest in the top of
Matt Jimenez he just gifted five IOP
memberships
that's a beautiful thing thank you
appreciate that man appreciate you bro
then we got Brett Bingham two dollar
Super Chat Lord Cognito to the FTC are
you implying yeah
I have some questions
Fargo 17 Again two pound Super Chat also
the EU told the FTC stop the cap bro
it was looking over at him really that's
right it was like yo don't say we said
that yo
ain't no receipts
because the thing is because the thing
is there's no receipts like how you can
defend that there's no receipts but now
you lying lying
uh let me see Brett bigger five dollars
we chat I don't see why the FTC is going
to to go against the only American
company in the industry for competitors
benefit Jim Dale Ryan is a is a what is
a snake he's outside man Mr Martinez
that's funny there we go Highlander
001 10 super chat shareholder meeting
call this week Microsoft and ABK cannot
do any deals till this is done if this
takes years shareholders may vote to
walk away shareholders are not Gamers
that if if it isn't a stalemate that
would be the only and again if that
happens and like pong said you need plan
b or c but the fact of the matter is
this was this would really put I think
an ability to derail everything that
they planned with Game Pass right yeah
because now
or they have to grow considerably slower
and a little purchase here a little
purchase there
um
renegotiate too they got to renegotiate
with ABK yeah absolutely absolutely
exactly then we've got Phase 23 beacan
why twenty dollar Super Chat what do you
got for kids Microsoft a no-show at the
game awards PS5 won November NPD and
dollar and unit sales Federal Trade
Commission sues Microsoft Xbox has more
Studios than PlayStation and still can't
deliver Microsoft is not having a good
year they definitely have a good week
though that you uh don't purchase
anything from continue to play where you
at
because I noticed you like to rep
stitches so having the fun over there
with your snitching
okay we got lucious Augustus remember
for one year five dollars
Nintendo Gamers want it Nintendo Gamers
want it steam wants it Xbox game Gamers
want it CWA wants it let's see I guess
ABK wants it APK employees won it the
only person who doesn't is Sony Sony's a
person
the CWA is the union yeah the union ah
the union yeah the Union
then we have Max arfi five pound Super
Chat the FTC claims the FCC claims are
bogus it adds into the pot however if
the EU and UK Regulators also see issues
with the deal the UK CMA is a different
Beast right it is different than the
European Union
paid off the most by Jim yeah
yeah we got Highlander oh oh what ten
dollar Super Chat Lena Khan has said
that she does not want concessions as
she said in an interview hoglaw covered
that all it takes is one to say no to
kill the deal do they know this is video
games this is not Facebook
then we got Tom for Toonami remember
from six months ten dollars for chat
it's a stalling tactic hoping that the
EU or CMA also block at that point they
probably think Microsoft walks with
having more than one fight if that
happens Microsoft should just play
Playstation games and just should just
play playstate PS game with their
billions exactly but that's what that my
that's what PlayStation wants them to do
is adhere to the status code because for
whatever reason well it's two things
they don't think they can compete in
what Microsoft is doing B and they maybe
think that no matter what if they
continue to play the same game Microsoft
still can't compete with them just
because they have they got the market
share they got their minds here they got
the Mind chair right we talked about
that before then we got Top Shot
the FTC shot themselves by narrowing the
gaming Market as high-end consoles
because they just defined Sony as a
monopoly Sony has more than 50 percent
yep yeah interesting I'm assuming
Microsoft's lawyers will bring that up
yeah
risk it for the biscuit all right the
seven eight dollar Super Chat when this
happened I didn't get mad at all exactly
because I knew that Microsoft is now
less likely to have to provide
concessions Microsoft lawyers don't play
are you implying that I said that
somebody might lose 10 years if they
will be hilarious yes they put Sony on a
year-to-year basis if they put them on
what how good are you this year to us
but it's guaranteed on Nintendos
guaranteed but you you gotta come see us
every year the Year for evaluation and
if we don't like what you did last year
guess what happens thank you you want 60
frames that's gonna cost you oh yeah
yeah
y'all get a special rate I get 10 90
yeah I get yeah we'll see what happened
then we got uh the Lucius Augustus two
dollars to protect the FTC has lost six
of their past six cases oh and six that
is true
then we got time from Toonami ten dollar
Super Chat from Tom from Toonami Phil
Phil if the deal passes coming out on
stage with two women on each arm a big
white fur hat all right Sony stop what
you're doing cause I'm about to ruin the
image and the style that's how I used to
wow not the bars not the bars yeah the
pimp game
now we got J1 member for one month Lord
bronze just wonder what the Fallout
would look like if the deal falls
through lots of bridges burned and money
lost great show and great guests thank
you thank you appreciate it that deal
don't go through remember what I said
um they will end a whole lot faster than
you thought
we got Italian clowns remember for 22
months
glad to see pong on today yes yes
fantastic long overdue
great and we have clowns again member
for one year five dollar Super Chat Xbox
will win the FTC lawsuit no doubt
Microsoft ain't gonna throw the flag in
back
[Laughter]
then we got Matt arthny again 10 pound
Super Chat the CMA are also slightly
against them defending Sony in all of
their documents claiming Microsoft has
social media dominance over Sony also
like Gamers out here are posting their
KD unlimited
it is it yeah it does it doesn't seem
like they're protecting consumers it
seems like they're protecting the status
quo and the market leader that's what it
feels like Lord Metroid remember for one
year five dollars per chat meanwhile at
Nintendo's headquarters we signed the
10-year deal for COD nah that's just for
good PR how is Zelda coming along
looking nice
so funny then we got post up ten dollar
Super Chat so EU stated that if
Microsoft offered concessions the deal
can be closed
so the eu's part the CMA has changed
their tone from phase one regarding
software and cloud services January will
be interesting yeah we're gonna see that
next date they started going away yeah
it's not um
max arthny ten pounds of the chat once
again with how political this FTC move
is feels like this thing was getting
thrown into court from the beginning
without Sony needing to rock the boat
against Nintendo and EA Sony should have
said nothing said zero quite possibly
because again it Lena Khan came in to
try to be strong on on trust busting
right that was her story so who better
to to start that off than Microsoft but
you you acting you're telling Sony not
to be who they are snitch gonna come out
man yeah yeah you're gonna tell and he
tell us man
watch that dude then we got Stitch to
the uh ten dollar Super Chat on the
unlikely event that the merger does not
happen do you all think that the
Activision board would vote to revoke
any contract done with Sony and create a
new partnership with Microsoft I'll be
honest I I think up front there might be
a little little funniness but at the end
of the day Mighty dollars
know if
when you get billionaires in in in in
the you get on their nerves they will
Scorch the Earth to get past you right
they can be Petty for sure it's gonna be
a petty situation because if you're
costing somebody something you're
causing a headache when it's not
necessary
I don't know I think Tony's gonna you
know they burnt a lot of bridges to me
backdrops that stock drops here and
those billionaires will get their bank
accounts going yeah we got to see okay
then we have pragmatic Eagle member for
two years five dollar Super Chat just
want to be Petty and remind everyone
that I told you about 70 games it would
be the industry standard I was in rare
company I love iops
we get into that we got Dragonheart Yobe
17 months or gold hashtag peace love
life I said the same thing [ __ ] I said
that if this deal doesn't go through
Activision dies then what IP sold off to
different Studios IPS might not be the
same after the Fallout if it fails that
is very true
no what they did what they care about is
Sony they don't care about anything else
they think like those exclusive games
sell anything don't sell anything
that's the thing the real Fanboys are
the ones that really want this to happen
yeah
we got NC ghost of low road
specific
FTC didn't do their homework Microsoft
was the wrong ones to block just because
they will support unions the FTC them
them the FTC Democrats support that by
doing what they're doing they're going
against what their party supports wrong
play right so that's a huge problem it
is one of those things again it's like
lean the Khan was in a position where
you're dabbed if you do you're dabbed if
you don't yeah and she chose she chose
violence you know so we'll see Mike with
the 20 Super Chat everyone knows the FTC
suit won't hold up in court even if even
FTC themselves this whole thing is not
about protecting industry or consumers
it is politically motivated and led by
an overzealous 33 year old looking for
cloud wow
wow
then we have Necromancer Zale member for
one year ten dollars of attack what's
sad is that it's up to unelected empty
suits that know nothing of the industry
to make the decisions it's true then
they aren't elected officials they're
appointed officials right so they have
agendas immediately you know they have a
dentist so yeah we'll see we got doobie
remember for 23 months Lord bronze did
the FTC or Sony mention death Loop and
ghostwire Tokyo weird that they're
mentioning unreleased games good one
that's bars right there I like that
then we have NC ghost of row road again
twenty dollars for chat Gamers need to
recognize the industry is going to
change it's not about console anymore
Amazon Google tencent Etc all know it's
money in game they all have bigger Banks
than Sony I'd rather see Xbox get it
than anyone else yes I've been saying
this forever keep the mother dudes out
because they don't know what the hell
they're doing we're already seeing what
Amazon try to do we've seen what Google
tried to do I don't want big franchises
going to them straight no doesn't want
it either he wants a healthy industry
exactly okay that one was the last one
then we get but man night wolf 3186 5
super chat love you guys so I've been in
and out of the ABK news but no now know
how big it is my question is are you
guys still confident that it will still
go through Yeah Yeah question just take
times again the the it was interesting
the mentioning of the the stockholders
and and you know how how long it's going
to be before this is put off but again
Microsoft makes money hand over this in
way many other areas so this is this is
still relatively small to Microsoft
right it's an Xbox thing but it's
relatively small and they have to pay
out two to three billion if they walk
away so that's on the shareholders as
well so exactly yeah it looks like we
got I got time I got it okay uh 15 Super
Chat what about Collins thoughts about
why would you be a Xbox gamer unless you
unless you like Acquisitions I can name
I can name one you can play with others
rather than yourself great show Lords
and punks shout out to Tyler just sort
of different different side different
frequency on that one you know what I'm
saying so we just disagree on that one
but we've kind of talked a lot about
this yeah yeah this is that it's just
funny yeah yeah that's always
alternative versus exactly yeah
then we got doc 50 five dollars in the
chat with Game Pass you can drop in and
out pay 45 for three months play all the
games you want and then bounce that's a
deal
that is true choice
we good
yeah we're good we're quite all right
let's get this thing flying all right
this one is King I'll set him up
seven dollars me
saying knowledge bro so uh yeah
Microsoft for raising prices on new
first party games built for series exit
s to 70 in 2023 for the Motorsport red 4
and Starfield will be among the first to
reflect the change Phil Spencer was on
the second request podcast and uh he
said probably something that we
conscious of and the impact it has on
our customers there's multiple things
that we could price on our platform he
said something basically had to give in
terms of us continuing to run the
business with the economic realities of
the increased cost the thing that we
decided to announce we haven't raised
any prices today because we just wanted
to give consumers a heads up on what's
going to come in the next year is that
for our largest AAA games with the
retail prices going from 60 to 70 and
we're in nowhere we're in no way the
first move on this meaning obviously or
take two has been their um Activision
Sony EA everybody everybody really
Warner like they it was funny looking at
the like just the the fall releases this
year right a lot most of the third party
releases seventy dollars yeah pretty
concludes he said uh we had not we had
not we had held off as long as we could
and we we still like the fact that our
subscription is at the price it's at our
console with our Series S is the lowest
price current gen console on the market
and managing the business the move we
decided to make was on the retail price
of our larger largest games and it just
really it's really just the cost basis
of building those games and ensuring we
can run the business in the right way
for customers so uh King this is your
topic this is the hot one seventy
dollars where you at
unacceptable oh it's unacceptable and
and and I'm talking about as a whole
talk to me as a whole is unacceptable
you have to find new creative ways in
order to give uh value to the consumer
you know especially in this economic
crisis that we're in right now inflation
is ridiculous I showed somebody that I
pay eight dollars for eggs yeah or a
dozen of eggs I pay eight dollars I can
go to the store I can buy three items
and it comes up to 30 bucks
and um if you have a household that's at
least five people strong
um to be honest with you the cost of
living is going up and the
the payouts has either gone down or
stayed the same right so
when you're looking at seventy dollar
games
and I know a lot of Xbox dudes is going
to say uh yeah but we have Game Pass so
we can offset it with Game Pass
that is not an excuse for somebody
that's in India
right so somebody who has the poor
internet or somebody in some place of
the world where Game Pass isn't
prevalent right so I'm looking uh to
that consumer because also we say in
seventy dollars here but in Canada it's
like a hundred dollars
yeah right uh all over the prices change
and the price is jumping I know people
saying well if you can't handle ten
dollars King uh you need to shut up
sometimes it's not always about you
sometimes it's always about your your
fellow gaming that's next to you yeah
maybe I can handle the ten dollars but
can he handle the ten dollars right
right so again I believe industry wise I
mean yeah Microsoft is the last Bastion
of it but I also believe
this is uh preemptively
uh in in in light of this new
acquisition they know that a lot of
their games is going to be on other
platforms you can't have a disparity in
price and models right so you can't have
the same game that you're selling on
PlayStation for seventy dollars and
sixty dollars on your your platform
that's anti-competitive all right so
again that's not a sale that's going on
in your store for a short period of time
that you can monetize and and control
that is a real competitive Advantage
whereas you're selling the same product
for a different price so this is
something that has to be facilitated in
order to show that there's competition
free competition across the boards when
it comes to the the financial aspects of
these games the price prices have to be
the same across the board so that's the
reason why third parties went kind of
first in this area because third parties
sell across the board so they can't have
a price for a game be this price and
that price so good we understand that we
got upset when it turned to the console
manufacturers with their titles because
they're the owners and the purveyors of
their games we thought that the console
providers will hold these games at a
certain price but now that we know
that Sony sells uh let's say the
baseball right so if you wanted to buy
MLB to show out of Game Pass well then
you have to pay 70 bucks right Sony
can't have the game be 60 bucks on their
platform and sell it at 70 bucks here so
there's the same thing right it's the
standard now Microsoft is the last uh
Bastion of hope that had to fall we
understand why I just don't agree with
it as an industry standard I'm
respectful I'm respectful look you know
this is a big one man Paul you know
where you're at 70 you know looks like
Microsoft was able to avoid it for the
most part and then you know kind of got
a precursor a little bit a little bars
early something might be cooking but now
it is here and you know on this eventful
week that's right that's right people
forget that happened towards the
beginning of the week yeah
um yeah I will never never ever ever as
a consumer as a customer defend any
million billion trillion dollar company
raising prices for the consumers when
they have been reporting and celebrating
record revenue and profits for years
okay never this is a situation where
these companies were like oh we're just
breaking even or we're a little bit
under we got to expand we gotta do this
we got to do that great
that's fine
um I will never ever just as a flat out
as me as my opinion ever defend it I
gave the smoke to all everybody who's
done it prior to Microsoft and I'm going
to give it them the same it's wrong it's
wrong from like King said an industry
standard it's just wrong for all these
companies to say we're making all this
money but guess what we need to know
from you listen I'm never going to do
that again like King said with the with
the Game Pass arguments and all that
kind of stuff those are separate
conversations in my point of view those
are values you're not going to use the
Game Pass I'm not going to because guess
what buffer let me let me let me go
ahead and give you a little something
from that buffer this is a precursor to
your game pass going on so what are you
going to say then are you going to still
say it's okay are you right replying
that game pass may go up as well I'm
implying that sir because now guess what
the greatest value in gaming just became
even more valuable right so right now
and that's a strategy that's a business
strategy strategy a separate
conversation I can have that
conversation from a business point of
view as to why and I've said that in the
past when Sony did it I said I don't
like it yeah but they knew their
customers would pay it so they're going
to do it right that's the way it works
we are being conditioned and this is not
the end of this okay if they open
tomorrow they could do a hundred dollar
games they would do it but guess what
they're already conditioning us with
ultimate editions they're already
conditional facts oh yeah we paid a
hundred right right exactly already paid
I just paid about it for midnight
yeah
they're they're conditioning us for this
so where is your line my line has
already been here and you've already
crossed it now with 70 now again I'm not
the guy who sits here and says I'm
voting with my wall never buying another
70 that doesn't happen either okay
because value comes into the equation
thank you but from a pure standpoint
just a pure customer standpoint I'm
never going to okay or cheer on any
company in any the industry saying
they're going to charge me more for the
same and let me end it on this real
quick because I know we got we got other
topics to get to let me know this you
start doing this listen this nonsense
with week one patches week two patches
servers being oh can't handle we didn't
know this was going to be such a popular
game all of that nonsense that we have
now gotten yes it's great they can fix
their games where we usually always put
on that square he do not but listen yeah
you're going to start raising prices my
expectations of the Complete product
that I'm supposed to be getting with
that 70 now takes another step up oh for
sure I want you to see this nonsense go
away
um so yeah overall I'm just not I don't
like it I hate it I think it was wrong I
would have liked to see Microsoft and
Xbox being who they are to be the leader
to say no we are good we just got done
reporting all these records we are not
going anywhere and I understand it's
King's Point about the seventy dollars
then you drop Call of Duty back down to
60 once you acquire that that's what you
do in my opinion and I know that goes
against the shareholders that goes
I get all that but I'm saying as a
they had a chance to continue to be a
leader they've done a lot of great
things consumer facing they've created a
lot of win-win scenarios for Publishers
devs themselves and us and I would like
to see that continue here that's out
Lord saw 70 dollars we are here
over here oh I mean no it's just
yeah us being Who We Are
I personally look at it I I it's two
different people who are looking at it
right you have the consumer mean
who like pong like King unacceptable
unacceptable
you're making money hand over fists
you're not losing money
overall
why they got to raise prices up right
and I completely
agree and understand but again the
situation for me exists in that I do
have the buffer of Game Pass right it's
not like that that alternative doesn't
exist so if it didn't the argument will
be even stronger but as a consumer as
somebody who that you know puts a lot of
hard work into
having being able to have the things
that they want yeah
I'm never happy about having to give you
more
as somebody who talks about the industry
has paid attention to the industry
for essentially all their life
I understand
where this comes from right and
sometimes we have to step back from that
and not again never never abiding by it
just understanding
everything costs more everything costs
more if we continue to want these 150
million dollar AAA games that look
beautiful and take advantage of of our
brand new hardware that we don't that we
don't want to have 10 versions of the
game and be cross-gen across platforms
it's just the reality of it
um and for them it's the easiest thing
to do when we talked about what were
these changes that were going to happen
we I think all of us said the same thing
yeah it's going to be individual game
sales it's not going to be the service
yet it's definitely not going to be the
consoles because that's just a bad look
and we know it was a bad look on Sony's
part although
well shout out to uh one of our
listeners from India I don't have it
right in front of me he let us know that
the price of uh the Xbox in India it was
a has gone up multiple times yeah I
didn't hear about that not game pass the
console proper right so we have to
really look at the picture very broadly
and not sort of in our Silo only because
the broad picture paints a different
picture yeah
um
at the end of the day
again and this being the old man let's
go
back in the day we paid a whole hell of
a lot for these games and it was
different because
the cost that they incurred making those
games was directly passed on to you
immediately they weren't eating that
cost especially Nintendo Nintendo
definitely but the reasons were tangible
if you had a game with a backup battery
that was going to cost you that much
more right
um and that that was essentially it why
the prices were so Bonkers right you you
needed if you had a you know whatever
50-hour RPG on a cartridge you needed
that backup battery we had you know
16-man cartridges exactly yeah
it gave you 3D Graphics exactly so the
realities were different anymore exactly
so now this is where it's just the shy
extend that just charging so you're
going back to the argument that we had
when we went to CDs and why is the CDs
no no no dollars when the CD should have
been ten dollars for the games right
that's you going back to that old
argument well this is the thing right
and this one this ice comes up in there
exactly so there's been this
homogenization of the of the process
where none of that is included in here
there's no specialty chip on a cartridge
there's no special thing that they put
on a disk they're just charging you more
so and again I remember when we read
this one is digital when we first went
all digital we was like oh my God we're
gonna get so much
how is a digital product ever not brand
new
I didn't determine a used digital
product that's crazy
it was an option it might happen yeah oh
no I know that I know they were trying
to throw everything at the wall for Xbox
one I know that it's just hey this is
where we're at I would not be surprised
in the next 10 years they go up at
another ten dollars it's just the nature
of things not happy about it one bit
yeah there are alternatives and I might
it would be foolish to sit here and be
like Microsoft isn't banking on you
taking that alternative route that is
the point that is this pushing you right
there yeah and we always have to
remember and we always have to remember
as much as we we love these consoles we
love these platforms we love these games
the end goal of each and every one of
these companies is to make money
actually not even to make games is to
make money
and they're going to do that any which
way they can no Absolutely I'll jump in
um yeah it's nothing really important to
be said you know obviously
the way I look at it is that you know I
agree with Paul in a sense that they
have the opportunity based on who they
are and what they know to kind of set
that tone and they did initially they
didn't say hey we're not going to be 70.
look I get economics I get all that but
I'm a consumer first you know at the end
of the day I'm a consumer there's
nothing popping about paying more money
there's nothing I don't look anyway
cooler to someone else because I paid
more Brands
you pay more means more quality no it
does come on
that's this fake dude was trying to
stuttle other dudes in gaming which is
the weirdest Flex I've ever seen yo I'm
paying 70 for mine like use a fool for
that like I don't I don't know where you
get off thinking you're stuck knowing
somebody because you paid seven dollars
you don't want to own all your stuff
[ __ ] you need to own it
like we already know what you doing with
that at the end come on now listen we
come from you owning it you gotta have
it you got to be yours even if you play
it once how I consume is how I choose to
consume it if someone's gonna give me a
deal to make me consume all of these
things that like long said back in the
day I wish I had something like games so
you okay
little 13 year old Cog would have had a
service that I could mom was like yo you
got money for one game I wasn't even
about the game I had to go remember that
yeah so I had to go on my own to get it
right and then when you finally got that
little pocket money and you got up uh
you go to that store you'll be like damn
only guys
Revenge it's either last battle you had
to make tough decision but you made the
wrong decision that was it bro it was
big and then when you go to trade it
they were like five and they're like
fine you saw the realities of Economics
right before your y'all guys you just
paid the 60 beads you you put it this
game was garbage and then you gotta come
back I traded him and be like okay um
for your credit
um you will get ten dollars
you want to go post the little place the
worst part is they give you ten dollars
you take that ten dollars credit put it
towards the new 70 game or whatever did
you getting and they put the sticker on
your game for 59.95
you saw the game you traded that you got
ten dollars for back on the shelf and
they talking about yeah for five dollars
below retail price
as a gamer
you're supposed to get the games at the
cheapest price that you can get them
listen because you want to get the most
that you can get the most I could get
bro okay I'm trying to eat you know what
I'm saying so at the end of the day all
this fake flexion I'm not with that so
I'm never going to be about raising
prices and not you know and then the
other the other part people forget it's
like
we getting hustled anyway because at the
end of the day forget about we getting
hustled on the back end because you get
the game gotta get the season pass
DLC
micro transaction you know what I'm
saying let's get out fortnite so all
this free to play bucks yay free fam you
know what I'm saying like we don't
bought all this other stuff some of them
are even more egregious when they free
because they throwing so much yes you
know what I'm saying and the expansion
and all that so it's like look at what
the industry is going so I'm never going
to cap for that no Corporation if I give
you this scenario how about those how
about games go back to 49.95 uh but
every game has Loot Crate
[Laughter]
oh so in order to facilitate this bread
they give us the option to purchase into
their ecosystem whatever the game is
even if it's a single player game we got
loot crates you got skins you got pay to
win got all that stuff in it
in order to get more dial out of us but
we go back to 50 we go back to that 50
with guaranteed 99 50 with guaranteed
loot crates that's what we're doing
everything
you know what happens then you start
getting that I call that that ashy
Spartan syndrome oh cause you start the
game up and your man look real ashy did
you see your man you know when you buy
two okay my man was actually oh bro you
know you see you see them dudes running
around and you know they pay all VCS
but they prey on us right for that they
pray because they know your man is dead
he got to fly the lawsuit and you did
with the ashy jump off the default
overall 69. you don't like the pro case
yeah nah nah I'm not about that so
anyway my thing is this and the other
thing is you know while I'm really gotta
I gotta comment I gotta come at Xbox a
little bit because it's like the other
issue that I had this conversation with
Maddie is that this is why I got to give
Sony credit
with the physical
because now you're charting a 70 and
let's be rural especially the Xbox's
case there are times when you get the
disk and it's a paperweight it is
literally just a conduit to get you to
download online and you can't play
offline so that's another thing that
they've got to fix because I heard the
obviously that we've heard they're
making strides in that you know what I'm
saying but at the end of the day I
should not pick up halo infinite and it
is a paperweight without the internet
connection
period so you've got to show me the
value and then on top let's just keep it
all the way 100 you of all people with
your first party output this year it
don't look good it don't look good to be
like yours next year though right I
understand
all that does
well that does now is put so much
pressure on these titles to be good
because now you said you don't get no
first party major AAA joints in 2022.
we're gonna get into the game awards
we're gonna get into the game
then now you saying next year when the
games that finally people waiting for
yeah Starfield red 4 4 to 70. the
pressure on them is going to be immense
because these games are gonna happen
people will be like we waited all for
this and we pray don't let nothing be
slip on a banana peel so we just got to
keep it real you know what I'm saying so
that's just where I'm at I know the
industry's shifting people gonna hit me
with the the economics and I get it I'm
always going to be a consumer first
that's just how I rock I'm all with
that's why what I hear about Game Pass
absolutely I'm in like you telling me
this amazing service that's gonna have
day and day and that definitely buffers
them I will give them that but don't you
want to own I don't care about all that
that's fake flexing these dudes nobody
ain't getting we don't want to show your
stuff nobody ain't got stock in these
companies to be flake flexing about 70
stop that's just internet gang banging
that's you throwing it up for the second
I get what you doing but you're not
that's not real real is what Paul said
when that pandemic hit people lost their
jobs yeah you got people out here
struggling but I think there's nothing
more hurtful when I'm in a party chat
and we're like yo we about to play the
game you know your man be like hey ain't
got the season pass got it you know what
I'm saying and then I could be like yo
fam get that game pass and I get gift
through that game pass off of that what
and you and that's that's real life no
more this thing was yeah when when when
people you know the pandemic hit yeah
and you know these consoles is here and
people had the TCL televisions and um
I mean they they TVs wasn't up to stuff
and and you know the pandemic helped
them down so in the games with the
seventy dollars TCL with a seventy
dollar come on man y'all gotta get out
of this listen at the end of the day
it's more of those type of people than
they are of these oh we got everything
seven like that's just the reality no
but on the internet though you can have
everything yeah but Twitter Twitter
everyone's lit I know they they got
Lambos they got drop tops with the
suicide yeah they driving right past me
yeah I understand so it's just like yeah
that's it then like I said just gonna
put a lot of pressure on them the only
thing that saves them is yeah the game
pass is a buffer for them right but I
like plong said like so I've said
don't think gamepad's gonna stay that
price forever
because once the first party Cadence
like they want with the with the
quarterly you best believe and then the
call our Activision deal does go through
you best believe at some point that
value probably because I I know about
you but I get a Netflix Netflix is
raising the price is now this remember
that oh I get that every year like every
other day yeah
27 as soon as they change their boss
exactly so that's all it is I mean
that's all so it's just something to be
kind to know but yeah that was that
let's move or unless y'all got anything
else yeah let's go yeah Crown your lord
sorry all right yeah we got a couple of
them hold on a second
they better drop that family playing
real soon to bustle my feelings
yeah cause I'll put the whole block on
I put my whole block on that selling I'm
selling family passes
yo you better be nice to me so you get
on that plane
you got access this blocks
it's talking sideways you were snitching
we got Tai casara it's three dollars of
attack every company always bragging
about their profits yeah yeah I should
shut up
we got Tony Bryant remember for two
years 28 months actually Lord gold great
show is always happy to be here live 70
games from Microsoft is a precursor to
Cod being multiplayer still and Game
Pass will go up and the family plan will
multi-plat that's what it is
uh and Game Pass will go up but the
family plan will offset that games have
to be quality I think that's what
Microsoft's game is like every bad
everything that's gonna they're gonna do
that doesn't look consumer friendly yeah
they have an offset for yeah which is
unlike PlayStation they don't have an
offset for a lot of that no they just
got an onset
yeah we got night wolf 3186 five dollars
which had to pong's point about the 70
games how does it look for Microsoft
when they announced that before
releasing their 2023 lineup they must be
Killer games I mean they had to get in
front of it right they needed to get do
it say it as and they kept to their word
they weren't raising prices this year
yeah yeah and the ABK deal affects it as
well because if we got the APK deal
through and then raised their prices
that's exactly what that position was
talking about exactly exactly exactly so
then we have the rubber knob member for
one year two dollar Super Chat more
money mo snitches oh wow wow we gotta
get these guys stop yes I know they
going crazy are we good then we have
Dorian Gray two lots of attack situation
in India was due to exchange rates yes
it was due to exchange rates but
nonetheless prices going up
exactly that's it all right cool let's
get the last one we are here this is
attic's topic unfortunately but we will
Breeze through the game awards
came and went a lot to discuss you know
about what was shown and you know
staying out events and also who was
maybe not present so uh yeah let's talk
about it uh game boys let's start with
you pong you know what did you feel
about it you know the show overall any
standouts and then obviously the
question that a lot of people wanted is
about Xboxes oh presents of course uh
listen uh overall I look at every show
in a vacuum I'm not one of those people
that compares
um but just looking at how Keely has
evolved to shows and again personal
feelings about Keely aside I think he's
great for the for the industry he's
obviously done wonders uh to bring more
eyes onto this industry to create this
uh kind of really really kind of a you
know celebrity type Oscars you know that
kind of thing which is great it needs to
happen for the number one entertainment
industry in the world so
um I think that he did a fantastic job
he's learning um ever since I jumped in
and started doing podcasting and started
covering these events from this point of
view I've seen him grow and really start
to hone in and kind of really you know
just cut back on a lot of the garbage
that people complain about and get a
much more efficient uh type show and I
think this one showed that off I thought
the pacing outside of you know Kratos uh
taking a little bit longer than expected
are you implying that keighley took that
feedback well we said we don't need to
let people speak you're like yeah we let
we let them speak now what yeah yeah now
what now uh too much uh no listen I
think the patient was great I thought he
cut down a lot of the stupid commercials
that didn't really fit yes
advertising what's much better uh
overall and I thought that uh you know
overall the presentation was fantastic
this year I really do think that he's
got to find some way however if you were
going to call this the game awards show
okay the awards and the people behind
those Awards do have to somehow get
their time somehow someway and I don't
know what the answer is to that yeah but
there has to be something he can do
because they do fly through a lot of the
rewards and this is the only time these
people are going to be recognizing that
in that way like we have the golden
joysticks we got the baftas we got all
that other stuff but this one is where
everybody's on right this is what
everybody's watching so um but yeah
overall again if I had to give it a
grade I'd give it a solid B
um for sure uh standout wise
um listen there was a ton here again I'm
a grazer there's very little there's
very few genres I don't play so I always
come from these shows with something and
this one probably I could go through 15
of them but let me give you a few
standouts here 80s too
you know again I expected let him come
back um with a sequel but a lot of
people didn't because that's not what
they're known for right they're known to
go try something different but with the
success of Hades what that did for them
what that did for the roguelike genre in
general yeah
got people into it um they had to come
back with this this is going to be big
for them it's going to fuel their future
so 80's too beautiful awesome
um and then right after the of course I
mentioned it earlier Judas
coming from his new studio ghost story
um we've heard some Rumblings uh that
this has not been the smoothest uh
production for them that they've gone
through so through some turmoil but
listen
younger people who never got to play the
original bioshocks um or even System
Shock if you want to go back that far go
back you don't understand the genius
behind Ken Levine and his teams right
that that he is one of those guys that
can come through with a game that does
something so different
um that it leaves that Mark on you for a
very long time and I think Judas
interestingly enough that you know he
can't use the Bioshock obviously 2K has
got the rights but he's obviously doing
his uh spiritual successor yeah right
that's a lot of influences you can see
it yo Bioshock started out in the ocean
uh infinite was in the sky and now he's
going to space right it's really cool so
that was another big standout for me
um
look uh steel and I blew up on our uh
live stream about this when we were
trying
armor core six oh yeah listen you don't
understand again people are going to be
shocked they're gonna be some people who
don't even know that from ever did a
Mech game before and it was Niche at the
time the fact that they're coming back
with this and there's an article from
Kotaku six years ago where Miyazaki
actually confirmed that they had started
work on Arma Corps but a lot of people
with the Dark Souls you know really
gaining so much popularity and now
obviously with element ring taking it
through the stratosphere right that they
would ever go back to armor core again
but they are and so this was a huge one
for me
um and like I said there's a million of
them but the last one uh again one more
because this is the Golden Age of gaming
right now as I always say right uh
horror genre is getting their come-ups
um they are blowing up but the one that
I've been asking for the one that Mavs
has been asking for is RT is to come
back to console and we are starting to
see the return Company of Heroes 3
getting the console announcement oh my
God that's a personal favorite of mine
huge not for everybody I don't care
that's right I can't wait it's for me
it's for me and it's the return of rts's
so yeah that's where I'll give you the
listing again there's a million more
yeah but
um as far as Xbox yes this is what they
have yeah yeah this is listen this was
an asset I'm in the boat let's put it
this way because there's different camps
I'm in the boat that this was the minute
they signed the ABK deal they signed a
lot of business decisions over to the
attorneys the attorneys don't care the
attorneys don't care about Optics they
don't care about the fans they care
about winning okay and so I think when
they sign this deal these decisions were
made because obviously qe's got to plan
this stuff out way in advance they had
to make decisions I'm almost I'm I'm at
the point where I think the attorneys
probably were saying you can't do a
showcase and and obviously
I'm sure Phil and everybody's like are
you kidding us we can't do that to the
fans that's why they came up with the
12-month thing so I think this was
pre-planned does it look bad I think so
yes obviously especially the year that
they've had
the ABK deal has taken there all the
momentum they've had and slowed it way
down you're gonna love the poll question
yeah
not to see Xbox there when they and
again people say well you know the game
awards aren't that they're not the it's
not the number one show listen come on
Microsoft themselves had come out and
said how important the game awards are
and they've shown that by announcing the
series X by show it Off hellblade 2
Perfect Dark they know what the kiwis do
for them as far as advertising go so
again to see you know to see the Sony
Awards Show sponsored by Samsung Xbox
game pass like that oh it was pretty
tough right pretty tough very slanderous
yes I know sir I know sir but but my
final point would be and I said this
during our live stream code stream with
them is that if XBox has something
planned if this now all the cards are on
the table now they know which way the
FTC is going you know there's nothing
business has to move forward at some
point so I said if they have something
planned for January or early February
this will all be forgotten no it's not
going to be be the same level as the
game awards you're not going to have as
many eyes on you you're going to have
Xbox fans whereas you know with the game
awards you get other eyes that may not
go watch an Xbox show see something that
they like that's why the power of the
game awards is there but I think that
that is the plan and obviously Greenberg
you know hinted at that through his
tweet that we're not gonna have to wait
too soon or no too long
um and that timing is key and I think
that was what he was pointing out so now
the smoke is January February we're
going to get something from Xbox I
expect that to be an XO type event I
think we're gonna get release dates for
um you know probably redfall for sure
star feel I think does get a release
date Motorsport is the one I'm still
wavering on whether or not we see it in
that in that first half just because of
turn 10 starting polishing in January
and all that kind of stuff but I think
we will get an Excel event uh type event
and I think there are going to Showcase
not only the first party but the third
party because the first half 2023 is
lined up to be that between first party
and third party starting right out the
gates with of course another favorite of
mine age Empires too Definitive Edition
coming out right away so I think that's
where they're going with it so yes it
was a disappointment not to see Xbox
there but for me again I look at overall
show I saw a ton of third party coming
to Xbox which was great to see some
games that I you know previous
generation we may not have gotten on
Xbox but that shows the momentum they
have and I so I was excited about that
congratulations another year dominating
year running us out the building on the
game boys the picks and just just
vintage masterful performances always I
came close
just I don't know man yeah yeah
the year before they was closer than me
so normally well the year before they
won today yeah yeah they did yeah they
didn't get the way yeah please don't
please don't don't try to take away my
win my bad my bad you did you do have a
title back all the time you you you sir
are the winless one yeah you had to put
that out there like that yeah do all
that that's extra I think I did sorry
he's in the dojo though
so yeah like Eddie's standing out so far
as game wise and then obviously the big
talk you know Xbox's presence yeah
so I think overall like just to to say
you know point out what uh what pong was
talking about initially is that yeah I
think you know Kelly seemed to have
listened to the criticisms of past shows
and and done things to fix that and I
think immediately from the off the bat
that was shown obviously Christopher
Judge took all that out of time hey you
know and I was I was like dude wow he's
really it's up there talking and just
you know it sounded like a therapy
session I was like yo what's going on
here but you know they let him Rock for
as much as he possibly could and he
didn't let him do anything that dude he
took off yeah yeah yes he took that
because I think I think Keely was
flabbergasted and then yeah you see them
stepping up on stage
yeah so um and then therefore the rest
of the show had to be sort of rushed a
little bit and this is what happens but
again he took people he took criticism
in the heart and I and I love that
because he's evolving it with the
community so I that that's amazing to
see
um in terms of things that I saw that
were really exciting and we do right off
the bat like dead cells with Castlevania
so if if you want to talk about a game
that has the feel of Castlevania the
tightness of that gameplay it's a dead
cells and now you're incorporating these
two listen man oh oh my Lord I was like
wait a minute this is crazy then we get
vampire Survival on mobile yeah oh yeah
it's crazy yeah I mean those things
really again it just it blew me away
little things again like seeing a new
Valiant Hearts I love that first Valiant
Hearts
um and then like after that
the thing that really you know I was
like oh my goodness was replaced oh man
you keep stealing my stuff the place is
crazy places
Blade Runner Vibes cyberpunk Vibes
brutal oh my God that looks so good yeah
I've been following that game for how
many years yeah bro it's been what two
or three years since we saw a game show
the last time I saw was at the PC show
yeah it replaced Street Fighter 6
looking amazing again I just I can't
wait to place you fight or six oh DJ DJ
yeah yeah there you go and then like
pong said bro Hades too Hades to me
along with dead cells is is a goated
game like that that's one of the greats
and to see that come back and then break
protocol and just go to go to a sequel
it shows what Hades did for them guys
um good point and but again MO most of
their games are very successful so to
see what Hades must have been another
level and it was it was but they had
more story to tell they did they had
more story to tell and that once again
they're building I know you don't like
this King but they're building it with
the community yeah well there's nothing
wrong with it I don't have to
participate yeah exactly I don't I wait
for them I wait for 1.0 that's what I do
you you pay me and I'll participate
you're not paying me I will wait to pick
it up when it's done when it's done
exactly so that
um and just like I get pong and I are of
the same mind of a lot of things when I
saw ghost story games and we I I've been
I talked about it in an interview this
year that Cog and I had although about a
little bit well I was like I've been
waiting so long for Ken Levine's next
game and to finally see it again there's
no guarantee it's coming next year
they're just showing it we might not see
this game for five years no I can't
believe
um I was super excited I was a little
underwhelmed that it was like really he
just made Bioshock again like I was like
it took me I was like all this time and
you're making Bioshock again I get it
that's his baby that's really where he
elevated to another level
um I'm glad to hear that the narrative
Lego stuff is still intact and this and
this is where this is going to really be
differentiated from other games because
again he's a genius and he's very
difficult to work with he admittedly has
said that he's not a good manager he's
he's just he is an auteur that's what
that is what he is so I'm excited to see
what this is and if it really and if I
were the guys at 2K make it the next
Bioshock oh my oh yeah oh yeah let's
hope this game doesn't come out in four
years yeah we're gonna watch out crazy
yeah it was nice to see the Cameron
Conroy dedication and that is Suicide
Squad that was a nice touch that was
that that was great yeah I'm gonna be
honest I was a little underwhelmed by
Jedi Survivor no no it just didn't look
next
same Jenny like say me yeah I'm gonna
play it I know it's gonna be fantastic
but it did look DLC
it did not again
what's your opinion
next chat
that looks so good
and that don't be a surprise what the
next thing that really kind of Boom I'm
excited for
is that well we'll have a Space Marine
too yes wow
Space Marine one is amazing so good
right but beyond that I gotta say man
that Final Fantasy 16.
that's the only thing they can do well
it feels like I mean again I'm hearing
all of this talk about you know it's
it's it's it it this is the game that's
supposed to try to unseat ff6 like as
it's as the goal summer will hold up so
I I'm very interested right I'm very
interested and beyond that I know I've
seen we've seen preview coverage during
the course of the week for this but at
Diablo oh almost oh yes yes
okay
it was crazy there was games at the show
y'all they need to announce that for
console though yes
yo I'll tell you again if you're a fan
of the old Baldur's Gate to be a fan of
divinity if you're a fan of ice Wendell
Baldur's Baldur's Gate three is is
taking that to the
yeah bro so I'ma be honest yo I think
Keely was on it this year yeah
phenomenal strong 8.75 almost nine yeah
I really like he did a very good job oh
let's not mention like I'm not a monster
hunter dude but that wild card so long
and it came back
yeah he was able to come back
yo that's so crazy because we we still
on and off right for his topic dude
exactly so uh I mean even the wild
hearts and I'm not I'm not a monster
hunter dude but that looks like it's
something I might want to try Okay
um and then the Microsoft missing
I I found it weird there was nothing
that that they felt like they should
just excite people over man I mean they
they they they they they showed us the
series X and they showed us
yeah pong went and I'm the second one
yeah yes plenty
um
it was just weird and I know they have a
lot to show and again if they stick to
what they said that by the end of June
we're gonna have three first party games
out according to them so special dick
said it's Monday morning in Australia
crazy we know good too so
it was weird to me not to show something
man just something to excite the masses
something you can't talk when you're
trying to win man yeah
I don't know something give me something
we're trying to win and I'll say this
though if they didn't have anything
gameplay watch the show for something
new and it was just going to be a
trailer
I didn't know I'm fine with it if there
was some gameplay available from
something we haven't seen or just you
know they they mentioned briefly and
this would be the first time we see
gameplay they should have done that just
to excite people hey the sizzle reel had
10 extra seconds of like Starfield of
Starfield yeah yeah they showed this is
a real multiple times yep yes they want
to remind they want to remind people
that certain games are associated with
Xbox uh you know day one game pass like
you know they show lies of P but it's
like you know we talk about when they
show lines of people but stuff like that
where you have to remind people hey this
is a Game Pass day one game and stuff
like that where it'd be very easy for
somebody who doesn't know but like oh
that's PlayStation yeah PlayStation you
know I mean so they need to reiterate
those things
um but yeah it was weird not to show
anything at all it was just weird
Lord addict your thoughts get stand
outside game awards and
Xbox's presence
uh I thought the game awards was a solid
game awards I actually thought it was
the best one I've seen them put on you
liked it when we did that I felt like
the the announcements were solid the
pacing was solid uh you know even with
uh Chris stepping out of pocket I didn't
even mind that too much
um yeah you actually defended him I
remember that yeah yeah because I think
the reason I defended him too much is
because like it didn't seem like it
seemed like the dude was literally just
like losing his mind on there like it
just how emotional he was winning that
award so it's just like look you know
don't don't let him do it again would
you like let him get his balls off okay
yeah he was with it and what I thought
was funny that music was playing they
had to they wrap it up be music and they
had dudes on side they was just added to
his talk though like I'm still going it
was beautiful yeah yeah yeah
so I really wanted to hit it yeah I mean
but let's not take away from the fact
also that he shouldn't have won that
thank you oh yeah no I mean he shouldn't
have he should have won that I was happy
I was one of my pictures
looked at him like oh really I don't
know
I thought I was gonna like have a lot of
it's gonna be like really hard to like
keep up with like who gets what points
but Cog is very clear oh no who did that
yeah okay okay what did we vote for yeah
I wanted to win so bad and I was
watching I was like
you know what's funny looking at his
score they were just they were just like
one or two things if called would have
changed she could have won like one or
two things with his heart though shut up
God bless him yeah I know anytime and
then y'all say I'm going with my heart
on this one I'm like but there is why I
would jump it is one that I am I am so
proud of I got a break protocol shout
out to as does fall shout out to Carolyn
Marshall of the team I was so proud that
when that Joy came through bro home girl
she did that you know what I'm saying
and like for people that played that
game yeah they know what it is that is
one of the most impactful storytelling
real life issues and Cooperative with a
override mechanic you play with family
you play with friends a significant
other that is one of their best tires I
was so proud to see that I was like I
know her you interviewed the house but
my heart that's the first time one of my
heart picks won
that one time
yeah
shout out to me giving Horizon forbidden
West too much problems thinking that
they were gonna snatch some things
you know I lost a bunch of that because
because of like okay you know they can't
get they're not gonna just not give
Horizon nothing yes they are yeah I was
surprising that was definitely
surprising so what about yeah the Xbox
part too
uh look I I don't mind them not being
there is like Logistics as long as
they're gonna actually have like their
own event or something you know for
years I've actually been saying them for
them to like maintain their own stuff
and do their own show
um I I do feel like even if
they do their own show they could have
showed like like a seed thieves
expansion or or like an Elder Scrolls
Online expansion something like not give
your best bars with some balls yes uh
because I feel like you not being there
it kind of makes me think maybe that you
know I conspiracy and tin foil hat thing
how do you go from being there so strong
to not being there at all it kind of
makes me think that maybe Something's
Happened and there's a reason they're
not there now I I you know me I I'm not
gonna go out there and say like this
beat between like Microsoft and like
that organization but it's just like how
do you go from announcing your Xbox
series X to nothing now nothing uh I I
do personally feel like there's a
scenario where
they got so much they need to announce
that they couldn't announce them all
there then they were just like look like
we need to announce Forza we need to
announce redfall with a release date for
the release date Starfield with a
release date and they probably got like
a little bit of little stuff they just
like
obviously he's not gonna let us do all
of that there so if we have to
if if we can't do all of it there we
need to just do none of it there because
yeah it's like one of those things it's
like we're already gonna have to make an
event in like February because of all
this stuff right why give him some of
our best bars here when we already have
to do it there uh but it's just like
even if it was that case and I think
that's probably a good chance it was
that you could you could have gave them
something small like something small I
think just to say that you're there but
it was disappointing that they wasn't
there in any way shape or form like you
know and you know shout out to Phil for
sitting through uh three hours of some
stress
they put the camera
I don't think he wanted that camera no
yeah so here's the conspiracy theory
version of this right what are we doing
could it be you just finished getting
announced that you were going to get
sued by the FTC for taking games away
from other people it's maybe not the
best thing to announce three exclusive
games yeah well here's the thing the
reason I don't think it says because
this isn't like these are brand new
exclusives and no one's heard about
these like yeah
I get that but the FTC news these games
are coming yeah like at this point the
damage has been done it's not like
you're gonna put the the the Pandora's
stuff right back in the box like we knew
these games are out there now if they
came back there and they show brand new
exclusives at the of the stuff that they
bought then that would be one thing but
it's just like the part that just
doesn't make sense to me I don't I heard
it like two weeks ago they weren't going
to be at the uh
so I I don't think it's that I think
that something happened maybe you know
there might be some kind of shape of
maybe a game is too like is on like the
borderline and they don't want to come
out and actually say it's coming out if
it's not coming out maybe it's one of
those scenarios where you know they just
it's like I said to not be there at all
makes no sense to me because
yeah it's not even just the biggest
station it's like you you announced your
Xbox series X here how do you go from
announcing nothing here
and that's why it makes me feel like
maybe there was some like like something
happened in the past year where they
felt like okay you know this isn't a
valid platform for us to announce stuff
on anymore because even if they were
doing their own thing how are you not
going to show up at all yeah it makes me
think there's there's something more
going on if you're not going to be there
at all
imagine being like Phil and Sarah Bond
sitting in that crowd
having all these games be announced but
you have nothing there have all these
like Game of the Year nominations but
you don't have nothing in the
nominations really like and you know
what's crazy whoever is pamming that
that camera back and forth you should be
ashamed of yourself because there's no
reason
for Phil to be on that screen so many
times but oh every there's a couple of
times when God of War won an award they
paid it to fail oh wow that's crazy that
was dirty that's crazy yeah I mean look
let's get to a King where you at seem to
be making your uh stance on Xbox before
we get into that the games as well well
um yes I I
um I'm here to thank every everyone
um King judge
I would like to start off with my
brother I took that uh
[Music]
not the dramatic breathing in pauses for
emphasis
not that cake no remember King he talked
to atraeus so talk to someone like you
talked to the moment the moment the
moment I heard my name being announced
oh Lord
I need to be man
you know what's sad he's doing a really
good job dude I can't stand the game
awards right you'll always be that you
know why why you don't like it it has
okay forget about Jeff I don't like any
award shows damn because it because you
can't tell me
what's hot you can't tell me what's hot
I can tell you what's hot because I can
play it I can say it and I can feel it
and I can say this is me this is what's
hot to me right I'm not I'm not a I'm
not a dude that needs to be in a group
to feel me I
see a lot of these dudes doing their
streams and these dudes just jumping out
they see God of War One
we've made it you've made nothing
you played a game
these dudes that's that's getting like
feel good for the for the the sound
design dude that that that that one best
sound design for a game that you
appreciate it right that's my biggest
thing King like why I get it like some
of these people are high profiles you
have them up there but they're not
Gamers one individual literally come up
there said he's not a gamer and I'm just
like look like Al Pacino I get it these
are high profile persons it was a
performance thing but it's just like
there is
there's countless people I said this one
time it's like why someone like like a
profile like Snoop Dogg literally talks
about gaming 24 7. he has been on mobile
I don't want to see Snoop Dogg but but
Al Pacino I want to see the people that
make these games I don't care to see
nobody people that have no involvement
in saying this Al Pacino had nothing to
do with any of those games that was
being talked about but yeah messing it
up for everyone oh and I feel you on
that I'm just saying like if they wanted
a high profile at least like the very
least get is someone that actually plays
games like I can't make games
and go get somebody who's actually in
the industry and stop getting these
people just to have these these names
associated with your project I would
have liked what's his name to do that
played uh in um the Zelda the the Star
Wars game the the dude
he was there to just do some lightsabers
and then he just walked off like it's
like why don't you let him give an award
I hate these shows because it Grooms you
and to believe in that you're
participating in a level that you're not
mm-hmm
it forms your opinion to feel that this
game is hot I mean I fell victim to it
when I got second
all right I fell victim to it when oh
game of the year and it is it's an
influence
you go in that direction what I do like
though that it brings highlights to
video games that you probably never
heard of right and those video games you
say to yourself well it made the list
let me go check that game out
this well great Point Henry yeah yeah I
don't care for him
you should they should do the right
thing which is the previous year's
winner gives away the award to the
current yeah
he's trying to hand away the belt
it's not even that I think that like
it's hard to keep up with that many like
mini pieces and I think that they do
strategically do these like celebrities
oh what what's coming out like you know
they've had one year they had uh Vin
Diesel because even that diesel makes
sense he's literally partially the owner
of a a gaming studio the people
yeah yeah it's just it's just
frustrating that you get Al Pacino and I
get it it's for performance but like I
said there's plenty of people that game
in in that in that industry that could
have gave that award that's not him and
the fact that he went up there and said
Idol games yeah I didn't like that phone
the fact that he said I don't got I'm
sure Jeff was like man I wish you would
it said it is the rumor is that the
teleprompter he couldn't see or
something I don't know
he said I can't read the teleprompter
but that does that sounded more like a
joke than anything to me
how did you not see it when you was
doing like the practice
cards did you see you see his cards did
you see
I was able to read my house who was the
winner
he can't see man okay all right so you
have this guy that's up there that's
can't see that's freestyling and then
that's the thing he was freestyle
he doesn't even play games okay enough
of that sick and tired stuff that we're
talking about I don't care about that
um
let me get to because I'm not going to
get past this I'm not going to finish
with this obviously so uh let's get to
what I've seen yes yes
love replaced love atomic heart
um
that's what I'm saying man great games
were at this event like reactivate it
was something that intrigued me
because I had the transform his brain oh
yeah and I didn't know the splash damage
what what were they going to do with it
so I want to give them a shot even
though I that was vertical slice CGI
crap yeah we know we already know that I
hate that but again this is the first
time I'm seeing it so I'm gonna let it
go oh thank you all right
um
it was a blue protocol
um
I don't know if it's me
or is Bandai Namco
turn it into a better version of Square
Enix been talking about it for the past
over a year now King I I think they have
got a hand on the Japanese RPG
industry and they're putting out quality
titles
and it's going to be one of those titles
that's going to break that ceiling
that's going to actually be the must
play RPG and I think they have a bunch
that are in that vein you know oh you
got to play this but it's going to be
one that's going to be such a commercial
success that's going to Dethrone the
Final Fantasy and it's going to happen
at some point in time because you know
you have Dragon Warrior that that is uh
keeps pushing it but it has to be more
prevalent here in the Western World
um
that uh the the game with
um what's that Red Devil dude
um Oh you mean I know you're talking
about the Hellboy though Hellboy yeah
I love the art Direction okay I didn't
see that game coming I didn't uh pause I
didn't I didn't expect it because I
thought it was going to be a cut scene
then I saw it was actual gameplay of it
and I was like I'm so
intrigued by it Hades too of course
Diablo uh uh three I mean four of course
uh Boulder's Gate of course those games
of course is is is has me intrigued and
trained to get to the to that next level
but then it was this one game
and he was doing a cut scene it was the
dude sitting at the table and he was
talking to which I thought was his wife
and the lady was talking to him and said
oh y'all the banishers and oh y'all
Ghost Hunters it's like no we banished
him and then his wife like disappeared
and I was like oh this is a a husband
and wife team oh yeah yeah he's The
Ghost and she helps them throughout the
and it looked great it looked like I
don't know yeah that's right
yeah that game looked good yeah I
remember I said I said you know I can
watch the highlights of the show I don't
have to agree with a lot of things in
the show I know the show is necessary
people get dressed up they go out there
you're supposed to have a great time we
supposed to have this pageantry we
supposed to have this stuff but we ain't
gonna sit here and start going at my man
sitting there taking his lumps my man
showed up yeah he showed up he showed up
where was Jim I mean not to be honest
where the hell was Jim Jim wasn't there
but I mean I know because Jim don't game
he can go he's too busy
FTC and it's a CMA he's too busy
snitching that he can't go and his games
is being
up there for Game of the Year this
game's just being up there for the best
game sound design your games is being
nominated you ain't there but the dude
who ain't got no games is sitting right
there the dude you said the realest dude
in the building is sitting right there
taking the bus and we ain't got no games
but I'm here what up man I don't think
anybody hold it real quick I don't think
anyone was saying that like you know
like clowning on him for being there I
just think it was a rough experience it
wasn't what real dudes do is they sit
there and they take their lumps I want
to feel this right here because I never
want to feel it again and if you take
the console if you take the console
stuff out of it King like he had every
reason to be there too because it's like
just because like I get it with all this
stuff going on
that's that's when you snitch and you
don't show your face how you gonna have
all your stuff represented but you ain't
there it could have been but my man was
in he was there he was he was dead
anyway any way you wanted they've been
going at it they've been dropping
freestyle yeah but somebody there's a
job at this record East Coast West Coast
but it was easy for Phil not to be there
right
for them not to pan over him not to be
not to have sex
but real dudes do real things this is
why I roll with them I feel like right I
feel that
and then someone else said not to
interrupt you because you're on fire
with this because someone did say at the
show like he's a class act because he
not only stood there he talked to bad
people asking questions and let's be
honest like you said this is really one
of the worst weeks in Xbox yeah so for
him to go there to face the music that's
real mad stuff you know what I'm saying
at the end of the day regardless of how
you feel about Xbox as a company
regardless how you feel about first
party out with they not doing the right
thing or whatever but as a man he didn't
have he couldn't use any excuse in the
book and everybody would have been okay
with him not being there but to be
honest with you I'll give you that we
will probably like look down on him more
if he didn't show up it's like you need
to tell me this is It's not like a place
to it'd be different if you went to a
Playstation experience you know what I'm
saying it's like you didn't go to a a
gaming event celebrating games like
because you know it's like I said that
outside the console industry there's no
reason for him not to go you know what
I'm saying like and the fact that he
went regardless even though that you
know people be like yo I'm sure that's
rough like it it's good because it made
like he values to celebrate the games
over what's going on in his business
with other people what
a real dude does
and some some of you guys are actually
gonna experience this one day um
you don't run away from the emotion of
the situation
you basking it be it good or be it bad
he knew going there not having no games
a phenomination in any category
is going to be bring scrutiny to him he
knew this
forehand
got suited up and went
Delilah said Bowser was there Phil was
there Kingston why why
they're pounding to him when other
awards has been won and yo none of your
games is up there okay yeah it's
actually you know I'm I'm with king
that's even worse like your games are up
there and you're not even there like
he's so the thought process
yeah we probably have some stuff to put
in in a real and this stuff is gonna go
no
we hold it till next year we're gonna
hold our own event
this this is not gonna happen next year
next year
have the same cameras shrinked on my man
yeah but I don't care I don't care but
you the work is Gonna Come okay have
these same camera strength on my man
next year when Starfield is out when red
fall is out when forces out and whatever
other games hit and you have no choice
but to include them into your little
show
because the cutoff point last year was
what point for Halo
so why Halo was enough for any uh Awards
should have been included right
it didn't make it last year so it
couldn't make the cut this year right
all right
I walked away very very happy
from the show I thought the show looked
great I watched it through you guys eyes
I had fun listening in the Attic
defending Chris I had fun listening in
the Attic saying damn solving still
isn't it this is ridiculous and I want
everybody to really give addict respect
because at it yeah he set that up put
together that whole tally thing yeah it
took him hours to get it right and he
got it right and he executed his
objective he's probably one of the
hardest working dudes that probably you
guys don't know what he's doing but he's
doing that he's working always
very hard all right so if y'all love
that format you love what you saw yeah
it was fire that was entertaining to me
it was way more entertaining than the
the game awards show because I don't
care I can go to sleep and I can wake up
later but he made it into a fun process
and I loved it and I appreciate you yeah
um
the last thing
I am so happy God of War lost
this I am okay you should have saw the
chat after you go to the chat
did some fraudulent stuff they would it
was a funeral it would have been you
would have been proud of of kids smooth
like you bro dudes was popping by you
could have told me how everybody was
XBox exclusive the way it is it was
popping off because they they they they
sealed that casket and threw them away
and we're not gonna see him no more it's
over it's gone and the best part of it
is
popping bottles Alden ring didn't win
nothing and God Wars out his slain it's
gonna be a sweep sweep yourself
DLC was not winning game of the year now
if it was the best DLC of the year
but elding King came out and
and I told you before but but it doesn't
look as next-gen as God would God will
look it looked like a PlayStation 4
exclusive
ring rocked this box
[Music]
god of war came out and it was a very
good quality game but Elder and ring
came out and it shut down the industry
like I've never seen that about a
coverage and that amount of people
talking about one game for that long but
attic they tried to slip a banana in a
tailpipe they tried to get him through
the door you know who messed it up who
you know who messed it up cause God is
Chris it was Chris
I I like to think
they didn't want him to come back on
stage you know everybody even the
grocery store man who brought my
that's what happened
to them and they was talking to them
they said listen here God of War was
going to win but elderly
I want to thank Chris for running your
mouth and uh wearing the gold suit thank
you so much I appreciate it you was
passionately uh overbearing so God bless
have a great day and uh shout out to
Elder ring game of the year
wait
[Laughter]
a minute I get my buzz up this is a
crazy little show yeah um the show is
phenomenal I thought it was a great
celebration games I think overall we got
to give I've had my issues obviously
with the way certain things with the way
the show is running it's a lot of stuff
but I think he did listen to legit
feedback
um look
technique I don't care what the white
second eight came out baby that Unreal
Engine five was looking glorious June
Kazama is back from Tech to Tekken
three-story amazing I can't wait to see
what they do with the The Saga father
versus son because it looked like Jude
took an L in the beginning and then like
Jay took an L in the beginning and June
had to come back to get her get boo get
her set up because yeah because we is
outside so we got you know what surprise
me there that Suicide Squad yes that
looked really good it was him in the
flash up it was kind of kind of
hilarious
um Street Fighter six again look good
he's pushing me against the walls yeah
stop that stop moving stop moving
because I like that they going against
the superheroes it's kind of funny so um
yeah Street Pharmacy looks good DJ I
like the colorful art style fighting
game community stand up it's great to
see two fighting games showing shining
come on I'm Destiny I know Dusty too
light falls outside I was happy to see
the stranded traversal really like we
got some Insomniac Spiderman thing going
on we got some strand things we can hang
people up and do all this thing with the
new powers look like a substantial
expansion
Diablo oh Diablo was looking I already
seen the game playing the gameplay
impressed me so to see this kind of
cinematic story it looked really intense
production value they look like the bag
has been dropped it's ready to go
gotta disagree with solve Shadow falling
I'll be Jedi survival
to me he didn't like Jedi survival he
did not like this video
bro DLC Dad shut up I mean I'm gonna
play it out and the stuff that I saw the
lightsabers that's cool you're gonna do
this on my time listen
we gonna put respect or respond we're
gonna put respect on Patrick ran we
gonna put respect or Vincent palette and
God got them thinking about single
player games and making money I can't I
could see what where sauce coming from
we're not listening to his Landing right
now it's not a giant joke I'm playing it
yeah
but look dismemberment that they know
they got a formula I'm so hot and to see
the dude come out you know that that
plays the main character you know do his
little thing it promoted that was a cool
little touch I'm with solvo Final
Fantasy 16 though oh good lord good Lord
that looked amazing can't I'm not with
you guys oh you're not feeling it you're
not feeling it I I you wait and see I
don't know is it about like Final
Fantasy 15 they spent a lot of time and
a lot of focus on the sums and I think
it impacted the rest of the game but
that's all I'm gonna say because I know
we've been live forever for me I'm I
like the way the potatoes go I like what
the cinematics is going I like where the
Summers is going shout out to
PlayStation for putting that exclusivity
at the end let you know you're not
seeing this for a whole year you better
come over here
shout out to the passing pettiness
um what else replace yes King yes yes
that that's it I'm all the way live with
that joint shout out cyberpunk got
Striker Bell y'all
and that is the DLC that's gonna
probably lock me in yeah yeah they got
strength they got strings I saw a string
of bell and I saw a little bit more with
uh this guy with Neil I was like okay
pandemic
[Music]
Levine wow Judas yeah wow Judas oh my
God that look different yeah I'm saying
man it was a phenomenal not a good
phenomenal it looked great it didn't
look different
great show and again my little personal
thing because Xbox did win an award I
mean right that two don't look a whole
lot different the Red Dead one but you
go
you are absolutely this horses
the iron bank is gonna send you to the
eye doctor
yeah that gave me the 90s feel it got to
have Michael Madison I need to see more
though I need to know if the game will
be good FPS yeah yeah I like the vibe
yeah the vibe was dope
oh there's a game I keep forgetting and
I Gotta Give Microsoft again as the
Falls so proud of y'all so proud of
y'all interior night do your thing ready
for this evil all right number two
um they showed it again ever and y'all
know Cog don't like being the older guy
at the playground playing no kid games
and party animals I'm in I am and they
doing terroristic stuff the cute things
and it's throwing dudes in the oven and
it's wow like that game look phenomenal
I I can't fret party animals every time
they show it I'm die laughing it looked
like it could be a Fall Guy situation
going on I mean I mean I need to know
what's going on with that I love the way
they Market because they don't take it
theyself seriously okay let's get to the
Smoke Xbox all right
yeah I gotta come to the foot of the
congregation
listen okay I'm with you he's a g for
showing absolutely real Mentor I give
you that
the only mindset I could think is that
for you to not have any Presence at the
biggest game awards
the only thing I could think is one you
already have something planned between
now and E3 because you can't show these
three games at E3 go hey guys you know
what I'm saying you can't just drop a
Twitter post and say hey what you call
it what you call this out uh red falls
out you can't you have to promote these
right yep so that either has to be the
bat and then the other thing I gotta be
honest like
maybe there was a mindset because here's
the thing
the week they had right let's just go
into let's do revisionist history let's
say the deal goes through
now Phil strolls in
crash bandicoots on stage right now the
Xbox thing oh that's ours right Call of
Duty oh that's ours yeah Diablo 4. oh
that's all it's a different conversation
right so there's a part of me not saying
that he's not a man about because he
still show up even after he knew the
deal wasn't going through that right
still showed up so there's a part of me
that goes man this the whole narrative
changes if this deal goes through right
he comes from a position of strength
that's that's the sole reason they
trying to cancel it so now the problem I
have
you have set the precedent you have said
by your actions the game awards are more
valuable than your own show you have
debuted the console the series X there
you showed hellblade you show hellblade
again you show Perfect Dark you have
shown that this stage because of who it
is and let's be honest it is valuable
because even if you do an Xbox show
that's only Xbox fans really going to go
to that you need to go and put your
joint on the eyes that has the most
people so people like oh Nintendo fan or
something like oh yo that look kinda you
know what Xbox I might be interested in
that it that that's why it's
disappointing you know what I'm saying
and here's the other thing we we after
the fact you go oh stay tuned guys but
here's the problem the bass is already
at its lowest again this is like 2020
when the consoles drop 2020. when the
series that drop right 2020 yeah
remember the energy yo no first party
game games at launch y'all what's going
on right you got to do something to get
the base up right yeah it didn't happen
too long ago either exactly now 2021 I
don't care what nobody say 2021 was a
phenomenal year for Xbox first party
yeah you know what I'm saying We're Not
Gonna Act Like That gear did not exist
you had psycho now you had Forza you had
Halo you had Age of Empires you had
Microsoft flight simulator I'm not into
all this Purity talking who had what
those games launched on the platform and
they were good and they won Metacritic
publisher together they've proven that
with a proper Cadence and when things
come out they can execute right now we
get to this [ __ ] it's a disaster we
gotta call it what it is like I'm not
liberal like no first party triple A
right no disrespect the pediment no
disrespect the grounded we love it
amazing but from a triple A standpoint
you're not present Lieutenant wasn't AAA
we're not going to do that stop it so
what I go dig is you've got to give the
you got this base is beaten down again
you've got to reinvigorate you got to
get the energy back up you got to read
the room that's why it's disappointing
to me that you don't have anything and
this is the last one I'll say this is
why I was against what everybody was
like yo I like the E3 format just the 12
months no I don't like it because what
you do is you set this hard Line in the
Sand and then there's no hope for the
future there's no showing you what's in
the Horizon there's no oh my God why
your competition is right over that you
can't you can't do that so that's where
I'm disciplined is it like
look you showing the repeat of The Game
Pass ads and the Samsung it just it's
not a good look to me you know what I
mean so all I would say is yes I do
think they're probably most likely going
to have a show but they just put more
pressure on themselves that's what they
think you know what I forget about all
that stuff you just said talk to me next
week behind Life come out
right back in the mix you but their job
is to win over people who skeptical of
Xbox and all this does is feed into that
narrative that yo they don't know how to
Market yo what are they doing and that's
what we trying to get away from you know
what if Sovereign is right okay
what if Sovereign is right in the fact
that they said yo nah we ain't gonna
show nothing we're gonna hold this back
so set the expectation by letting people
know that there's a show coming still or
say hey guys just to get you don't
expect our presence they've done this
before yeah
go crazy they should have made a tweet
that was like thank you like all they
would have to do is say look we're not
going to be at the Video Game Awards and
then launch the date that they're
actually going to do this
with with telling the Xbox dudes that
were hoping that something would be
shown they did it okay remember with the
third party expectation they got dragged
with the third party showcase and then
they had to come out and say for the
next show this this that this they've
done it before so they could have easily
said so people because people come let's
be honest after that deal got they got
sued the Xbox Community is like yo bro
you better do something
get me hype about something and then
let's be real here uh
we were setting people's expectations
better than they was yeah
yeah there's a potential that their
presence was kind of low
I felt like well maybe they stink
something out because they've done that
before where they've done their own
switches
right yeah just show something
okay then you lean into your joint
that's it
nobody just because of the Year this
year has been for them this has just
been one of the worst weeks bro you had
the 70 games you had the FTC block then
you got the low Presence at the awards
you had no yeah you just put more
pressure on yourself and I just want
these games to be great and succeed so
that's really what I want to just pile
on but that's just how I felt about it
but yeah other than that but as far as
games you're a fan of games that show
was fire like yeah exactly no doubt
about it but that's all I got I never
went crazy
one last piece of smoke I'm sorry and
this yeah I apologize in advance for
this but it bothered please apologizing
in advance this ain't good this ain't
good it bothered me I don't know I'm
gonna mute myself most anticipated game
when they mentioned Hogwarts Legacy
the entire industry like a hive mine
Borg stayed quiet right and I'm just
tired of the hypocrisy when it comes to
what games we choose to Railroad or not
for whatever reasons you got to tell me
you're gonna allow you're gonna
purposely railroad this game because
that's what they're doing in a railroad
this game because of JK Rowling oh the
politics and you're and you're gonna
allow this game with how many however
many people work so hard on this this
beautiful looking game
they've stated multiple times that that
you know they you they're using her work
they obviously it's based on her work
but this is all stuff they've created
like and you as an industry they've
decided they're gonna railroad this mind
you when I say hypocrisy
when Yoshi P came out with this BS
reasons why there's no black people in
Final Fantasy XV yeah nobody said
anything nobody said I ain't playing
that game
yeah I'm tired of the hypocrisy do your
damn job and shut up that's it I'm tired
I'm tired I'm so tired of the soap boxes
we choose to stand on and then very
selective very selective when there's
certain issues that just happen across
the board and if it's not but if it's
not the game you care about or or if you
determine that is something is more
egregious than something else so one
other thing is cool that's it like I
said I apologize in advance
because it feels like come February when
that game comes out
we're going to see Silence from a lot of
big outlets and when ff16 comes out it's
not going to be the same and we saw the
same thing happen to our boys over at uh
at War Horse right yeah yeah that was
that was another one yeah exactly
preacher so I'm just tired of hypocrisy
just do your damn job and and talk about
the games and keep it to the games and
then trust me your job just becomes a
hell of a lot easier respect that's it
not respect get them I figure points off
good points good points yeah that's all
I got man I thank you for another uh
phenomenal show y'all we guys are 20
hours poll questions
you want me to pull first while you get
the supers or Jim Ryan there weren't too
many supers
and he's not going to no shows yeah he
wasn't there he wasn't there okay hold
on yeah
I wasn't in the club either
[Music]
minimal Presence at this year's game
awards which mindset do you closely
align with the choices are a a b k deal
and the FTC can debate investigation
puts Xbox in a tough position to
Showcase plans might like that one B
inexcusable to show not show anything
upcoming at Gaming's biggest event C
utilize your own Xbox show at the top of
2023 to Deep dive into new titles or D I
don't care I just know I'm tired of
waiting for next year shout out to all
the people Rock the vote is going up on
Twitter iron Lord podcast Twitter go
appreciate the feedback there so we got
the chance ready yeah I hope I didn't
miss something but
[Music]
um
because I have have I wanted I have a JD
gamer that ends my list here and then
jumps to another JD gamer I don't know
if I missed something in between but
okay all right let me go okay rubber
knob five dollar Super Chat did you all
see the young guy who snuck up on stage
at the end of the show yeah
real quick let me just get well I forgot
yeah real quick
um with that situation like low-key
they're very lucky because at the end of
the day you know Tassie made a good
point dude came up there with a big coat
God forbid
Phil everybody up in there and they go
crazy that's a learning experience that
from a security standpoint they've got
to tighten that up that could have went
a whole different way y'all I know it
was funny we had the memes we had the
dog so it's kind of crazy here it was so
crazy that guy was able to get up there
and we could be talking about a whole
whole different situation let off in
that crowd and kill all of our Legends
or some of our Legends isn't that happen
to Dave Chappelle factual we gotta do
better so I think
yeah we dodged a bullet Gaming Community
we have to do better with the security
we got to protect our Legends factual I
just I wanted to say that they didn't
let a lot of Pearson with her sword yeah
they can't let these dudes run up you
gotta have greater Security on the stage
five yeah yeah uh then we have Mr
Nichols two dollar Super Chat yeah
I don't know how you got that name yeah
Mr Nichols oh my God all right two
dollar Super Chat uh you can't drop
prices when you got the US government
against you wow then we got Tire
casaurus three dollar Super Chat do you
think Xbox will show up for the dice
Awards we'll see we'll see we got Dorian
Gray
he will Phil outside you know how he do
Dorian Gray two dollars I just want to
say Seafood Bayonetta three FTW yeah
Let's uh bay another game that's why
it looked like a mini game you'd play on
another game yeah don't look nice yes
Bayonetta three is is nice and all but
I'm sorry
come on yeah continue
let's go hold on one second I apologize
One Moment you're good that you saw
taking care of business take care of
business real quick then it showed up
dinner showed up or something the food
came through I gotta wait all right I
don't know where he was at so um I'm
gonna see if I can try to pick up I got
it I got it I just had because wifey
wife is assuming we're done
she went out so she doesn't know okay um
okay I want to say yeah or Donald Taco
should you fly to six smoking on that
Tekken eight pack in 2023.
I don't know man we'll see we're doing
looking like Tekken 7.5 and weeks
showing but I I know y'all catboy is
you talking about that little QT cartoon
two bosses do they soak up that
environment he's never gonna feel that
again oh y'all gave him the energy to
never feel that pain that hurt again we
don't have anything in this down he
taking notes
when next year come through sound design
voice acting oh they always will be
doing and he gonna come back with the
same thing and he's gonna look at you
and he's gonna say what about now what
about there what's good now all that
yeah we got nothing here we got nothing
to show what up I'll let you go see what
happens then we got uh JD gamer remember
for two years two dollars ten dollars
which excuse me I'm late but Sony is
done block blocking this deal and it
will be bad for you PlayStation 70
dollar 70 billion will be spent on for
on just being petty and you'll never
again get a third party
sure we'll see what happens
remember for two years five dollars Xbox
has got too many studios to to Big up
the game Wars now expect them to launch
their own Metals uh their own Microsoft
game awards Jeff is done with his
PlayStation loving butt how they gonna
do their old Awards with just they win
punctuation please
don't be doing the Xbox it was with
Jessica and you know what's funny how
are you going to realistically be biased
on that oh for the best Xbox
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this year I wonder if it was because it
was all PlayStation stuff so Microsoft
decided not to play the role of Charlie
Brown anymore and took his games and
stayed home and looked no leaks
all right you going all the way with it
because Microsoft is pretty bad at
leaking stuff that is true we usually do
yeah
I don't know Taco five dollars to
protect did Xbox suddenly delay all 40
plus Game Pass games 20 exclusives six
first party games
oh our Gamers being entitled again I'm
taking receipts that's right that's your
dick I see you in there yeah you know I
know I know what you did
that we got dead Planet 2 live super
chat if there is a January show when do
they announce it
yep
then we got JD gamer 2.5 acquisition
talk time who will it be from Japan Sega
Capcom Bandai Namco who are we getting
who are we getting all three
of you just smacked up the FTC it's a
done deal I know once they put the FTC
in the dirt they coming for everything I
gotta be the dirt they're gonna put them
in the put them in the dirt
so I I gotta jump right to JD gamer
again I hope this is the next one that I
missed something uh JD gamer five dollar
Super Chat seventy dollar games okay pay
for it and settle down it could be 70
games 50 increase in console costs and
19. 18 a month game pass with no Day One
exclusive so it's good for now okay all
right all right what do we have next
we have drunken ninja chat shout out to
the Danny Glover and Chuck Norris game
yeah
over there
uh let's see what else we got I might
have gotten jumped let me roll back a
little bit
they're doing this on purpose yeah they
trying to keep us they they had yeah man
I would I got to go mate
Release Me release I got it I got it I
got it yeah I got a slow mo I got it
yeah okay so we got slo-mo backslap two
dollars Super Chat talk to himself
hypocrisy at its finest yes
tired of it Lucy's Augustus father JK
Rowling has nothing to do with the
Hogwarts Legacy meanwhile Yoshi p is the
director of Final Fantasy 16 and no one
held him responsible for his bull yes
it's a lot of balls in his world there's
no black people stuff yeah in his in his
total you know where dragons exist in
the real world you know and anyway they
didn't find black people yet
they didn't fight it's on the other side
of the island that's the DLC
yeah time will kicks will be a stupid
message
49.95
I can't reach out stop it
so what's the DLC Africa
here we go with a whole different black
dragon package
[Music]
good to see what y'all please
Microsoft drops a bag and co-ops and
Grammys or the Oscars and then has their
own game second getting a massage on in
the vga's rip uh Jeff imagine I'm a
Co-Op part of the Oscars this is the
Microsoft gaming part of the Oscars
over the four hour beat em up Seafood
Tekken seven was definitely better than
Street Fighter five but that made them
hungry and Tekken gonna have have to go
hard to win we'll see about this yeah
like it they each have their own
audiences
yeah we took your character and made it
hot over here
yeah I mean he made you hot what you
talking about
you even have your own game
over there to get some
Starfield release date trailer for the
Super Bowl perhaps bigger place than the
vga's for audience reach Microsoft got
the money maybe you never know that's it
we're caught up all right finally we
made it attic left came back
this is wild are we gonna find out how
many Volare pillows yes so yeah so we
can get addict punch out not super punch
we needed to play Punch Out the league
is at the top of the description use
code law 15 five pillows we get the boy
get it he's not getting past kick hippos
he gonna do three hard hours yeah and
it's not it's not regular punch out it's
a dog made a fire named Ifrit is more
real than black people I'm still looking
forward to ff16 but their statement was
nonsense yes it was you gotta get the
DLC
we gotta get a DLC Chocolate Island
[Laughter]
where they got black dragons
[Music]
where they can find you what you got
going on sir I'll uh cut my uh
record-breaking outros first yeah take a
time but uh no I'm humbled and honored
again to be a part of this uh again you
guys have been such an inspiration to so
many people including myself who do this
podcast thing and you guys are freaking
amazing with everything you do so thank
you for the invite and I'm glad I could
come during this week what a time to be
here so uh listen find me on poxel on
Xbox on Twitter you know the drill there
I'll I always post my links whatever
else
um I got Xbox Factor every once in a
while but again with work it doesn't
happen all the time p.m in the p.m on
Thursdays over a fun speculations
Channel 7 P.M Eastern six o'clock
Central Time uh Fridays Xbox ultimate
back on fun speculations channel uh 10
p.m Eastern nine o'clock Central Time
Saturday mornings that's the one we are
in Mission 1K me and my brother from
let's get them to 1K
steel hates horror games as much as I do
and he's gonna play some protocol if we
hit that one case
we got about 340 to go somewhere in that
neighborhood so please check us out
three times hours we go four now it's me
and steel we have a great time with the
chat every Saturday morning 10 a.m
Eastern put it in the channel right
there thank you so much sir and then
Saturday nights it is the shop podcast
Channel with fuzzy Belvedere we always
have a great time on Saturday nights so
that's where you can find me thank you
all again chat you are amazing as always
I've been in this chat so much I love it
I love it being here so thank you all
it's the Golden Age of gaming please get
out there enjoy it no better time to be
a gamer than right now play what you
love love what you play real soon that's
my boy right there frog so we can just
I'm so happy we finally got a chance you
know what it was good that it happened
this way because it was one of the best
shows so salute to you the history was
phenomenal
it was phenomenal and again please
support the channel links in the
description go hit them up goes go
salute all right get these super chats
and I gotta go put salt out all right
cool Google so um super soft Super Chat
we got Spartan go 17 two pound Super
Attack Just Square Enix wider audience
ain't black BS
DLC read the next one read the next one
Super Chat DLC
call herself the Coco Brothers
the Coco Brothers anyway Lord attic
where can the five people
follow me on Twitter Lord addict IOP uh
you can find me
you might completely blanked out don't
worry about it I got you adding next I
appreciate Palm for coming on uh you
know it's a good show sorry you had to
miss about an hour and a half of it
what's crazy is I I got back and I was
like guys are still
[Laughter]
worry about that yeah see you guys next
week right now it's looking like we're
gonna have a community stream next week
uh special day bottom
pillows it's gonna be mainly just you're
not celebrating what's happening unless
something crazy happens most likely
there won't be a lot of news talking
next week it'll just be like
reminiscions of the whole year no doubt
no doubt salute everybody in the chat
Lord stop what could the five people
find you thank you for doing the Lord's
work on super chess today no doubt you
can find me emptying my bladder right
about that yeah
that's it sir yeah that's it sir
absolute Lord King in the building with
the spice with the slander I love
everything that you're doing right now
yeah
I mean I guess me and you talked very
early on yes and um boy upwards and
onwards sir yeah thank you uh I told you
I thought it was a great addition with
uh you and math yes you
doing Jazz uh you and um ran outdoor and
Jazz those are the two
podcasts for some weird reason when I
fall asleep watching YouTube in the PM
and it's that they actually rotate to my
sleep so it's funny it's funny as hell
of me um for a while it was only Jess
and uh
trying to concern me
but uh thank you again for showing up
giving you a rich history and uh you
know we talking about video games uh
from the Genesis of it
you know from pong that's right all the
way to where we are right now uh guys
you can find me
combat talk with the Lord uh with the
King uh next Saturday uh where we have
Frank Martin uh fighting sorry tried to
do it this weekend uh just things didn't
work out properly so I do apologize but
I do appreciate everyone that did show
up Tuesdays 5 p.m yeah uh RNR with the
Lord me and addict talking about the the
latest movie was troll uh we we have to
put up a poll every week uh to get you
guys to participate to find out exactly
what we're going to watch right now I'm
watching a show on Netflix called
Sandman absolutely phenomenal stuff I
know the book is incredible I want to
finish up this series and then go over
to the comic books to see how authentic
they kept it but from right now from the
beginning the production value on this
show is through the roof the acting is
phenomenal and I love the law so far it
touches on a whole bunch of different
things that is uh commonplace and common
knowledge of touches stuff on the Bibles
touching stuff on entertainment it
touches stuff on ground and stuff
currently so it's very fun very
entertaining and very very easy to
follow
so y'all can catch us there and uh me
and Attica will be having a ball on
Tuesdays at 5 p.m no doubt norcognito
here again salute the parks with
everybody that came through the chat was
on fire so the 49ers 35 after the Tampa
Bay Bucks see it the smoke can go down
I'm loving it um but yeah look next
week's gonna be fun we're getting oh
just uh we're gonna do a community
stream and then oh no not the chance oh
no no sorry go ahead I'm sorry
um shout out to the Purdy looking
already better like Jeff Jimmy G but um
is Yo again appreciate everybody coming
through next week addict right we got a
special Community stream and just for
reminder next Sunday will be the last
ILP of 2022. the lawyers will go on a
little bit of a break we need to
recharge the battery coming back strong
we got a phenomenal top of the year plan
for y'all but we're gonna end it all
right we're gonna do something a little
different we'll give you more details as
we get closer yeah more pillows and yes
uh the community stream next uh week uh
I guess we'll be combo with my birthday
because it's the same day yeah
Saturdays when uh
when I'll be doing that yeah Saturday's
communities the young Wolf's birthday he
getting old he gonna play Big Dog he's
gonna play all the games he tried to
turn his camera off when Paul was
talking we're gonna get him to play Pong
Tetris
he's like
do it anyway
but uh we're gonna have some fun 45
shots
age at that day the salute to him come
show out we will do that on Saturday
it'll be the games of his choice of
course it's his birthday you get to pick
what do you want to pick and then Sunday
again last ILP of 2022 before we come
back and then we recharge everybody
enjoy you know Sunday that's all I got
we out of here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]